um before you and I don't know if
they've been handed out yet but I assume
the 608 is before you
um I uh put in there that
the department should select two but no
more than three area agencies to undergo
a pilot of what they intend to roll out
on the first of July so so go ahead and
take a subset of the community and and
and try to implement what they're in
they want to implement on a small scale
before they roll it out it's essentially
you know the look before you leap model
it's uh as a carpenter say you know
measure twice cut once so it it's just a
validation effort this is not me saying
that I don't support
to really know what I think it's going
to be but but I have been enough in the
community to listen and the area
agencies I think you're going to have a
number of them talking and number of the
community talking I think they're
generally in favor of it because they
don't uh to summarize what I think
you're going to hear they don't think
that there's enough information that
there's enough systems roll out for that
like the I.T systems and stuff for them
to really be able to effectively do
what's going to be expected of them I I
put into the legislation a very loose
disruption of a pilot project and what a
stakeholder is
um because I believe that the the
professionals at the Department of
Health and Human Services can certainly
know how to do a pilot project and put
it together so I I wanted to tell them
what they needed to do do a pilot
Project without telling them exactly how
to do it because I I think they can
figure that out
um the checkpoint in that is that
there's a great deal of transparency
about these uh meetings that are to be
held with the stakeholders and they're
to be videoed and and shared
um so that there's transparency in the
in the process some transparency that I
think many might think doesn't uh exist
in the in the BDS redesign efforts but
that's for the committee to hear the the
you'll you'll hear that
um the this a m report uh admits that a
lot of the data that they might need to
do a better plan is just missing it
didn't exist and so a bunch of
assumptions were made when you start to
do something that can affect as many
clients as this would you you really
ought to have that data and the pilot
project would get that
what I was surprised most by all of this
was the Deep cynicism about the that it
has emerged from the DD Community I you
some of you may know I was on HHS you
know three terms ago and I've been sort
of involved and I I've heard about you
know last year I helped fund stuff in
the DD community and and what this bill
has done is it's opened the door where a
number of people have called me and let
me know of their deep seething cynicism
about how the money is Flowing from
government to take care of the clients
and and and I think you're going to also
hear some testimony that uh you know we
shouldn't do a pilot project we should
just burn the whole thing down and start
over so so what I I highlight that for
you now so that I want you to remember
that what this bill is about doing a
pilot project regardless of the context
and scenarios and the history and all of
that this is just a very simple before
we roll out the whole thing let's do a
pilot project so I would ask you when
you're listening to the testimony you
you you you you keep that stuff
segregated in your mind stay focused on
the pilot project you're going to hear
that we may possibly lose hundreds of
millions of dollars from the feds if if
we don't just roll this out completely
on one July I think that's a little bit
of a smoke screen a little bit
fear-mongering
I I I CMS has already approved several
waivers for delays and I I just got to
believe that if we in good faith work
with them and say we want to implement
your program but we're going to do a
pilot project to make sure we do it
right and we don't hurt people when we
when we roll this system out I think I
think we would we would get that waiver
so so you're going to hear about the
money but I'm also going to ask you to
keep in mind that there is a finance
committee if you pass it there's a
finance committee that's supposed to be
worrying about the money and what you
all ought to be looking at is I
understand the tradition is the policy
and and I'm here asking you a policy
decision should we do a pilot project
before we roll out this great of a
change and I I think the answer is yes
so I think this bill is rational I think
every Professional Organization out
there conducts pilot projects I think
it's the it's what you know professional
project managers recommend and and it's
it happens to be what I'm recommending
as well so with that I'll take questions
if there are any okay yes representative
McLean thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so I understand
the concept of of the pilot but just
from my own edification two quick
questions if you could maybe kind of
walk us through the history what's
driving the redesign itself and second
is the pilot looking
um at
um
what the redesign is going to look like
or is it going to investigate does uh
the redesign go ahead at all or or both
so what's what's kind of the scope of
the pilot uh the first question I'm
going to give you an admittedly
partial answer there are other people
here who know the history of the
redesign efforts and what's motivated
far better than I do but I but I think
you know a lot of the stirrings started
around 2017 you know CMS wanted to come
up with a a better way to get services
to clients uh you know I believe that
the direct Bill part of it was to
basically bypass middlemen so that the
money went you know more directly to
service providers and in support of the
clients I I believe that's a lot of the
motivation and the timeline of when it
got started in New Hampshire we we spent
a pretty intense four-year period I
understand getting ready to roll
something out and we we stopped all of
those efforts when the Alvarez and
Marcel report came out and apparently
we've taken a new New Direction
completely New Direction and and again
that's why the pilot project is there
now to your other point about what is
the purpose of this pilot project
i i i presuppose that this is a
fundamentally a good program I I I
fundamentally understand that we have to
do something in order to make sure we're
in compliance with federal law and if we
if we don't get around to doing it uh
representative then we do put at risk
the money it's not that there's never a
risk it's just that I don't think in the
short term we're at risk of losing the
money as long as we're you know
communicating to CMS and I wrote If I
Had 608 in front of me I would go
exactly to the section in there it's a
small bill but there's a section in
there of some of the questions that I
would expect a pilot to answer and uh
and I think there are some more
questions that could be asked but that's
you know that's for the in-depth project
planning that I think should happen
generally what's good about this rollout
what's bad about this rollout how do we
how do we do do the the good stuff and
with it and fix the bad before we roll
it out to every area agency
other questions
yes representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
and thank you representative Edwards
taking the question
why a pilot
program versus a study committee or a
study Commission because the study
committee is still just dealing with
Theory and uh and uh in the report that
the uh that was developed and I think
it's going to be referenced here in a
bit that specifically says that this
study was done without adequate amounts
of data and that many assumptions were
made along the way and so a study
committee is going to deal with the same
uncertainty they're they're going to not
have the experience that a pilot project
is going to do this is this is the power
of a pilot project is is as you get past
the theory you get into what's really
happening during an implementation and
and and and and you get you get a level
of uh understanding and comprehension of
what the implications are for the entire
system by doing a little bit you know
you try before you buy kind of the study
committee is just more people sitting
around talking Theory I think thank you
other questions yes representative Nagle
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I I received an email this
morning about this and I I'm just
ask a question for you it says that
um uh where are you we're under a
corrective action thing that that um
expires on July 1st
um if we don't do this what happens and
if we do do this does this Advance us
towards being in compliance with CMS
I I think there's a discussion to be had
with CMS and what we're doing to address
the corrective action plan I think we've
been under that correction action plan
for years and we've kicked the can down
the road a few times uh and so uh rather
than kicking the can down the road
saying someday we're going to do
something this is fundamentally
different this is we're committed to
doing this but before we do this we're
going to do a pilot project just to make
sure we do it right and that we don't
hurt clients in the way now it may be
that we find that area agencies have
sort of outlived their usefulness and
some of them have to go away to get
efficiencies and economies of scale and
there might be some consolidation or
some other reforms that are that we
discover I'm not here to protect the
area agencies I'm I'm here thinking that
fundamentally we have people who need
these services and we're all should be
focused on the common mission what it's
going to take to meet the needs of the
the developmentally disabled
um and that I went beyond the answer to
your question I I think it's it's a I
think it's a valid concern and I think
if if you all decide on the policy
by the time it gets over to division
three I know some of the people on
division three I I I know that will
bring in the the the really smart people
to bring us testimony on precisely where
we are with the money we're not gonna
We're not gonna throw away 182 million
dollars of federal money that'd be
insane
so
other questions
yeah
yeah thank you representative
um yeah thank you representative Edwards
for taking my question so
um in your experience I mean because
there are time constraints on this
um have we run similar Pilots like this
in the past and have they been able to
be executed within some of the time
Scopes that you see in this bill
you know that's an excellent question
representative McLean I I I I think I
might be able to come up with an example
of when we should have done a pilot
project and because we didn't we screwed
it up pretty badly
um and I think it's in the in some of
the Medicaid reforms that we did we
broke things that we didn't want to
break there'll be some more testimony on
that but specifically to give you an
example of when the state has conducted
a pilot project I can't think of any I I
can tell you in my experience uh with
the Department of Defense telemedicine
test bed we we always did a pilot
project you know before we rolled out
filmless Radiology systems and hospitals
instead of sending it to everyone we
looked at three hospitals to get three
different perspectives on what it takes
to implement the system and to train the
people and worry about the culture and
get the except acceptance and so so I've
had experience outside of the State of
New Hampshire in other government
situations where pilot projects were
critical to the long-term success
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative I
have two questions the first is must all
other efforts be suspended or only those
that would be implementing the full
program as of July 1st
or is that something to look into so
so I'll apologize if the wording around
that is a little clumsy but I can tell
you what my intent is and and maybe you
could help help me clean that up my my
intent was for the two or three area
agencies that are the subjects of the
pilot that to the maximum extent
possible they should be implementing the
the program that it that we want to have
at the end of this process it's been
envisioned by the department for a long
time okay and that the other area
agencies uh are held in advance and they
continue to operate in the status quo
until we get the pilot project results
and we know how to start sending the
others into the woods with what we now
know
that's very very helpful in my follow-up
sure follow up thank you my second
question is that data is required in
Section 5 on March 1st that's only eight
months after the pilot program begins
and the pilot program is supposed to go
10 months are you looking for interim
data so that there can be information
about whether this is looking good or
complete data
I'm
um
sometimes you have to plan according to
the time available
and this is one of those times where I
have heard the concern that CMS
wants us implementing the corrective
actions plan and they're expecting it on
one July
the eight months is me guessing how much
a reasonable amount of time might be to
negotiate with CMS for them to say okay
we we could we can forestall enforcement
a little bit longer you know
they're because there will be area
agencies uh in the pilot project and
because the department will be there
they're going to be learning constantly
right so every day is an another day of
school and uh and and they have this
sisney organization uh that uh this the
the Lessons Learned will will be rolling
out informally as as they go and and as
a result of that sort of informal
information flow I think we can just
anticipate that the the final report
will be basically writing itself as
people learn what works and what doesn't
does that does that address your
question it does help we can dig into
this more later but I think that
absolutely helps thank you
other questions yes representative
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
um would you believe that I've run a
number of pilot programs myself
and so I understand the value of it uh
is it going to be a document for this
pilot it has the scope of what what it
intends to do as well as
what's the success criteria what what's
the ultimate goal so that we as as we
move forward we we know what the intent
of this pilot is
let me let me go back to what I said in
my earlier testimony that that what I
put in here is loose with the
expectations that the professionals at
the department working with the area
agencies will come up with the the more
comprehensive I'm telling them what they
need to do they need to do a pilot
project I'm not telling them how to do
it you're you're absolutely right that
they they need a scope document they
need to know what the success criteria
are you know rather than serve as the
project manager for this
I have just sort of cut it off where I
think there's a handoff point to say
okay now that we all know we should
there shall be a project plan go go do
one
thank you thank you yeah representative
Weber
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh you stated that this would
be going to the smart people on division
three but I don't see this I didn't say
smart people I I never said that
I just I know someone but I will not
require the tape to be rewound
what I am concerned about is that this
bill is not on the early Bill list and
therefore I don't think it's going to
finance at all can you confirm or deny
it doesn't have a fiscal in it it does
or it may but it's not on the early Bill
list so it's it's not on the second
committee list and not all FN bills are
first committed
I mean that that shouldn't that
shouldn't be a hard fix
to have it referred to uh Well Finance
could I have particularly when the when
there are people you know saying oh no
we're going to lose 182 million dollars
I I I think it's rational to try to get
it over to the finance committee
follow-up representative my concern is
that we have a deadline tomorrow for
this committee to act
if it is a second committee bill that is
the deadline
so I would like some kind of assurance
and I would hope that the chairman would
want some kind of assurance about what
is happening that with this bill and by
when it needs to happen because I don't
believe it's been flagged as a bill that
needs to be acted on by tomorrow nor
would I be particularly comfortable
acting on something this major by
tomorrow
and I'm not sure it's been noticed
either in previous testimony I've I've
admitted that you've been training me
for five years on uh house rules and the
protocols and the data flows and so I'm
highly deferential to your observation I
I'm not sure what to do about that I
don't know if there's you know a call to
the speaker's office to say hey we need
we need an exception here
um I don't know I don't know how that
works I I do think that I'm here asking
you about the policy primarily and not
about the money
thank you other questions
representative Nagel oh I'm sorry other
other questions
I'm seeing none okay thank you all right
well thank you
also signed up to speak this morning is
Chris Antonello from the Department of
Health and Human Services
and again if you can hold it to around
three minutes
it's okay great thank you good morning
I'm Chris santanello associate
commissioner at the Department of Health
and Human Services
I'm here today to oppose um how spell
608 is introduced the legislation seeks
to Pilot changes to the BDS system and
indefinitely suspend any other BDS
redesign efforts which would take us
back several steps and years from the
progress already underway to improve the
efficient delivery of services to this
vulnerable population I recognize that
change is hard for everybody the current
bill appears to speak to redesign
efforts but also on line 15 or 16 15 to
16 include any additional changes to the
current system
the department is currently working on
changes to the system on two different
categories of changes required Federal
changes and the system redesign based on
the 2020 Alvarez and Marcel report I
will in my three minutes um speak of
those separately as part of the required
renewal of the 1915 C waiver which funds
developmental Services is required every
five years we have been under a
corrective action plan with CMS since
2017 under conflict of interest and
direct Bill conflict of interest has
been a requirement of CMS since 2014.
working with CMS we have been able to
extend the deadline for compliance until
July 1st 2023 pushing it out further
puts the waiver those we serve Federal
matching dollars and the department at
risk
in 2019 the legislature debated New
Hampshire's compliance with 42 CFR
section
441-301 and determined that area
agencies authorized agencies and other
organizations under contract to provide
services shall be in compliance with
this federal law
New Hampshire chose the lowest bar for
compliance with conflict of interest we
chose it at the individual level not the
agency level this makes it much harder
for the Department inter enforce but it
gives agencies flexibility and increased
choice for individuals and Families
direct bill for developmental Services
System is necessary for the system to
come into compliance with Federal
Medicaid rules it aligns with every
other service program in the department
developmental service providers are an
anomaly with current billing practices
it is not the norm a provider must
enroll in Medicaid
but a trading partner can bill for the
agency so far only one area agency has
agreed to do this this would ease the
transition
these changes while critical are
necessary and they are not required as
part of the recommendations of Alvarez
and Marcel
the recommendations which are the 1915 C
tiered waiver tiered reimbursement rates
establishing a comprehensive I.T system
and developing an in-state Network for
increased supports for individuals with
intensive support needs in the spring of
sorry we are happy to Pilot any of the a
m recommendations and we have clearly
communicated that we will pilot the a m
recommendations thank you thank you
questions
uh yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
is it possible in your opinion with the
agency
to do an interim report back to the
oversight committee over at DHHS in
other words as you get into this program
to provide a
report on how the program is doing so if
we need to make any changes we're not
getting deep into the process at that
point in time we could take corrective
actions if we need to but is it possible
to do that yes absolutely
representative representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um can you or is there anybody in your
department who could help us draft
around the two different pieces here
so that we could continue with the
implementation of those things which
must be implemented under the corrective
actions
by July 1st while allowing the rest of
the changes that are the departmental
changes to be piloted in the way
contemplated by this
Bill yes absolutely
okay representative Leon could I have a
follow-up I'm sorry uh
if we needed to do it by tomorrow well
we can't do it by tomorrow because
there's no way to notice a hearing an
exec on this uh but can that be done
relatively quickly I guess is my
question
sorry I don't mean to cut you off I'm
trying to um yes absolutely it's a good
thing John Williams is not in here right
now because
um but yes working together with John
Williams and Melissa Nemet the attorney
for um this part of the department we
can we could
by the end of the week provide something
thank you
good representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and being so um flexible here my
question is if this can be also drafted
with a five-month interim data point
with the criteria of success so that we
know if it's looking good or if it's
looking like there needs to be some
change in action while getting the full
10 months of data
for the a m work yes okay thank you
other questions
I'm seeing none so thank you
also signed up to speak is Rebecca
Bryant from the Region 3 Area Agency
good morning you have three minutes
ma'am Mike microphone please
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today on favor of House Bill 608 my name
is Rebecca Bryant and I'm the president
and CEO at Lakes Region Community
Services where the area agency for
Region 3 centered out of Laconia and I'm
also the president of Community Support
Network Incorporated representing the 10
area agencies
in the process of the systems work
imposed on us over the last two years we
have been repeatedly told by our
Regulators as you heard today that
change is hard they know change is hard
they tell us that on every single call
the level of difficulty or the amount of
effort required has never been a
question or concern for myself my
colleagues or the dedicated albeit
inadequate Workforce in our agencies in
supporting the most vulnerable citizens
in our communities we do hard things
every day 24 7 365.
what we are asking for is change done
right prior to joining the Human
Services world my career was in
corporate finance and in manufacturing
I'm sure you're familiar with the
Japanese term kaizan which means change
for the better Kaizen requires all
elements of a process Upstream
Downstream on a plane or in a cube to be
identified and considered when imposing
change or continuous Improvement
ensuring that all elements are connected
another key component of kaizan is the
implementation of the scientific method
creating a hypothesis testing it
correcting it until you get it right
when Toyota would come to us to
introduce a change or component of
continuous Improvement it would be
thoroughly tested in a gated area
separate from the rest of the
manufacturing process until it was a
hundred percent correct and the system's
changes we're being asked to implement
we do not yet have all of the components
identified sourced priced or tested
we're asking that we gate off a corner
in our system that we can safely
Implement which a tremendous amount of
hypothetical information test it correct
it where necessary and get it right in
manufacturing if we didn't get it right
we were always aware that it was not
just the possibility of the failure of
an automotive component but actual harm
Downstream to those operating in
automobile in human services there is no
room for Downstream the people we
support are directly impacted by
everything we do we are looking for this
bill amongst other ways to slow down and
test and do this work correctly the
bureau and the department have asked for
extensions in other areas just recently
unbeknownst to us there's another
extension asked for another CMS
requirement for evv electronic visit
verification other states have
successfully continued to demonstrate
that we are in good faith moving forward
but get delays so 7123 did not have to
be the end-all be-all to Jeopardy's
jeopardize our Medicaid dollars an
extension is absolutely something that
should have been on the table until we
got this right I can tell you speaking
for myself and my agency and my board we
are not against change I personally and
this is completely a personal statement
believe that our current system is not
sustainable we need rates we need change
but we need change done right thank you
thank you questions
seeing no questions
oh representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for being here and
taking my question what are your
thoughts on the proposition to the
department to
um just suspend the non-a M parts of
this and pilot the other parts
um I think it's really complicated
because honestly I don't think you can
separate the a m from the conflict of
interest and and the corrective action
plan so corrective action plan covers
conflict of interest and direct Bill and
a m covers a whole bunch of other stuff
and over the last four years all of that
has intersected so it is very much an
intertwined conversation right now and
again you know I you heard
um Ms santanello refer to the fact that
only one Area Agency signed up to be a
trading partner we don't have the
information technology currently to be
trading partners so a trading partner
for direct bill is not even a
possibility and that's not just because
we're sitting back going oh we don't
have a system and we're not going to
change we have a legacy system that in
Partnership many years with the Bureau
New Hampshire leads was the billing
system for 9 out of 10 area agencies we
have a lot of Legacy systems and a
humongous amount of I.T overhaul that
needs to happen and by the way we have
we don't have funding for that
infrastructure so so you know there's a
lot there's so many detailed components
of this obviously um but that that's
just one example where I just don't
believe we can talk about a m and the
corrective action separately at this
point they're very intertwined
thank you
other questions
right before you get a copy of your
testimony ma'am too and before we're
done but uh yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and also thank you
for taking the question
this is a field I'm not really burst in
so please pardon my ignorance here
is New Hampshire the first state to go
down this road or are we following a lot
about the states that we could learn
from and therefore we don't need to do a
pilot because the other State's already
done it for us
I shouldn't say all at different levels
every state is having to obviously
comply with the center for Medicaid and
Medicare services so is that
follow-up
partially what I'm asking for is if
other states have done this successfully
instead of having a pilot can we look to
those States as the pilot to learn from
them and therefore we don't have to back
up we can continue forward knowing that
we could reach out to a fellow State and
learn from them to help us versus going
down a road by ourselves to create a
separate pilot great question so no we
can't look in another state because
there's no one other state that's done
it the same when you're when you're
working with CMS on your waivers you
have the opportunity to look at how you
do things in your state and get it
approved by CMS there's many states and
process that are not complete most of
the other states that have been working
on this had already still had
institutions New Hampshire as you know
closed our institution a long time ago
our system looks very different we
actually specifically asked Myers and
stuffer and forgive me I always get it
wrong m s who is working under a m on
this project for the rate setting piece
of it we actually recently asked them on
a call if they could look at another
state and tell us another state that had
done this successfully and the m s
consultant actually on that call said to
us no there's no other state that has
done so much at one time as New
Hampshire is trying to do
foreign other questions yes
representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question and you may not be the right
person to ask this but I'm going to ask
it anyway
this is a little naivety also but a m is
Alvarez and Marshall Marcel Marcellus
okay great
um it would be really helpful to
understand for me the road map of this
entire system
um not just your your your agency which
I actually believe in not work with but
um
um the entire roadmap of what's being
affected the number of people being
involved is there any way to get that
kind of information for us
um and I should have asked this of the
previous person probably yeah I mean I
think that a road map could very
successfully be created in partnership
with both BDS and and area agency and
put that road map together I did
previously submit to the committee um
testimony a letter that I wrote that
walks you through the timeline I would
highly encourage you to read that
document because it does have the entire
timeline I also submitted two hard
copies this morning but I submitted soft
copies prior thank you
other questions
yes
German I'm sorry
oh okay sorry I thought you were
pointing to someone over there
representative McKay
oh okay thank you Mr chairman uh
I I come from a
very long history of trying to
understand the DD system and I think
representative McMahon who's standing
over there has had years of experience
of and I can't ask you if why it always
has to be so complicated because I I
know that's an inappropriate question
but for me it has been a very long
journey
I am
totally confused by the Department's
a fiscal note
if if it's not going to finance I don't
know why they would have such a
frightening
a statement that in the absolute worst
case scenario the loss you have a
question representatively yeah
I think the question is why is this
always so complicated but I know you
can't answer that question
but that it does seem to indicate a very
serious implication for the future of
your program
can you get anything out of all that
companies I would love to be able to
explain why anything related to
government is so complicated I I
I I did spend my my life started in
public accounting and corporate finance
I came to my agency as a CFO and I've
said this many times and I've said it
before in other hearings I truly was one
of those wet behind the ears Finance
people that thought I was going to come
into this system find efficiencies such
as a m and others have tried I have
never found such tight budgets such lean
margins and such hard-working people and
we work for the families in New
Hampshire my board is made up of 50 of
consumer representation I work for the
families in New Hampshire I don't work
for you know I'm not working for
corporate America for a reason so all I
can tell you is that when it touches
families it gets complicated and it
should and it has always been a
partnership between the bureau
developmental Services I've been here
for 17 years the first 10 as a CFO we
had tremendous partnership with the
bureau we sat at the table together we
were not blindsided by reports such of
this we were not finding out when things
were being delivered and ordered we were
at the table creating the solutions so
why is it complicated today that's why
it feels complicated to me today and I
know a lot of people will say we're
trying to preserve the area agency
system we're trying to preserve our jobs
I'm an incredibly transparent blunt
person you can take me and and decide
for yourself you don't know me but I can
tell you right now I can walk out of
here today and I can get a job back in
Corporate America doing whatever I want
to do I have the skills I have the
experience what I don't have is the
passion for anything but what we're
doing here when you have worked for the
families of the State of New Hampshire
our most vulnerable citizens that is who
we are working for I'm not preserving
Becky Bryant's job I'm preserving the
quality of life for the individuals in
the Greater Lakes Region
thank you other questions
anyone else any other questions
okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Karen
Rosenberg I believe it is from the
disability rights leadership
of New Hampshire
good morning my penmanship must be
terrible it's the disability rights
Center New Hampshire thank you this is
Karen I'm Karen Rosenberg and I'm the
policy director for disability rights
Center in Hampshire
um the state's protection and advocacy
Organization for people with
disabilities we regularly hear from
folks across the state who benefit from
HCBS Services these are the services
that area agencies are currently helping
to deliver and which allow people with
disabilities to live in their
communities instead of Institutions and
we are very concerned about this bill
and
um and are adamantly opposed to it now I
mean pilot programs can make sense in a
lot of Industries and maybe even in
government programs but unfortunately
this program is funded in large part by
CMS with Medicaid funds and there are
laws and regulations that the state must
follow in order to secure the those
funds there are processes that CMS has
in place to waive some of those
requirements and in fact the CM the
waivers that we're talking about those
Home and community-based Services
waivers are called that because
CMS has allowed the state to secure
Federal Medicaid matching funds to
operate these waivers with waiving some
of the requirements that would generally
be there for state plan services so for
example if it's a state plan service
that's a service that generally has to
be available to all people throughout
the state but a waiver but the HCBS
waiver programs are programs where the
state has secured cms's permission to
only make these particular services
available to certain individuals
and they can limit the number of
individuals even so
um but but the state doesn't get to go
Rogue they have to get cms's approval
for any waivers in order to secure that
essential matching fund that we need to
be able to make sure that people get
those HCBS Services there's another
mechanism CMS makes available to States
that's called an 1115 demonstration
waiver that's another mechanism that
states can use to try to get permission
for some limited amount of time to test
a theory that would allow where they
would get permission to waive certain
Medicaid requirements thus our
Department of Health and Human Services
that has actually secured one of those
waivers at least one there's maybe more
but that's what's allowing the state
right now to fund inpatient substance
misuse treatment also something that's
not generally funded by Medicaid but
this is you know if you were to pass a
pilot program I was thinking about this
for this particular program I've heard a
lot about putting the cart before the
horse this is like putting the cart
before the Trojan Horse and we're Troy
because if we we've known for since at
least well 2014 that conflict-free case
management was required we've been on a
corrective action plan since 2017
um that's requiring the state to comply
with this Federal Medicaid regulation to
qualify for their money that we need to
have conflict-free case management and
direct billing and these are things that
actually benefit people with
disabilities direct billing allows
people with disabilities to have broader
access to the services that they require
the level that they require
if you could start oh I'm sorry
I've got a lot to say I'm but anyway I
again I encourage you to oppose this I'm
happy to take any questions you might
have thank you questions
anyone have any questions for this lady
nuts oh yeah representative Weber
thank you very much Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question
so if we do not pass this bill
what do you foresee happening between
now and July
that you think is positive and more
positive than what would happen if we
were to pass the bill the state needs to
come into compliance with the direct
billing and conflict-free case
management by July I mean that's what's
required and you know it's I'm not the
one who has to implement that so I think
everyone needs to really dig their heels
in and do it and that will be positive
for everyone
other questions
and and just a follow-up follow-up
and do you read as somebody said that
this
bill is going to Halt compliance with
that piece of the puzzle well I'm
concerned that that's what it intends to
do
um this is not the kind of thing that
can be piloted we've already gotten our
prime directive from CMS that we must
accomplish this
so I am concerned that we would put
federal dollars at risk and that would
translate into reduction in services for
people who really need them
thank you other questions
see no other questions okay thank you
very much thank you
we have uh two folks signed up from one
sky uh if I'm reading the name what's
right uh Jason Archibald and Matthew
cadero
do folks want to testify individually or
come up together
I'm sorry okay uh all right Mr Archibald
you want to come up first
good morning thank you all very much for
taking the time to hear I submitted
testimony this morning via email I ask
that you take the time to read it I am a
I'm the type of person that um if it's
not written and I can't point to it it
doesn't exist
so throughout my testimony I reference
what the bureau has actually said and
what the bureau has actually done
um so this morning just the cap uh just
to begin our system supports 7 500
people to the tune to about 400 million
dollars a year
the last three years I've been part of
the system we've actually underspent our
budget by 30 to 40 million dollars we
are extremely efficient
um that money could go back into the
system and increasing rates it could go
back into increasing housing but the
bureau has chosen to give that money
back to increase the a m work
how we got here is in 2017 we received a
corrective action as a state that we
needed to have direct bill and we needed
to have uh conflict-free case management
the state worked with the area agency
system for four years to accomplish this
the area agency systems including mine
divested
businesses bought new accounting systems
bought new
um uh made other Investments including
like physical capacity to buildings
spent millions of dollars to come into
compliance
around
um September of 2020 sometime that month
a m was hired through a sole source
contract
also in that month BDS
um sent a request to CMS to extend the
deadline for coffin-free case management
and direct Bill to July 1st coming up
and
um
they also began the a m work a m turned
around and submitted their a m report
and I'm going to read some quotes from
that that I think will put things in
perspective for you
and that was sent to us in March that's
when we found out about the report the
report was based off of only the
bureau's
priorities as it states in the report
and the data that they were given and in
the report in several areas it literally
says that the report was incomplete and
the report was the the data was uh um
corrupt or erroneous in areas
and they call that out the purpose of
the a m report
um in certain areas is just one quote
was to constrain access and cost
um
so a m recommends BDS introduced tiered
waiverid structures in which the funding
caps are placed at specific levels to
constrain service authorization and
access
this is kind of the the reasons that we
have issues with the a m work and when
you look at the a m work itself it
didn't involve any stakeholders
that they're an aside why we're here
today and why we're asking for it to be
piloted is because we're not ready for
July 1st we don't have the billing
systems put into place we don't even
have the regulations and if they were
sent out to us today we wouldn't get
them till May which means we'd have two
months to turn businesses around uh to
come into compliance
we're going to spend millions of dollars
on poor project management and our area
agencies our nonprofits and our families
can't afford that people will more than
likely not get paid and Sarah says will
not be provided which are going to leave
a large segment of our population
without services
these are the issues
one of my biggest concerns is the
hyperbole around the CMS
cap in the fact that we're going to
potentially lose Federal match dollars
and I will read this part because I
spent a lot of time researching it
um suggesting if you could start
wrapping up please okay
um suggesting the state may lose our
federal match dollars due to our
legislative body listening to its
constituency constituents is hyperbolic
No statement of this kind has been
publicly made by CMS nor has it ever
acted so unilaterally to quash
sovereignty of a state and its people in
periods of non-compliance CMS has
historically shown it works with State
administrators to bring them in
compliance in a realistic way they
actually have
hundreds of documents on their website
that talk about you should work with
legislators because unfortunately
foreseen things happen and I provided a
link in the end of my testimony to that
documentation they work with us they
have no want will a desire to destroy
our system they only have a desire to
make it better and that's what the
corrective action plan is for we as area
agencies want the same thing
we just want to make sure we do it in a
way that doesn't harm anyone and if we
try to force this through come July 1st
just because we're we're trying to meet
a deadline that we haven't even talked
to CMS about extending we're going to
harm someone and when we look back at
this moment because we're all watching
if it's not done right July 1st
there's going to be consequences and
those consequences aren't going to be
for the people here in this room who are
not family members and not individuals
it's going to be family members and
individuals who are going to feel those
consequences so thank you very much and
if uh representative Martian I would
like to address your question about
piloting if you don't mind
um there's been several times where I've
submitted I've worked in other states I
have a um a history my work history is
about a little less than 20 years I've
had the privilege to work around the
country
um
the foster care system in Florida has a
setup similar to ours it's very
successful I've sent it to the bureau
I've sent it to a m
um there's many times where I sit on the
the rate committee meeting it's very
scripted we don't have the ability to
really say much more than what they want
us to talk about
um that is something that we should look
at as a model
but we still need to Pilot this because
if we don't
I truly believe we're going to lose a
lot of New Hampshire providers and we're
going to send people into out-of-state
placements because we have no we don't
have the capacity for them now thank you
another question yeah representative
King
thank you chairman McDonald and thank
you for testifying today I really
appreciate I really liked your testimony
um my question is
everybody's concerned about missing out
on federal dollars
um and so we have to change our system
to meet what the federal what the feds
want for us if it weren't for the money
do you think it would still be a good
change to do or are we simply bending
over backwards for federal dollars here
like is it is it really an improvement
or are we just doing it for the money
thank you
my honest and personal opinion is a
combination of both they have some
really great ideas in the a m report and
then they have some really terrible ones
in my opinion from working around the
country in a lot of different systems so
if they had the one thing about our
system was we have people here that
um
I felt like I've I've been in awe of how
much they actually know and in this
whole redesign process their voices
weren't heard and I've talked I've heard
unprecedented
um
you know stakeholder participation and
transparency I've had to send myself to
foyer requests I've had to threaten to
send foyer requests during the meetings
if you watch my testimony on any of the
rate setting meetings you're going to
find that I don't follow the game plan I
ask questions and the responses I get
most of the time is that's really good
thank you we'll consider that which is a
nice way of saying anyways
um the federal match dollars I I think
is really and I think representative
Edwards said it was fear-mongering I
think that's extremely accurate
um to say that we're going to lose 182
million dollars worth of funding
um right now I think would
would be a black eye for the Biden
Administration I think it would
um really pit us against CMS and
realistically what we're saying is we
are going to come into compliance we
just want to do this safely so no one
gets hurt again CMS having worked with
them around the country I've never met
one person from CMS that is gun ho of
taking funding away what they are gun ho
about is making sure that people getting
good Services getting quality services
and they're done at the right price
thank you yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the question
the more I listen to your testimony
more concerned I am that there's no plan
that's really been solidified to do a
pilot project on
so therefore if we don't have a real
solid plan where we're going to Pilot
so are you saying that we have a real
solid plan it's been well designed to do
a pilot project on or are we still
trying to design
pilot in order to implement the pilot
so what I would say is that we have half
of an idea and a good thought so the the
issue is and I don't mean the pilot
program I mean what a m has put together
and what we have so far with the bureau
I think if we try to if this was a
rocket ship we would have maybe the
fuselage and no engine and if we try to
put this forward on July 1st we're going
to fail miserably
follow up please
so what I'm trying to understand is that
we have part of the plan but we don't
have a real plan so come July 1
we can't even exercise in your opinion
if I understand it correctly both a
pilot program plus the full plan because
we don't have a plan to begin with it's
really been vetted and tested and so
forth on
a drawing board anywhere so if we're
going to go forward
how we can go forward with the pilot
program if you don't have the plan the
number two
would you be willing or somebody Maybe
representative Edwards to basically put
this contingent upon getting a waiver
from CMS I don't know how long it takes
to get one but I would be concerned that
if we don't get the waiver from CMS we
are
at risk of losing the money so I don't
know how long it takes to get a waiver
but would you be opposed to having a
waiver crave depending upon what happens
so what I will say is that
we've worked the last two years under
the direction of BDS and DHHS to get us
to the point to where we can provide
these services in the methodology in a
way that they want us to do that we have
no regulations we as area agencies
cannot bill for the funding that we need
to be able to do that so
when they go to implement this like
yesterday I received an email from DHHS
saying that a part of what they
considered originally to be part of the
cap and that we had to come into
compliance with we're no longer doing
that up until a month ago we had no
contingency plan from BDS that was
shared with us
um and last Monday was the first time or
this yeah last Monday was the first time
or this Monday I'm sorry was the first
time I've heard of dhhs's Desire want or
will to actually pilot any of the stuff
that we have
the last month a lot has been going on
at DHHS that they've realized that we're
not going to be able to do everything
come July 1st and they have scaled back
dramatically and it continues to happen
I don't think we have an option to do
anything but pilot a program unless we
want to put our entire system at risk
I personally put the lives of the people
we support over 182 million dollars with
that being said my experience with CMS
is that they are very smart people and
they will work with us part of their
system to help States come into
compliance is they provide a technical
assistant someone that youth as a state
can go to and they can Shepherd you
through the compliance that you need to
do to get to the other end if this was
such a concern why would we have
scrapped two years ago everything the
state had already done the Investments
the area agencies had made
to now not only redo all that work over
four years but then add on all these
additional components if it was really
that much of a threat and a concern no
person in their right mind would ever do
that particularly anyone that
understands that this is going to affect
directly affect 7 500 people because
that's how many people we support not to
mention the tens of thousands of staff
that support them and their families
other questions yes representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this question I let me
start off by saying I appreciate your
description of the Cooperative nature of
working with CMS we often hear that
government is corrupt and unworkable so
I appreciate your optimism uh my
question really is
um which is a superior choice if I
understand this correctly we could go
ahead with this piloting program or we
could just ask for an extension until we
are ready to to know that we can do it
and do it right maybe at that point we
wouldn't need a pilot program or maybe
we would still start with the pilot
program
I think we regardless have to ask for an
extension I don't think there's a
there's a Avenue in which we don't uh or
let me say that I don't think there is a
um
an intelligent way to move forward
without doing that or safe way but with
that being said I think no matter what
we do because it affects so many lives
and so many businesses and the tangible
effects to our like the New Hampshire
economy Alone
um I think you have to do a pilot
program
it's again getting back to doing change
right not change for the sake of change
doesn't change it's disaster waiting to
happen
other questions
representative Weber
uh you may not be the right person to
ask this question but you're the person
sitting in the chair so I'll I'll just
ask you and you can certainly defer if
you'd rather not answer it
um
if you know
does the department if if we accept
that the department is going to need a
waiver no matter what
because
time is creeping on and we are no longer
young as representative McMahon might
acknowledge but aggressively mature and
progressing on to whatever the next
stage is
um
if we get a waiver
and the collective wisdom of the people
around here was that yeah it would be
good idea to start with a pilot program
do we actually need legislation to do
that or is the purpose of legislation to
force DHHS to do things a certain way if
if they just chose to do this could they
do it this way without the legislation
thank you for that question I would ask
that you read my testimony because all
this has been done without the voices of
the people in this room and I mean the
family members if we're only going to
listen to One voice at the table let it
be the families and the individuals
um you know the area agency system I've
worked in different parts of the country
it's one of the best systems I've been
in but it has its problems they need to
be addressed there's not one CEO that I
know of and I've talked to of the area
agency system who doesn't say we need to
make changes if you talk to the DRC
they'll tell you we need to burn it down
and in some instances they're correct
because they can point to things that we
need to change we need to have unified
policies I think we should all have um
accreditation status so that we're not
just meeting the state's minimum
requirements we're meeting the country's
best practices all those things cost
money and we don't have a lot of it but
we're spending we spent 20 million
dollars on a m as far as I know and that
number could be wrong
um but that's what's been shared with me
to essentially revamp this entire system
when we could have taken that money and
for a couple million dollars worth of
savings a year uh we could have taken
that money and we could have said uh
solved our out-of-state housing crisis
right now when a person needs congregate
level of care whether that's
behaviorally intensive or medically
intensive we have to send them out of
state to Florida Texas Massachusetts or
Pennsylvania so if you have a loved one
you have to say goodbye to them because
they have to go to Florida for service
and treatment
the difference is in New Hampshire we
spend 365
000 at most those are four beds that I
have in New Hampshire
um for people who need palliative care
end of like treatment
we're spending up to seven hundred
thousand dollars for someone who's not
even at that remote level of care to be
in Florida and it's a fifty thousand
dollar plane ticket one way back and
forth and it can be cheaper if we have
more people going and if we have more
people going we're spending more money
you bring those people back we can serve
them at a lot less money and we're going
to save the state six six million
dollars annually
give me the 25 million dollars or give
it actually give it to the New Hampshire
housing fund let them manage it I I
don't have faith in the decisions being
made at this point that make the most
sense and the best example I can give
for that is even if we open up new
programs the the room and board budget
for the state is exhausted it's 2.5
million dollars and all that money is
gone it's going to room and board so you
would assume if we have all these people
going out of state we need to start new
programs so let's increase the budget
come to you folks and ask for that money
I have inherited hide nor hair of that
in three years that I've worked in the
state as an area agency director it is
in the a m report that that's a problem
when we need to address it
it's not something that we needed to
spend 20 million dollars to figure out
though thank you other questions yes
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um I've really enjoyed your testimony as
well was very enlightening
and this may or may not be related to
what we're talking about but it's really
important to me I really need to
understand this system and how it works
I was actually surprised with the number
7 500 I thought the number would be a
lot bigger than that but can you give me
I'm understanding that the state is
divided functioning to six networks um
like Lakes Region Community Services one
and then they contract with other
agencies am I wrong about that and is
there some description somewhere the
entire system that I can look up and and
understand it tomorrow
no
[Laughter]
easiest answer sorry the way our system
works is BDS contracts with us we
provide Case Management Services we
figure out what an individual needs to
support them in their environment with
their families preferably or in their
own place uh congregate care settings
even though I'm here advocating for them
are a very it's a very minute need it's
think of it as like hospital setting of
care we want to put people in those
settings and then we want to transition
them as fast as humanly possible into
more individually based settings where
they can live their lives typically as
we all do but once we determine what
those persons needs are we then build a
um their service list and then we RFP it
out to our vendor agencies we contract
with so that's Easter Seals that's
Beckett that's life coping That's Life
Connections and those individuals turn
around and they say okay
an RFP could be for me Matt six two 260
pounds highly physically aggressive
um so what we want to do is we want to
have two to three staff with him it's
going to cost X Y and Z dollars to
support him where our system's unique is
that we capitate administrative costs
for area agencies at three percent of
that budget and nine percent for the
vendor so we we're not
um building in a lot of cost with rate
buildup methodologies in other states
they have runaway budgets right now
because they have to I can profit as
much as I want in that um in that
environment so it incentivizes me
instead of taking Matt who's going to be
very difficult to serve and maybe uh and
maybe you know cause some workers comps
claims I can take repnagel who's in the
same band but needs a lot less support
and get that higher rate and and by the
way I'm not advocating that we don't get
rates by any means
um I'm just saying this is these are the
things that we actually need to figure
out before we jump headlong into this
I've never heard of anyone plummeting to
their death by looking before they leap
but I've heard of it with people just
jumped not knowing what was in front of
them
okay another question follow-up
follow-up
um so how do you interact like with
Community Bridges Lakes Region lrcs
whatever how do you interact with them
or what is the interaction with them
um a lot of it is Professional Knowledge
um you know I can tell my experience
here but
um
those individuals have a lot of
knowledge and we did this with that and
that's how we get around
um and we were able to get that person
services or this is how we were able to
do that
um but then we also share
um resources so when we have like a
individual that
maybe I can't support the best I can
reach out to them and they may have a
vendor that they work with that works
specifically with people who need like
sign language but they may be
behaviorally intensive at the same time
so they're they're able to help we're
able to work together to be able to work
in the best interest of the the system
at hand
other questions
seeing no other questions
okay thank you sir
thank you all very much have a great day
thank you chairman
oh um okay
um ma'am we were gonna what I was about
to announce we're going to recess this
bill
um because of some scheduling issues
we're going to proceed to 69 we will
resume testimony on this after host Bill
69. Mr chairman yes
um I believe that uh Miss Archibald was
one of the pink cards that you had
referred to prior to the the last
witness it it was yes
um again
okay sorry sorry for the confusion
um so anyway uh at this point I would
again like to recess the hearing on
hb608 and please proceed to her Clarity
Mr chairman sure uh are we recessing
this completely for today or are we
recessing this we are going to recess
and re-notice is that my understanding
until after 69 and then we're going to
return to it oh okay I understood from
representative Leon that we were going
to recess for the day so
if you're interested y'all don't go away
okay
again sorry for the uh for the confusion
um at this point I'd like to call upon a
rep representative
um Mark McLean the prime sponsor of
house bill 69.
uh thank you Mr chair
um for for the Indulgence um
uh I do have a witness here on hb69 at
Jared Rhodes from the Department
Institute of Health policy and he does
have a flight to catch so I I appreciate
the Indulgence of you and and the rest
of the committee
for the record chairman McDonald thank
you very much uh members of the HHS
committee my name is Mark McLean
representing Hillsboro district 15 which
is Manchester Ward 8. I'm here to
introduce HB 69 which Builds on the
direct Primary Care legislation that we
passed two terms Ago by extending that
model to Health Care Facilities it
basically allows those Health Care
Facilities that operate on a
membership-based model or exclusively
take direct payment for services to be
excluded from the requirement to accept
all modes of payment so basically the
legislation is being brought forward in
attempt drive towards increased
transparency in health care pricing to
kind of put some downward pressure on
costs and to introduce new service
models in under serve communities so I
think one of the areas where the
Affordable Care Act fell short in my
estimation was it really was promising
to bring health care costs under control
and a key element that was discussed at
the time was um to introduce clearer
more understandable pricing information
that would encourage people to shop
around and enhance competition
unfortunately that never happened and
Health care billing today remains just
as Byzantine as it's ever been
when I filed the legislation I got a
call almost immediately from the
hospital Association and to be up front
you know they're not supporting this but
we had a great conversation and they
really were able to you know graciously
kind of put me through some of their
concerns with the bill one of the things
that they're saying on the transparency
front is us saying listen we already
comply with all the legal requirements
and on top of that the federal no
surprises act which has been
co-sponsored by Senator Hassan is going
to be coming in and that's going to be
bringing even greater transparency
um and it's going to requiring
comprehensive good faith estimates for
services rendered and everything that we
had and it was very great conversation
and everything that was put forth in
that conversation was correct I think
really the only thing that disappointed
me about the conversation was just that
I agree that the the hospital
Association and other agencies are doing
everything that they can to comply with
the law when it comes to pricing
transparency but it seems that they stop
there and they don't go beyond that and
I think for me personally that's a shame
because I think that that is where the
Brain Trust is that's where the
knowledge is and I would like to see
um the agencies like the hospital
Association really kind of taking the
leads and and not waiting for the
legislation I'm also concerned a little
bit though about the no surprises act
and I have a feeling that it may not
deliver as promised and it may actually
lead to inflated inflated pricing I love
the concept of the bill to be honest
with it I loved it so much that in the
last term I brought in HB 264 which
basically did the exact same uh thing as
no surprises but at the state level but
when I went over to Chairman hunt in the
Commerce Committee I got crushed I got
crushed by chairman Hans I got crushed
by the committee I got crossed by the
hospital Association I got crushed by
the deputy the insurance commissioner
because they're saying look the cost
structure is so complex that if you try
to do this it's actually potentially
going to create more inflated pricing
because maybe people are going to you
know kind of inflate their quotes things
that and so
um I really hope no surprises does what
it promises to do but I have a hunch
that it may fall prey to some of the
pitfalls that were revealed when I
brought forth um HB uh 264. hb69 by
contrast is much more alexandrian and
that it kind of cuts through the tangle
of the Health care billing by
introducing the direct pay model for
that model to work you truly have to be
transparent and because most people get
their insurance from commercial Market
or enrolled in Medicare or Medicaid I
think the usage rates are facilities
using this model will likely be
relatively low but for those who are
uninsured self-insured or high
deductibles the idea of having uh good
knowledge of what your upfront pricing
is in the colonoscopy that may have
um enormous appeal for you and even a
small amount of competition May generate
change releasing facilities as well from
the all-payer model will also release
them from the enormous administrative
burden that that engenders doctors
become doctors because of the desire to
help others they're not accountants and
they don't want to be accountants and
close to half the administrative burden
in operating a facility is tied to
billing so if that can be eliminated the
potential in expansion of services may
be there um it won't be for everyone but
it will introduce competition new
approaches and possibly exposure to
Innovative new ways to deliver Health
Care one of the main objections to hb69
in the past is to fear that it will
decimate New Hampshire's critical access
hospitals I personally think that the
uptake rate is not going to be high
enough and so any immediate effect would
be blunted
um but there are a lot of protections
for critical access hospitals the
exclusion Zone remains intact the 101
Medicare reimbursement remains intact
the 24 7 emergency room requirement
remains intact none of those are changed
so the critical access hospitals are
still heavily armored against
competition but I asked the committee a
question are we protecting critical
access hospitals merely for the state
sake of protecting critical access
hospitals the reason that the federal
critical access act went into effect in
1997 was an attempt to preserve Health
Care access in the nation's rural
communities ultimately we have to
remember that's the real goal preserving
and ultimately expanding access in those
communities so one of the ways I think
that the critical access law actually
impedes the expansion of access is at a
caps the amount of hospital beds for
example at 25. so I asked legislative
research about you know Trends in bed
count throughout the state and and what
I quickly discovered is Alice Peck 25
beds androscogan Valley 25 beds Cottage
Hospital 25 beds Franklin Hospital 25
beds Huggins Hospital 25 beds I'm not
going to go through the whole list in
the interest of time but I think you get
the idea so even if the hospitals wanted
to staff beyond the 25 bed count I don't
think it's going to happen because
they're very concerned about preserving
their status as a critical access
hospital so recognizing this I think if
new methodologies are offered that may
offer an alternative way to expand
access should they not be explored I'll
just leave you with this one note
because I know we're pressed for time
with Mr Rhodes but consider if you will
the way that the state has sought to
expand the use of renewable energy
whether you like them or not Vehicles
like the renewable portfolio standard
energy efficient resource standards they
were brought into being so that the
state could explore different renewable
options and ways to bring them to the
marketplace we have an all of the above
approach when it comes to going into
Renewables why then do we seem to be
Tethered to a single path when it comes
to providing Health Care you know I
think that at a time when medical access
is increasingly under threat we should
just like with the renewable energy go
and consider an awe of the above
approach
and that concludes my testimony in the
interest of time and because Mr Rhodes
has a flight it has to leave at 10 45 I
would respectfully ask if you could
defer questions to him if that's
possible thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative McLean
okay Mr Rhodes would you like to come
forward Jared Rose
hey thank you
chairman Pearson Vice chair Leon and
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify on House Bill
69. my name is Jared Rhodes I am a
health policy researcher affiliated with
the mercatus center at George Mason
University in Arlington Virginia and I'm
also an adjunct instructor at the
Dartmouth Institute for health policy
and clinical practice in Hanover New
Hampshire I live in Lebanon New
Hampshire
I'm here today as an individual not a
representative of of those institutions
uh but I'm here to say that I support
hb69 uh the main reason that I support
the bill is I believe the residents of
New Hampshire would benefit from
allowing direct pay Healthcare
facilities to operate in this state and
passage of hb69 would be a step in that
direction I think under current law New
Hampshire requires Health Care
Facilities to provide services
regardless of the source of payment and
this requirement to accept all payment
sources it may be a non-issue for large
hospitals or large Health Systems who
actually see size and as an advantage
but it creates a uniquely impossible
hurdle for one particular type of
healthcare facility and that's direct
pay Healthcare facilities a direct pay
health care facility is a facility that
accepts only Cash
Direct pay facilities don't accept
payment from third parties insurance
companies or government programs the
reason they do this is to simplify their
business practices and eliminate the
administrative overhead associated with
dealing with multiple payers each with
its own paperwork and processes and
contracts the efficiency gain that it
gets plus the the sort of discipline
that comes from competing on prices that
are going to be naturally transparent
because you're dealing with you know
advertising to Consumers means that the
the prices at direct pay facilities can
be anywhere from 1 8 to 1 10 of the
prices of other facilities who are paid
through through Insurance a
tonsillectomy for instance that might be
twelve thousand dollars if you're paying
for it through Insurance could be three
thousand dollars direct pay or a
gallbladder surgery with a liver biopsy
that's twenty three thousand dollars of
paid through Insurance could be seven
thousand direct pay
the ability to accept just one simple
streamlined source of payment is the
whole direct pay model by not accepting
uh payments from Myriad payers direct
pay facilities can have fewer
administrative staff maybe they have a
smaller building uh their Physicians can
spend less time going back and forth
with payers about coverage benefits and
prior authorizations and co-pays and so
forth
direct pay facilities do exist in other
states this is not a brand new idea and
we could have them here too but our
current requirement that Healthcare
facilities accept all payment sources in
effect makes the direct pay uh pay
business model impossible
um so in summary keeping this brief um I
believe our our status quo is is wrong
in in at least two ways first it's it's
actually unjust I think to the
entrepreneurial Physicians and surgeons
who would like to open uh and operate a
facility under this model
um and then second uh it does not serve
the health care interests of New
Hampshire residents who would I think
benefit from having greater choice and
cheaper alternatives uh for their care
so for those reasons I I support hb69
thank you you're taking questions sir
sure representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question
um
could you outline for us specifically
what kinds of facilities are covered by
this bill because it is in the section
on
um
hospitals and
Healthcare facility residential care and
health facilities and I'm never very
clear exactly what is covered by that
right I I might need some help
understanding some of that too but the
the my remarks today are have in mind
the the Standalone uh surgical you know
day ambulatory Surgical Center kind of
model that's that's what I'm
um uh referring to in in my remarks
and may I have one more Mr chair
my other question is
um
isn't the problem
understanding all the issues of billing
which are very valid uh isn't the
problem with this kind of service that
it Cherry picks
the people who are able to pay in full
themselves
thereby ensuring that
it's not the problem with the critical
care access is they will then only get
the people who are the neediest and the
least insured and the least able to pay
on their own
thereby jeopardizing their status
yeah I'm not sure that uh there's uh
that they're competing for the same
people here that they're competing for
the same patients and consumers
um there I think the number uh as we
heard from um Mr McLean the the number
of uh facilities that would open would
be probably relatively small
um there are there's a relatively small
number of these types of facilities in
uh operation uh in in other states
um and uh uh it's it's it's not um it's
not at the scale that uh that that we've
seen uh creates a lot of tension between
um uh yeah this uh on that issue that
you identify
um and I think what it what it actually
does is is offers an alternative to
um uh to to people who uh would like to
use this model
um some of which some of whom might be
uninsured themselves so it's it's not as
if they're this is not quite the you
know if you're thinking of this and and
and ideas of uh you know oh this is
concierge medicine for the Rich and
Famous I I don't think that's the case
it's uh it's actually the the reason it
appeals to a lot of people is because of
the lower prices because it's something
that they actually can't afford it can
be more expensive to go uh the insurance
route
King
thank you chairman McDonald
um
what kind of patients or consumers
following you know riffing on
um uh representative Weber what kind of
patients or consumers are drawn to
direct pay health care facilities thank
you good question so it could be uh an
individual who's uninsured it could be a
person who is uh
thinking of themselves as self-insured
uh maybe they're they're a small
business owner they don't
um they're not buying a you know part of
a participating in a group small group
plan for themselves they have uh they
would like to purchase a catastrophic
care plan a high deductible health
insurance and then pay for these sorts
of other
smaller procedures and services
themselves uh because they they view
that as a better than going the
insurance route so those are some of the
the types of people yes representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um uh in that
they take cash only they don't take
Federal insurance Medicare Medicaid are
they required to see any and all
patients that come through the door and
take care of them when they come through
the door regardless of ability to pay
right well I think that there's still
some
um some some statutes in in uh in effect
that requires uh for instance a
um addressing that right there's a uh I
think it is that that you must have a
financial assistance plan and and post
that and offer that right my
understanding is that that's part of
section 151-2 through F and that that
would still be uh in in play
um so and a lot of in in experience
um a lot of these places do offer that
too they will um they can offer
um payment plans even to uh to people
who want to to pay for things over a
long period of time in case they can't
afford it all in one go
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I'm seeing some similar we know that
this is a similar model to the direct
Primary Care model that we have in New
Hampshire and um and I happen to be a
consumer of a primary care doctor who
uses that model and
um after I had my baby recently and
wasn't working
um she actually suspended my payments
um completely and kept me on as a
patient and um do you think that there's
anything that's do do you see that um
these kind of Health Care Facilities
will also be similar in that fashion
that they may be you know the in the
interest of having
um return customers and um encouraging
people to who need this alternative
um to seek their services first of all
congratulations on the baby and I I
think yes um I think there's a great
um this this really does bring the
patient The Physician Physicians
together uh there's no other third party
involved and so you have a a closer
alignment of of Interest I think and um
this kind of return customer kind of um
you know model in ethos I think it's
good for for that relationship and so
um yeah I've sort of you know certainly
anecdotally I've heard of of those kinds
of uh those those sorts of things
happening
um and
um and and one other point that that
that comes out of what you said uh which
is that I do think this is a good
compliment for um direct primary care we
have a a small but but healthy and
growing uh direct Primary Care kind of
seen here in in New Hampshire which I
think is a good thing uh it's a nice
once again just another alternative it
might be right for you it might not be
right for somebody else but it might be
right for you and if you go that route
with the direct primary care now you
have a really good
um option that that's compatible with
that that that that it doesn't make you
feel like well I I'm going direct
primary care for my primary care but now
I have to but I'm but I'm double paying
almost for for health insurance I'm
gonna buy it but not use it right so
you've already made that decision to go
that route and so this you know having a
direct pay Healthcare facility is going
to be really
um uh good for you and anybody who goes
that so I think it actually uh
reinforces and helps the um the direct
Primary Care scene grow
in New Hampshire representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um both of both you and the
representative who testified talked
about a a very minimal uptake of these
kinds of programs and um
you know unfortunately
um in my mind we've experienced in New
Hampshire a program that was also
predicted to be very minimal but has
expanded dramatically the education
Freedom accounts and so I'm wondering if
um
in terms of the overall impact in terms
of the policies that would protect
people who are really Indigent and
couldn't pay
in terms of the policies that um
representative cushman's provider
gave out of the goodness of their heart
in terms of those kinds of protections
could you imagine writing
some of those protections actually into
the legislation so we would be assured
that this would have minimal impact on
other providers
um I suppose but I'm not sure what those
would be uh exactly I mean I think I
think it's a good approach here is to to
think of
the
landscape of options that are out there
and and not every option has to
um uh
satisfy the entire market and and so you
can have different components that are
optimal for different compo parts of the
market that and so that's what I I guess
that would be my um
uh
that'd be that'd be my response on that
I think I think that this is this is a
good option for a particular
um uh type of you know patient
particular type of consumer out there
um and allowing that to flourish
doesn't seem to me to be in conflict
with other representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question I have actually a
request along with a question uh the
first is
as a university doing some research in
this area I assume that some sort of a
study out there talking about at the
states that have implemented this policy
and what impact has had around that
facility there's some sort of data out
there that you can share with us there
aren't any big studies on this
um I I think it's a it's a relatively
new area I mean I've done uh I recently
authored a a large report for working
with the Saint Anselm uh Center for for
ethics and society that looked at both
direct primary care and
um and direct pay facilities and and
sort of what
um you know what what does the landscape
of those look like but it's not we don't
have a national measurement of of all
these or an analysis state by state of
how this has played out in all states my
report was looking at New Hampshire for
instance
um it's a relatively new
idea and uh and there's not a lot of
Health economists that I know that are
that are examining it so by can we say
to them quick thank you Mr chair so to
restate it we don't really know the
impact through research
we
there's no research out there to talk
about the impact it has on the local
area health-wise as far as the
healthcare facilities
right okay yeah I'll be clear about that
number two is my understanding is that
census is cash only it would not be
included in the patient's deductible so
if they do end up going to a facility to
use their insurance policy all the money
they paid through cash would not be
considered part of the deductible would
that be true that is correct yeah and
and that's actually
um that could be actually thought of as
a protection I I mean I suppose I mean
you're thinking of I mean it's it's it's
on the the patient to be saying all
right um if I'm willing to do that it
must be a really good deal and
um and so you know that that could be
part of the limitation there if you're
if you're you know concerned about it
spreading too fast or something like
that the in practice what we tend to see
is um that the the the price differences
in the uh are are such great that even
even with you know even being covered
for for it someplace else at a higher
price you know I mean and you could if
if uh if your insurance is offering to
to cover 80 percent of uh fifty thousand
dollar surgery well but you could get
that surgery for five thousand out of
pocket over here you know doing doing
the numbers it might still make sense to
just pay for it so that's that's how a
lot of the the personal calculations end
up being representative lay on and then
representative Weber uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
um one of the things we struggled with
is that a lot of Charity Care is
defaulting to State paid
um I I'm looking at this model and at
the lower cost it seems like it could be
a good Avenue for a charity care except
the language of this bill says that it's
paid directly by the patient and is not
reimbursed or otherwise paid by a third
party I'm wondering if changing that to
say and is not billed to a third party
would allow somebody to voluntarily
contribute to cover the cost to people
who otherwise wouldn't be able to afford
care anyways anywhere and would be a
drain drain on the system but unable to
pay their their way
yet that's a creative creative idea um
and it might yeah that might that might
be good I'm not I'm trying to think of
um you know whether I've heard of that
in other states I don't think I have so
uh that could be something that you'd
that you'd consider adding to this yeah
okay representative Weber
I'm sort of tangentially exploring that
same concept but from the other
direction
uh we heard
whatever one's thoughts are in the
charitable
um notion of this
which is completely Unwritten into the
bill
people said well you know there they
have to have an assistance plan but
isn't that Assistance Plan made a
complete mockery of by the fact that you
have absolutely Institution
by this bill has no requirement of any
sort to provide any care to anybody who
is not paying their costs in full
I'm not sure what was the question the
question is isn't it true that no matter
what all these speculations are about
charitable payments or payment you know
payment plans the institution itself is
under no obligation of any sort to
provide any sort of charity care
yeah the only
um the only thing I can point to is the
um the part about the financial
assistance plan and so yeah I don't know
how far that goes Etc or what other
components there are thank you
yes representative Nagel Mr chairman
thank you
um I'm sure you're aware of this model
already exists I can fly to Thailand
tomorrow and have this done at a
substantially lower cost than I can have
it done here what I'm struggling with
the issue again looking at other states
um I understand direct patient care in a
primary care setting I'm struggling to
understand the volumes that you're going
to need to create and run a health care
facility that there can be enough people
does that work in other states
yeah um I mean one of the most
successful examples of this is it comes
from Oklahoma there's a a couple of
Physicians started uh something that
they call the surgery center of Oklahoma
back in the late 90s and they've been
they've been uh in you know successful
and growing ever since then
um they you know a couple of their
Hallmarks is a very transparent pricing
I mean as soon as they had a website
they were putting their their prices out
on the website and um and also other
other kinds of things that some
academics think of as as amazing uh
breakthroughs it's totally natural for
them for instance to do bundle pricing
and just and to say okay for for this
type of surgery whatever else might may
or may not be involved it's just one one
single price and so you're not getting
um uh you you're not getting like a
facility fee and a physician fee and a
surgical fee and an anesthesiology fee
and everything uh kind of um uh
piecemeal like that
um and so yeah so that's um so we have
some of these other uh examples there's
there's an example that I talk about as
well in in the report that I can share
about
um a surgical center in Arkansas as well
uh Colorado
um you don't have to go to Thailand um
you can go to these other places but it
would be even night nicer if you could
do it right here in New Hampshire is is
how I'm I'm thinking of it
hey you are you up for any more
questions or you gotta get going I uh I
think I have to go I'm sorry
I don't want to make it late can you get
a copy of your written testimony
absolutely thank you thank you
let's go
I have it I have one it's a it's a big
bound thing but I can I can absolutely
lead this um and maybe we could I have a
yeah pass around I have a digital
version I can send as well
yeah absolutely did you send that to the
whole committee on digital articles
thank you
thank you sir
okay also signed up to testify in this
bill is and I I'm going to try my best
with the name Lisa d eosenza
uh from new steps next steps can
Community Services
how did I do with the last name it's uh
dino chenzo diocenzo okay sorry thank
you thank you uh thank you three minutes
ma'am
so I'm here to um just give you guys a
bit of perspective from a vendor's point
of view
um I know we've heard a lot from area
agencies and others but
um
which which which hearing are we in what
sorry we accidentally mixed one from the
house bill 608 with the house bill 69 I
apologize that was my mistake no worries
we are on House Bill 69 the same one I
just thought we have too many cooks in
the kitchen I think up here
okay all right
all right
I think there was a full moon last night
going to be hungry all right
um
I'd like to recognize Paula menahan then
from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record Paula minihan
Senior vice president state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all
our hospitals um the hospital
Association is opposed to Senate to
House Bill 69 and I do appreciate
representative McLean um talking with me
he was very gracious in his time when I
did reach out as soon as um I saw this
bill or the LSR actually so I do
appreciate that and I wanted to
acknowledge that I also will go over my
testimony but um since critical access
hospitals came up since I have been at
the hospital Association when I first
started I am uniquely qualified to talk
about critical access hospitals because
I helped them convert from a PPS
hospital or a non-critical access
hospital to a critical access hospital
so I believe that even though I tend to
not comment on others testimonies unless
asked I do believe that it is
appropriate for me to State since I
think it was representative Weber asked
relative to how critical access
hospitals could be impacted by this a 80
percent and I think that's very
important eighty percent of services
provided by critical access hospitals
are outpatient including
um outpatient surgery so just keep that
in mind
um because our critical access hospitals
which I think are near and dear to our
hearts um in the state certainly half of
them are critical access hospitals we
could not survive without them so I
think that is very important to consider
and I just wanted to to make that point
I'm happy to answer other questions but
again my my policy our policy is to not
comment on others testimony unless asked
thank you questions no I I'm not oh
sorry that's okay
um I I do um I do have my testimony um
the bill does exempt facilities
operating with membership based or
direct payment business models from
certain health facility licensing
requirements as stated and I will skip
down
um
uh to I think it was against
representative Weber was asking which
specific facilities
um and so it would include all hospitals
um including residential care and
long-term care facilities it would
include
um uh Ambulatory Surgery centers excuse
me it's not long-term care sorry it was
it they're excluded but other health
care facilities would be including
Ambulatory Surgery centers hospice
facilities urgent care centers birthing
centers in addition any special Health
Care license which is includes cardiac
catheterization which they are they can
be freestanding open heart surgery which
are not freestanding and our bypass and
mega voltage radiation which can also be
freestanding this bill would allow for
these types of facilities if if they
exclusively provide services to persons
who are membership based or make direct
payments to not accept all patients and
I think that goes to representative
Murphy's point and that is a very big
concern and I think the state of New
Hampshire and the legislature should
think about that from a policy
perspective they if they can't pay for
those Services
um these these individuals
um would not be eligible for charity
care Etc the hospitals fall under this
statute and provide care to all patients
which I think is very important this is
a cherry picking
opportunity as I think representative
Weber addressed
I'm also not aware of it's not wrapping
up please yes um I'm also not aware of
other facilities I would I would um
appreciate um seeing if they're what
other facilities throughout the country
but if you talk about Ambulatory Surgery
centers this this bill does not limit to
Ambulatory Surgery centers so our all
our hospitals would be impacted and I
just want to leave um leave this um
thought with you that if you were to
pass this bill
um what would happen if you had a
freestanding emergency room which is
allowable in this state if you have a
membership base and you have a gate at
the entrance saying that um at three
o'clock in the morning if uh just drop
parent with a sick child shows up and it
says for members only will there be a
gate if you um and then what happens to
that to that family that is um that is
really a chilling thought
um we do not believe that this bill is
appropriate for the legislature to
endorse this type of Health Care model
that excludes citizens from access to
services and and we ask that you find
this bill in expedient to legislate I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
yes representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um everybody's mentioned you know
outpatient surgeries and freestanding
surgical surgical centers uh Etc but
does this also include uh freestanding
Radiology Suites like MRI Suites yeah um
actually they are not licensed under
health facilities in the state of New
Hampshire so they would not be included
so they would not be included in this
bill they could they could do this
independent of whether this bill without
this bill they could do it independently
now thank you um and I I think the other
thing is on the direct Primary Care
model is under as I believe you know um
since um you fall under this statute is
under the Board of Medicine
um licensing so direct primary care has
nothing to do with this um and I think
that it's important that everyone
understand that that is completely
separate from what this is this is
licensing of Health Care facilities and
what all that means relative to charity
care Etc
representative King
thank you Mr chair and thank you Miss
minahan for answering questions
it seems like one of your biggest fears
is the possibility that a sick child
gets brought to an emergency room at 3am
only to find out that oh it's you know
members only and then something really
bad happens as a result of that
these types of situations exist in other
states in other countries is there any
evidence to support that having happened
like do we have you know children that
have died because they've been taken or
is this just totally hypothetical no no
evidence to back that up thank you
um thank you for the question this is
not my only concern I think I raised the
issue of our critical access hospitals I
am just it's a hypothetical because if
you were to pass this bill that
effectively could happen because this is
not limited to one type of facility and
again even if it were to limit it to
Ambulatory Surgery centers then we have
the issue of the critical access
hospitals not being able to effectively
treat to take care of the patients that
they have and if you're cherry picking
so it was just a hypothetical I've never
heard of such a system like this
anywhere to be honest in at least in the
country I I don't know about the other
countries representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question
um we brought up direct Primary Care
earlier and most a lot of the healthcare
I think all the health care facilities
in the state do provide primary care and
that part of your Revenue generation is
the direct primary care options in this
state has that affected your services at
all
um I do not have any data to
um to refer to so I cannot actually
answer that question effectively I don't
know how many there are to be honest
representative Palmer thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um going back to critical critical
access hospitals so
um I'm remembering a surgical center
opening up next to Valley Regional
Hospital when I worked there back in the
90s this was actually before critical
accessibility nearly bankrupted the
hospital because they siphoned away a
lot of things it's a little bit of a
different issue because it didn't have
to do with the payment model
but um my question is
um do you or can you get through other
state hospital associations any data on
what's happened in States that's had
this so we can see if there has been a
detriment because I know like our
critical Hospital you know there's no
margin so if we lose if we lose 10
percent of
of procedures that get reimbursed well
we're going to be in big trouble and I
think that's true in both New Hampshire
and Vermont
um I last year when this similar bill
was introduced I did reach out to my
colleagues throughout the country and
again no one had heard of this I'm very
interested in in learning um about the
states that apparently have this but it
sounds like it's specific to Ambulatory
Surgery centers but to your point
um that is the re what you just
described back in the 90s is why
Congress passed the critical access
hospitals law to ensure that that
hospitals like Valley Regional would not
go away because that is exactly what was
happening with so many critical small
hospitals throughout the country the
other thing that you're reminding me of
is um the comment that that
representative McLean made relative to
the license number of licensed beds
throughout the for all critical access
hospitals that is a that is a statutory
requirement of and you know that because
you um you are in the critical access
Hospital service area so um they cannot
by law um in order to be a critical
access Hospital you have to follow a lot
of regulations like I said that's what I
helped the hospitals do working with the
state back um in 2001 through 2005. so
they cannot have more than 25 beds or
else they would not be considered a
critical access Hospital hence why that
their license has 25 beds other
questions
uh yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr I need to get a longer hand
at least an arm
instead of looking at this as a
potential Devastation to the hospitals
west of event the hospital taking a
larger area with population wise
opening up their own cash only facility
that's not
directly owned by the hospital per se
but it's part of the Health Care system
is there anything to say the Health Care
system through a legal entity where you
have a separate cooperation that the
hospital system could in fact have in
some of the larger areas in our state
such a facility like this without having
to be competitive to you but instead of
turning the tables the other way and you
become more the person competing in this
Marketplace
not under the current licensing regime
because
under the current one but if we change
it what I'm saying is at that point in
time and we allow for this to occur is
there anything to Bar a hospital through
a separate corporation which is not
directly owned by the hospital from
getting into this kind of a Marketplace
on their own I
probably cannot answer that question
um anything that falls under the
hospital though falls under Federal
requirements and of course they cannot
and would not
um discriminate based on ability to pay
so that that is their mission
um and I think um they would not be
eager to entertain that kind of a model
um whether it's allowable or not
um because that would not I think their
Board of Trustees would would look
unfavorably upon that um because it's
discriminatory against those that cannot
pay and that is that certainly is not
their mission
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here my
question uh touches back on
representative Merchants you said that
the hospitals are would be prohibited
from doing that from federal law is that
because they take Medicare and Medicaid
payments or is there any other aspects
that make them subject to federal law on
how they operate so erisa
um the excuse me um mtala um if you have
a um a mtala which is the emergency
medical law would require anyone that is
a hospital to take everyone that comes
through the door so that has nothing to
do with Medicare that's a separate
that's a separate federal law and so if
I can follow up that if there was a that
I would there's no exemption in here for
these cash Pay Direct pay or membership
hospitals no there's no exemption for
them to that requirement is there
I don't know how that would work I don't
know
but you don't see an exemption thank you
I don't I don't understand how that
would all work
other questions
representative navel thank you Mr
chairman thanks again
um this is going to sound like a stupid
question but it's not so if I show up in
your hospital and I say I want to pay
cash would you turn me away no and as a
follow-up to that question would you
charge me a different rate than I would
if I was paying Insurance
um charges are charges
um and what's reimbursed is different
depending on what coverage you have but
I think the um one issue
does come up because we do have many um
Healthcare is complicated
um so if you have insurance whether it's
a ten thousand dollar deductible or
um a two thousand dollar or no
deductible
um you if you have insurance you're not
actually eligible for a self-paid
discount which the hospitals not all
providers in the state must adhere to
this but the hospitals do and it's also
part of the ACA that they must
um if you are self-pay you are you are
offered a discount but if you have
insurance even though it's a ten
thousand dollar deductible you do have
insurance and I think that was to
represent a Merchant's earlier point you
are not considered uninsured you're
considered you may consider yourself
underinsured but you are insured so if
you were to just pay cash but have
insurance I just wanted to qualify
because this comes up
um honestly this does come up we have a
state law and a federal law relative to
self-pay discount answer charity what
you can offer if you don't have any
insurance that is not the case if you
just choose to pay out of pocket you
I hope that makes sense thank you other
questions
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
I'll be blunt I'm not a fan of the
current system I know that many people
are not satisfied with the hospital care
we have the long wait times I think that
things like limiting beds to keep
critical access Hospital status are
things that contribute to that to
decrease patient satisfaction and put
patients in danger sometimes and I'm
just wondering hypothetically since we
were dealing with hypotheticals a minute
ago hypothetically if you know the we
passed this bill and we have direct
payment hospitals prop up and they start
to take some of the clients from the
critical access hospitals
um and hypothetically if they they're
still required to have these payment
plans so you know I I see
I see lower income people being drawn to
that because they have the payment plan
options and and lower prices for
services
um is it such a bad thing if a new
system that was more satisfying to
patients and decreased wait times and
decreased costs is it such a bad thing
if you know the system changes
foreign
so there's a lot in there
um critical access hospitals and the
reason that they converted to to
critical access Hospital status
um are are kind of complicated but one
of the um they are paid differently than
a larger facility so they have to
maintain
um all sorts of services and their cost
is their costs are reflective of that
hence why the Congress believes that
having our critical access hospitals be
stable was a very important
federal policy back in the um in the in
early 2000s when they when they passed
that law so anything to disrupt that
would be again as rep as representative
Palmer indicated the hospitals are
actually in dire Financial condition
right now and um and they the critical
including the critical access hospitals
so disrupting that so you would um I
guess the hype the hype um the
hypothetical is really bringing in new
entrants into the market
um and disrupting the current health
care System
um I do
um kind of take offense to indicating
that long wait times equates to low
quality of care I think our hospitals
experience with their patients is would
show otherwise but besides that it is
really important to maintain the current
health care system that we have and all
we're saying is just play by the rules
if you want to come in you get a license
like everyone else and you take you take
all comers and including charity care
and certainly if you want to set up a
payment plan that's great hospitals do
it all the time
and so again just play by the rules and
then you could be part of the Health
Care system that has been here for in
some cases hundreds of years
representative King thank you chairman
McDonald and thank you for taking yet
another one of my questions
at the very beginning of your testimony
I believe you said everybody loves our
critical access care hospitals but would
you believe that there are many who
actually do not and would you believe
that there are many who are so unhappy
with previous care that family members
and friends have received that they will
actually drive hours further greater
distance out of their way to go to a
different hospital other than the one
that they live nearby because they're so
unhappy with the critical access care
hospital that they live near thank you
I don't know that that
um requires an answer
um I as legislators if you have concerns
about hospitals or you're hearing from
constituents that's what we're here you
should go talk to the CEO of the
hospital you should come talk to me um
and we can address those concerns the as
I have explained before the hospitals
are in crisis right now and there is a
Workforce shortage as I think you're
well aware throughout the entire system
not not just Health Care System the
entire economy right now is in crisis
relative to getting Workforce so that is
one of the biggest issues that we're
dealing with right now but the hospitals
are committed to taking care of all
patients that they can and unfortunately
yes very very long wait times I was at a
hospital Ed the other night on as a as a
guest not as a patient and the wait
times are extraordinary extraordinary
but you know what they take every every
single one that comes in doesn't matter
if they can pay or not and there they
are they are taking care of those
patients for every single minute of
every single day so that's what I'm
proud of I'm proud of our hospitals that
are taking care of patients if you have
a problem and your constituent has a
problem I encourage you to come talk
with me and we can certainly address it
through the hospital but I don't I I
will not I don't know that I have
anything else to say thank you
alternative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Miss Monahan for everything you do in
order to provide the best care that you
can to the people of New Hampshire and
everybody that you work with I
appreciate how the system's in crisis
and I'm actually curious if it's the if
it's the unpaid care or if it's the ex
the increase in in Medicare and Medicaid
care that's paid below the sustainable
rates which of those do you think is
driving the hospitals further into
crisis those that are under the CMS
systems or those who are coming in
without any any coverage at all it is
just it is just the demand is just
extraordinary right now that is really
the issue and they are just struggling
because of um again Workforce shortages
so the entire system it's not has
nothing to do with a particular payer
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you Ms
Bennett for taking my question we talked
about the patient access but could you
speak to maybe you know but speak to the
fact that in many
towns in which a critical access
hospital is located
it's a primary economic driver for that
community so losing it is not just
losing patient access we're losing the
possibility of sustaining the community
economically as well yes
I acknowledge that we have another fact
sheet that I should give you relative to
um
to the uh actually it's part of the fact
sheet that I gave you but I have more
information that I'm happy to share with
folks because yes hospitals and health
care in general are huge economic
drivers and definitely the hospitals are
sometimes the largest employers in a
given community
other questions
I'm saying no other questions thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Greg Moore
from Americans for Prosperity
good morning Mr Moore if you can have
hold it for three minutes or so I I
shall thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh thank you the
opportunity to speak here today for the
record my name is Greg Moore I am the
state director with Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire
testifying in support of house bill 69.
fundamentally we believe that that this
is good legislation however I'll be
candid we would prefer bigger Bolder
reforms in terms of deregulating the the
health care facility space but we think
this is a good first step
part of the reason why we think this
isn't a huge step is because there
aren't any facilities that take direct
pay right now in New Hampshire
and the law that is being adjusted by
House Bill 69 wasn't passed until 2016.
so we made it all the way through 2016
without any health care direct pay
health care facilities uh taking place
in New Hampshire so that's that that's
that's part of the reason why I believe
this is not going to have a huge
transformative impact as much as frankly
we would like that however we do support
this legislation because we believe that
it provides more options to Consumers
more to that to Health Care consumers
across the state of New Hampshire who
need more options right now New
Hampshire has the highest use of high
deductible health plans in in the
country
and those those deductibles are among
the highest in the country as well for
for family plan they are the highest so
New Hampshire citizens your constituents
are paying through the nose for health
care right now and that's fundamentally
is creating creating the potential for
for for the value for the uh facilities
that might take direct pay the other
piece is that starting in 2019 when you
passed the direct Primary Care law there
are people who are becoming more
comfortable with the idea of paying for
their health care costs themselves as
opposed to going through a third party
payer
third-party payers add a huge overhead
to the system and there was some I've
seen some studies that show anywhere
between uh 35 and 60 of the health care
costs are due to a lot of this overhead
one example I saw is that there was a
National Association for independent
Physicians and they made a
recommendation that for every physician
they should have two people doing
billing
now that's obviously going to add a ton
a ton of overhead and moreover it
creates a barrier between between the
the doctor and the patient and while we
certainly understand the concerns of of
the hospitals who undoubtedly don't just
like every other business they don't
want any more competition if they could
avoid it but uh but the the focus for us
is on getting more options to the
patients again I don't I don't foresee a
major a major facility being built I
think there's almost no chance of a an
actual Hospital there is another
provision in the law that created this
all-payer provision in 2016 that
requires anyone who's seeking hospital
license to have a 24 7 emergency
department unless of course they were
they had their Hospital license before
2016 in which case they don't need to
have a 24 7 emergency department so I
don't foresee anyone that's that's going
to take a hospital license and that
hospital license is for anyone who's
going to have a patient stay overnight
if you're gonna have a patient to stay
overnight is it possible we could see an
ambulatory surgical Care Center
potentially but I think that the chances
of that are still pretty small but we
think it's a good positive step in the
right direction and I'd be happy to take
any questions from the committee okay
great thank you representative Murphy
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you you just
mentioned given patients uh I'm all for
options but you're talking about giving
patients more options are you talking
specifically and only
a payment option versus the option of
having a facility that you stand up and
has services available that cover the
broad spectrum of services that the
patients need not just the ones that are
high revenues like a surgical center or
an MRI unit but all the services that a
um a patient and family might need
thank you for the question
um I I'd point to you what happened in
2016 the biggest impact the legislation
that is would be changed by this uh
relates back to legislation Senate Bill
481 from 2016. and the biggest change
that's come out of the healthcare
landscape now that bill was put in place
because the certificate of need board
was being repealed so we no longer have
a certificate of need board
and the biggest change that we've seen
that we've seen a proliferation of
urgent care centers across across the
state now I have no doubt that that
probably has some impact on the overall
Workforce and maybe creating some of the
workforce challenges but we don't know
where Innovation will go when we start
changing policies every industry when
it's when as soon as it gets deregulated
we start to see Innovation take place
and uh those Innovations provide an
opportunity for Change and for more
growth and more new opportunities so
whether whether Health Care comes in one
one big box or is broken up into a bunch
of tiny little boxes we think it's best
for for to have the opportunity to
explore those opportunities for
Innovation because we think that those
opportunities for Innovation invariably
will provide greater greater choice for
for consumers and and likely a greater
competition for health care you know for
health care services which will drive
prices down thank you and I see a hand
over here yeah a representative profile
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Moore for taking my question so you
indicated that the the the language the
current language in the bill that
specifies
um licensed Healthcare facilities have
to accept all forms of payment dates to
2016. can you speak to the
sort of the the
landscape for critical care hospitals
before that and after that and if
possible speak to
um what is that what we've seen in other
states with with respect to critical
care hospitals uh certainly uh think of
the question
you know we worked on this issue closely
when the chairman and I happened to work
together over at DHHS
um it was it was a big issue with
working through the critical uh the
critical access hospitals
um
and I'll tell you I'll tell you that
that when you look at the I think you're
talking about you said Critical Care did
you mean critical access hospitals
yes okay sorry I just want to make sure
the report that that uh I know Jared
Rhodes spoke about his report but if you
look at his report one of the things it
does is it actually shows a map
and each critical access Hospital under
the law Senate Bill 481 same senate
senate bill that that is currently in
fact uh each critical access hospital
has a 15-mile radius around which
frankly it would be nearly impossible to
build a health care facility without
without the support of the actual
critical access hospital now consider
that 15 miles 15 mile radius is about
700 square miles
and when you lump all those
together what you end up with the map
and there is a map I encourage people to
look at it in the report it shows that
basically the only place where this
could have any effect this log is the
southeast portion of the state because
those those
critical access Hospital zones bump into
each other all across the northern
Central and western parts of the state
so so that I think it'd be really a
challenge to to even find any of these
these things now as far as the overall
stability and the health of critical
access hospitals nationally uh since the
passage of the uh the the ACA the
Affordable Care Act uh hundreds of these
have gone out of business now I don't
know if that's relates to Simply Market
forces that work across the country that
they were headed that direction anyway
but since since people started tracking
it since it passes now in New Hampshire
we have not had any despite the fact
that nationally there's a trend for its
critical access hospitals to close in
New Hampshire none of the 13 critical
access hospitals which were there when I
was at HHS they're all still there we
haven't seen a new and frankly I think
it's one of the things to consider about
the overall Healthcare landscape is that
we have not built a new hospital in New
Hampshire since 1983 three
not built a new hospital in New
Hampshire since 1983 and that was uh in
the vice chairs town uh and it's been
quite a while that our population has
grown by 50 but we haven't built a new a
new hospital
follow-up follow-up
yes you mentioned thank you Mr chairman
uh you mentioned the uh these most
likely emerging these
um
like most likely emerging in the in the
lower tier of the state can you speak to
whether you see that as potentially a
draw for patients coming from nearby
States and whether that is an economic
Boom for your whether it draws economic
activity I would say to
um to New Hampshire
certainly uh certainly
other states around us have very
restrictive regulatory policies
regarding uh regarding the facilities
licensing most of them still have
certificate of need boards that we
repealed in 2016. the uh and and so
there's always the opportunity for if we
have a new a new model that's working
well and maybe offering things at a
price point that they can't get in their
home state that they would come to New
Hampshire from somewhere else to decide
to get that care
yeah yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Moore
um we've received a lot of assurances
that this would be a very a small uptake
and that it wouldn't really affect
um hospitals although I appreciate your
bluntness when you said you would like
it to be bolder and you'd like it to
um
to Blossom and get bigger
um my question is
to what extent would organizations like
yours
play a part in promoting these
institutions where they to come into
being to to actually be to what extent
would political organizations play a
part in marketing these um
these facilities
I hadn't considered the question thank
you for the question I hadn't considered
that uh I don't think that we would I
don't think there's too much of a first
of all
and I think you're you're
talking maybe about some of the uptake
on the on the EFA uh
but there's no Market at this point you
you can't Market to something that
doesn't exist it would be my initial
take is that that there are no of these
none of these facilities so you can't
say go to this facility that doesn't
exist
follow up follow up I'm talking about if
this type of legislation passed and they
did start to exist
Healthcare is so personal uh that
doctor-patient relationship is so
critical I I don't think there's a space
for that
um I think that that what would drive it
more than anything is the transparency
and the pricing
thank you representative Leon uh thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here or hearing all sorts of issues
about the workforce shortage but we
don't have to hear about it because we
know it's real
um by having one of these facilities
that would allow a doctor to choose how
they they practice like it used to be
like when many doctors went to medical
school as opposed to the more employee
relationship that a lot of doctors now
experience do you think that that would
help retain doctors that are later in
their career maybe attract others who
are dissuaded by the employee version of
a medicine and do you think that it
could help retain people that object to
some of the CMS requirements
thank you for the question uh I would I
would say that I've had a chance to talk
with some of the direct primary care
doctors people who are offering direct
Primary Care
and they will and of course all of them
came out of the the old system that or
the employee system as you described and
I they they are uniformly uniformly
thrilled to be away from that uniformly
thrilled to be away from that might that
cause some to either stay in the area or
or have the opportunity to uh practice
longer I think there's certainly a
possibility but but I will say that the
satisfaction from these doctors who are
offering direct Primary Care is is high
and I know that I know that uh the the
saint anselves paper I did a
satisfaction survey and they reached out
to these direct primary care doctors and
I and I think that the data are in the
report
thank you representative Seth King
thank you chairman McDonald uh
representative Leon and I think a lot
alike because I was going to ask the
exact same question except I was going
to ask about nurses my understanding is
there are a lot of nurses that have
recently left the workforce a lot of
them are very unhappy with working
within the Legacy system do you think
that you could bring back nurses to the
workforce if there was an alternative
system as well thank you thanks for the
question uh I'll just say that I'll just
say that
I interviewed somebody for a position
with our organized with our organization
who came out of the nursing field and
she's she left the practice of nursing
uh because of the frustrations with the
existing system and that was an
interview I had yesterday so it's fresh
in my mind
um and here I was thinking man we need
you in nursing but that's their choice
that's their their choice and and if we
have a system that that's taking these
highly skilled professionals out of the
out of the system I think it's I think
it's obviously bad now there are other
options for some nursing there's there's
some private duty nursing there's some
other options that can't exist other
than being jammed into the Legacy system
uh but I think that again creating more
opportunity just again this type of
innovation we don't know what would
happen should uh should should this
should we have the system start and
again
unfortunately I don't think there's
going to be unless we see the direct
direct I think the direct primary
facility
growth would track alongside direct
Primary Care growth I think that's the
two have to ride hand in hand and uh
keep in mind I will I will add one thing
uh
when we pass this law in in 2016
. uh one of the real focus of putting
the all-payer provision in
and I guess I have to back up to 2011.
2011 uh in 2011 and I think maybe
representative McKay was the only one
around for that uh there was a bill to
Simply outright repeal the con board and
pass the house and then went to the
Senate and they said okay let's give it
three years and so it was going to be in
2014 and then in the budget in 2013 they
said let's kick it out another two years
so it went to 20 to 2016. and ultimately
ultimately uh uh one of the provisions
of of uh that the basis for the 2011 law
uh was that some folks wanted to invite
a cancer treatment facility into into
New Hampshire who said that they would
come to New Hampshire if the state got
rid of its certificate uh certificate of
need law
and that that Pro that hospital did not
take all payers
they did not take all payers and I
suspect that that some of the provisions
you see are based upon and frankly if
you went and looked up the Senate
testimony from Senate Bill uh 481 you
actually saw oncologists coming in
saying we need essentially saying we
need to keep Cancer Treatment Centers of
America out of New Hampshire so I
suspect that's that's some of the basis
of of uh why that law went into effect
but it's also important remember that in
2016 we were under a very different
landscape
um
right okay if you could
we need to move on any other questions
yes representative Cushman
thank you for taking my question and
thank you Mr chairman
um can you speak a little bit
um so I could pay about 600 700 a month
and receive primary care and instead I
pay 250 for my entire family and all of
our Primary Care is covered and they
have group buy-in for lab so the labs
are really cheap and I don't have any
co-pays can you speak to what the cost
savings may look like for a person who
chooses to utilize services at a direct
payment facility
I I'd ref reference what Mr Rhodes said
earlier uh speaking he's spent a lot
more time looking at this longitudinally
than I have
um I think if you look at if you look at
the he references the surgery center of
Oklahoma
and talking about prices pricing being
uh 50 or less of what they get in a
facility that has to go through the
tradition more traditional
um more traditional payment methods so
uh he'd probably be a better reference
than I okay other questions
name
I'm seeing no other questions
oh representative Nagel okay thank you
Mr chairman um thanks for taking my
question I'm just curious are you
familiar with the Laser Spine Center of
Florida
I'm sorry I I'm not familiar with it
thanks they pretty much operate on under
the model you talked about
um their prices were extravagant and
eventually they went out of business for
legal reasons but what are the one of
the interesting things about direct pay
is that if you look squarely at if you
look squarely at Lasix which is a
procedure that's not covered by
insurance
um the Lasix procedure has both improved
qualitatively as you'd expect the
petitioners do it more often they're
going to get better at it but also the
pricing has has dropped dramatically and
part of the thought on that is that
because
it is not covered by insurance and it is
a competitive environment that we've
seen the prices really drop so I'm not
familiar about the specifics I don't
know if lace if Lasix is what they were
offering in Florida
oh they even use lasers yeah just name
just call themselves laser okay it's
good marketing other questions
okay thank you very much
and the last person signed up to testify
um
Alex catrubis from nhhca
good morning good morning thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee
my name is Alex katrubis I'm here to
represent long-term care facilities both
for-profit and non-profit
nursing homes private nursing homes and
we are opposed to house bill 69.
as you've heard right now in New
Hampshire we do not have a certificate
of need process we do not have a
certificate of need process in the
nursing home World either but we do have
a bed moratorium which the nursing home
strongly support and we support it
because our Health Care system is
interconnected and considerable taxpayer
dollars are involved if the balance
of Care Resources is upset then the
unintended consequences could be
disastrous
the language of House Bill 69 may sound
unobjectionable to the layperson simply
exempting the requirement that a
facility provided services to all
persons who require the services the
facility provides regardless of the
source of payment for the services
provided to any person any facility
that is on a membership basis business
model or exclusively provide services to
a person
who make direct payment for services now
that's directly from the bill so what's
the harm you may ask is this not a free
market operation yet those questions
ignore the interconnectedness of our
system
if a particular facility can cherry pick
those who are private paying and ignore
all others the burden will fall more
heavily upon taxpayers or the insured to
subsidize those facilities that do not
contract to those served by Medicaid
Medicare or private insurance
if this bill would be applied to nursing
homes for example private Medicaid
Contracting facilities would collapse
flooding the County nursing homes
and you as representatives of your
county delegation would have to foot the
bill for that
in signing the emergency medical
treatment and Labor Act law in 1986 no
less a champion of the free market than
President Ronald Reagan recognized that
Health Care Facilities providers have a
societal obligation prior to that point
a hospital could turn away even a dying
person unable to pay for his or her care
resulting in some facilities dumping
patients upon those facilities committed
to serving all in need
but it would appear that house bill 69
would close the emergency room doors
that Reagan opened at least where a
facility is membership based or only
accepting direct payment for services so
with that I have some other things I
could say but there's a lot of folks
behind me who are from the public who
want to speak on these other bills so
with that Mr chairman I will submit the
written testimony and suspend okay thank
you very much you're welcome
representative Weber
just a very brief clarification because
I thought at one point I heard somebody
else say that this bill would not cover
the nursing homes that is correct it
would not I read it as it would not
cover the nursing homes however you all
you heard the previous speaker talk
about how this is only the beginning and
you know it could be the camel's nose
Under the Tent a slippery slope whatever
you want to call it but as it stands
right now it would not impact the nurse
so could I could I follow up so you're
just concerned about what the next step
is you're not concerned about the
effects of this bill we are we are we
agree with the hospital Association we
serve folks on Medicaid all of the
private nursing homes to take Medicaid
patients and and we care about
folks that don't have resources who may
need care so we stand in solidarity with
with the hospitals but it does not
directly impact nursing homes thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
last session we heard uh we heard some
bills on direct pay in nursing homes and
long-term care however we were told that
that already is available that there is
no all payers requirement and I was just
curious
um I was just curious if we were
misinformed last year
I'm not sure I understand your question
my question is it's my understanding
that nursing homes and long-term care
are not required to take all payers so
therefore they already have this freedom
that that that is true but all 99 of the
nursing homes take Medicaid
in New Hampshire we have to have a
balanced system where we have private
pay we have people who have long-term
care insurance we have some people who
pay out of pocket uh we we need all of
the the different sources of revenue for
reimbursement into the mix if we don't
have that it's going to fall on the
taxpayers to foot the bill thank you
other questions
any other questions
okay saying none
uh thank you you're welcome
I have no one else signed up to testify
on HP 69 does anyone else wish to
testify
seeing no one I am closing the public
hearing on hb69
and we are returning to the public
hearing on HB 308 608 I'm sorry
um also um
I know we've got we're going to go
through all the pink cards uh and
everyone will be um is welcome to
testify uh but we do want to point out
that we're also going to have a work
session on this bill on March 8th and uh
it's a obviously an important issue
there's a lot of interest and because
you filled out a pink card today you
don't necessarily need to testify today
you'll have that opportunity on March
8th also
so with that
um there was a lady here earlier from
one sky and I I would welcome her back
if she's still here and again I my
apologies for the earlier confusion
thank you chairman McDonald my name is
Janan Archibald I am a legislative
liaison from one sky and I'm here
because I've received testimony from two
family members and while I realize it's
not appropriate to read the testimony I
would just like to introduce it and then
pass it out for you to read
um at your convenience so the first one
is the story of a single mom who has
raised her child with complex
disabilities and she was searching for a
Day program and you'd think that would
be a relatively easy thing to do but
unfortunately it's not between his
complex disabilities and then this
individual also suffered from severe
physical and emotional abuse in Prior
care those two came together and it made
it very difficult to find an appropriate
program for him to enter into they
finally found a program that works great
and he's thriving but the provider just
informed this family member that they
will not be doing direct billing to
Medicaid any longer so now she is
wondering what to do with her son and
you can read her story here
the second the second testimony is from
another single mom who was talking about
when the state switched from a fee-based
service to an HMO service for Medicaid
and what ensued after that transition
evidently some of the providers that
they use in specialists in Boston
weren't part of the provider Network so
it left her child without care until the
state was able to roll back the program
for the disability community and work
out the details so that is this
testimony and I will also email it to
you with our direct contact information
if you'd like to reach out to them
directly
thank you thank you
questions
any questions
seeing none okay thank you very much
also signed up to testify on hb608 is
Lisa diocenzo from next steps Community
Services
foreign
for the earlier confusion no problem
thank you
so I was asked to um speak on um to give
you some perspective from a vendor I am
a vendor that I'm the executive director
of next steps community services and
we're a pretty small agency that
provides
um its which is intensive treatment
services we have nine programs
amongst the state we serve 30 people
that have
intellectual disabilities mental health
disorders and who and or who are Justice
involved we have 32 beds in our programs
two of which are um designated receiving
facility Beds which the state of New
Hampshire is required by law to have we
provide person-centered holistic
intensive treatment to those 30
individuals
um a sample of our clients just so you
know what kind of folks that we serve we
had one guy that was in New Hampshire
hospital for 14 years
we have another person that was
um
in the spew the specialized psychiatric
unit in Concord for many many years and
was going back and forth between there
and the designated receiving facility
we have a gentleman that has autism that
pretty much you know not pretty much but
no one else in the entire state would
serve so those are the kinds of folks
that we serve the most about very
challenging and vulnerable people
a few years ago we were told that we
would be our way of conducting business
now would be changing
um and to be honest we were kind of
excited and happy about that because
although change is difficult it's also
um a good thing that we were moving from
individualized budgets to rate setting
within this new system
um that we were changing from area
agencies doing the billing for us
passing it through to us to us vendors
being required to do direct billing
so in April 2021
we next steps um
applied to become a Medicaid provider
and along the way we've checked in with
folks to see where we were in that
process and we were told this past fall
that there was someone within the state
that were vetting these applications for
vendors so as we stand right now this is
almost two years later
we still don't have a provider number
yet with Medicaid
um
so what's more concerning even than that
because I'm sure that could get worked
out is that we don't have really a
comprehensive thorough plan on this new
system we don't have we I'm talking its
vendors providers don't have
um what it really looks like what do our
rates really look like what is the rate
structure
um when are we going to get the rates
when will we receive the rates when
we'll be will we have a chance to
negotiate those rates
um
the consequences of of that is that what
if we can't sustain the business that
we're currently doing within those rates
what will happen to again we only have
30 clients that we serve but these are
30 clients that have already been proven
to not be able to get services with
anybody else if we if we as an agency
can't sustain business and provide these
services to these folks they will
be going that's not wrapping up please
they will be going out of state at a at
an extremely higher cost and I will not
be able to sustain my very small agency
of
of that that we do very important work
for people that again it's a small
majority of the DD population but it's
an important
sector
okay thank you yeah any questions uh
representative Weber
thank you very just very briefly you
told us about the number of persons you
serve could you tell us very briefly
maybe the number of full-time equivalent
jobs you have
about
120 staff members
is that what you mean yes and follow-up
follow-up are those full-time or
part-timers full-time okay yeah thank
you very much
yes representative Nutter upon
thank you for taking my question
um a couple years ago I chaired a
commission on Senate Bill 86 and um
it was our understanding that we have we
had like 40 people in New Hampshire
whose
um disabilities mental
judicially involved and wherever we're
so severe that they were sent out of
state mostly to Florida for the tune of
like
380 000 a year
um for their care and do you have those
similar kind of patients in your
facilities Yes actually I mean again I
think we're in the its
program service model there's only about
you know 60 or so beds for those folks
of course we're interested in growing
capacity so that we can take some of
those folks back from Florida and other
states Pennsylvania Massachusetts
whatever
um but again where
we're questioning whether we're going to
be able to do business I can't I can't
go to my board and say everything's
going to be fine this fiscal year when I
don't even know what our rates are right
now thank you so thank you okay thank
you other questions
any other questions
saying none thank you very much thank
you
also signed up to testify is Ellen
mckayan from csni
good morning
good morning my name is Ellen McCann
I'm the executive director of Community
Support Network which is the association
of area agencies
uh and several of the CEOs have spoken
this morning I want to thank you for the
opportunity to testify on behalf of HB
608 and act for establishing a pilot
program to support the Bureau of
Developmental Services redesigned
I've been referring to this redesign
work as system transformation work
because that is truly what's happening
A system that has been in place for over
35 years is being transformed and how it
delivers and is reimbursed for services
this is more transformation than at any
time in the system's history
all being done while we are recovering
from a pandemic and experiencing an
unprecedented Workforce shortage
we support the need for this
transformation work as it will update
some Antiquated processes and bring us
into compliance with Federal Regulations
which is needed to obtain our federal
match dollars but and you've heard this
in a couple of other testimonies we are
for change done right
the transformation requires the
following
an overhauled I.T system
revised core fundamental rules and a new
rule
re-engineering many critical business
processes
new and revised extensive documentation
comprehensive training a new slate of
rates
thoughtful organizational restructuring
and change management with thousands of
employees
families and individuals
that's a lot
system transformation is no small tasks
these components I just itemized need to
work together seamlessly like the gears
of a clock changes must be modeled out
tested and piloted
why
to ensure new processes are fully
understood and that they work that rates
are viable and that everyone understands
their role and responsibilities in the
new system
this is change done right
and this is the spirit behind hb608 an
approach that ensures the least
disruptive go live there are some things
we want to talk about with
representative Edwards that may impact
the Bill's language a bit we want to
make sure we utilize the right pilot
approach to ensure the stability and
sustainability of the system
the individuals and families this system
serves deserve no less they must have a
stable system to ensure that the
services that support them in living
fulfilling lives are not disrupted
individuals and families must not be the
collateral damage in achieving
compliance by meeting a date
large projects of this nature typically
have Pilots of varying kinds scenario
analyzes system testing extensive
modeling of rates and processes and
we're confident we can work with the
division of long-term supports and
services and its Consultants to make
this happen you can begin wrapping up
please yes
um I will say
um
on October 1st 2013 there was another go
live date that was the federal health
care exchange and if you recall that go
live date the system was up for two
hours six individuals across the country
were able to enroll before they took it
down
that was not a go live that went well
they identified
Harvard Business School analysis in
identifying what went wrong said
basically there were three things too
much work to do and not enough time the
inability to test efficiently and blind
adherence to a date
they could easily push out the date to
fix that situation but our system
transformation go live is different
implementation misses yes
we have to get it right we have to get
it right okay thank you yep questions
any questions
okay thank you very much
also signed up to testify is Michelle
schladen Houghton from region 8.
okay sorry I I knew I was not going to
get that correct really I wanted to give
it a try
good morning
thank you
foreign
it's okay take your time ma'am
we're all looking to help so just talk
like you're talking amongst friends
foreign
[Music]
in
different
[Music]
consumer
lunch
in life
one
determination
um
two
two things
like
one
my own arms
business
um
accents
my
community
um
and in
drawing
um
everything's call me
life
then any
one of
them nice teasers
[Music]
hey
it's so important
this
film I think it is
um important
tint to
know
what the read design
is going
to look like four
I couldn't
consumers and families
um
I
has
this is seen a
went to the
Korean since I haven't seen
in the potentials
um
too
distinct I'm waiting from nerves
families
and
I
don't think
this is
what
new
yeah I'm sure
in
tense four
four
five
Genie
community
um
thank you very much
for listening
thank you very much for coming here this
morning thanks
do you have any questions
[Music]
do you want questions ma'am that wasn't
does anyone have any
no
yes representative profile
would you believe that some of the most
impactful testimony we hear when we sit
on the side of the table comes from the
people who are directly affected
at in their everyday lives so thank you
for being here
other questions
anyone else okay
yes representative Weber
I just wanted to thank you for your
courage because it isn't easy to sit
there in front of all of us despite the
fact that there's nobody here who isn't
rooting for you we're just trying to
figure out the best thing to do but
thank you for coming and thank you for
your courage and thank you for your
advocacy thanks
um what do you mean
currently
um
on a medical model homes
um that was
um
you know repeat fully and stamped so I
can concern
trained on
you know the being a
[Music]
contributing back
to my community
um
there are a lot of
individuals that you don't need some
work put our links in satisfy
um and
um skills
um
and again
contribute back soon not on
one side of the steam giving us money
and
conditioning down to
and spend and giving us the opportunity
to
continue
and maybe in
Inspire my name is went to
developmental
disability
to actually
get in
2001 Florence and you know maybe
volunteers
sent out into speed
and speak
to you all you know so and thank you for
your time
thank you thank you thank you for coming
in
also sign
also signed up to testify is Deborah
descansa
from Exeter
good morning I think it's so morning
isn't it just really
uh you have five minutes now if you
could hold it to three please oh
uh my name is Deborah descents I'm a
resident of Exeter uh and I'm in support
of the pilot program
I am the mother of an adult man who
receives Services through the Bureau of
Developmental Services I am because of
him I founded an agency farmsteads of
New England over 20 years ago
to provide services for him and others
we are a fairly small agency we serve
approximately 40 individuals
uh in both day and and or Residential
Services
we have a budget of about four million
dollars uh and have about 80 employees
most of whom are full-time and most of
whom are providing Direct Care we have a
skeleton crew uh in terms of the
administrative office
I I have
three aspects of the system change that
are worrisome right now the first is
direct billing
uh when I first heard about direct
billing I thought well that's nice you
know we'll have an option we can bill
for ourselves or we can continue to have
the area agencies built for us
but what we have learned uh in recent
months is that we can only have one
agency bill for us the one trading
partner as they call it so even though
we have contracts with six of the area
agencies we would have to find one
agency willing to do all our billing
um some of the area agencies have
recently announced that they do not have
the infrastructure and will not be able
to bill for uh agencies
um
there is one agency that has said they
are going to spend the money to improve
their infrastructure and they will do
the billing for anyone who wants
and while the individual price seems
reasonable it would end up costing us
for our 40 individuals twenty thousand
dollars a year
and that is twenty thousand dollars we
don't have
uh under the current
um
current system
uh I can also say that uh I'm a member
of the private provider Network so
there's about 20 agencies
um who I can't say that I speak for all
of them but I can say that in
discussions with the PPN group everyone
is concerned uh how are they going to
handle this we have had no training in
how to do direct billing if we make a
mistake it can take months to correct
that mistake and to be paid and small
agencies like marcelves
cannot wait months to get paid because
my 80 employees need their paycheck this
week
um the second area is the prior
authorization wrapping up man please yep
prior authorization system again we've
had no training in how to do prior
authorizations even though we'll be
required to
uh and again there's going to be an
expense to that and the rates haven't
been set yet so we have no idea
what the rates will be and if it will
cover that
um
uh and then the rates themselves a large
part of the
um
the way the rates are being developed
is based on 2021 data uh that the
various agencies have provided and the
cost reports uh in 21 2021 data is based
in large part on historical budgets that
may have been developed 10 or 15 years
ago because we don't get cost of living
increases every year
um so
they're not they're not sufficient we
that's part of why this is Staffing
shortage today because we can't pay
staff enough
to do the important work they do and
I'll wrap it up there I have submitted
this testimony electronically a couple
days ago so great thank you I appreciate
that
could could we do you have a hard copy
with you right now I do have one hard
copy with me that'd be great if we could
get it for the clerk
um any questions
I'm seeing no questions okay thank you
very much for coming in thank you
thank you also signed up to speak is
Kathy spinney from Pelham
I'm going to hand you some written stuff
for later
thank you
that written testimony speaks to the
what
and again you have three minutes that
written testimony speaks to the what of
what we're hoping to accomplish with
this legislation I'm going to speak to
you now about the why
um I am a parent of a 40 year old young
woman who requires complete support she
cannot walk speak do anything
independently I'm a single parent she
lives at home with me therefore I am by
definition part of her Hands-on Physical
direct support team along with paid
staff I also run a small business
why this bill is important is because as
you've already heard from the beginning
a lot of this work let's put the federal
mandate stuff aside over here for now a
lot of the other initiatives that have
come out of the a m report were done
completely without our input
and as you can imagine there's nothing
worse than having someone at thirty
thousand feet look at you and say I know
what you need
instead of asking you
we weren't asked
and if we were asked we would have had a
very different list of things that we
saw
as Hands-On part of the caregiving team
that we needed in terms of initiative
supports where the state should be
putting its attention
I will remind you that our entire system
was created by us from the bottom up it
was families that initiated the lawsuit
that closed Laconia State School it was
families that initiated Family Support
legislation it was families who before
the area agencies existed started their
own little day programs Kimmy Nichols
Center Debbie voter Center there are
numerous of them came from us
things like participant manage and
directed Services which is a model
option of managing your own supports
came from us and the reason our system
has historically always been highly
ranked in the top five nationally is
because we have been a bottom-up system
and we've luckily had the opportunity to
collaborate with the state on building
that and the lens historically had been
from the state perspective of how will
that decision affect the uses of the
system first and foremost let's look at
that before we pull a trigger on
anything that has not happened here
why this legislation is important it's
one of the few opportunities we have to
slow down look at the things that aren't
federally mandated and make sure that we
on the ground the families who
ultimately are going to have to clean up
the mess if any one piece of it isn't
proven to work that's why this is
important it's crucial that families and
individuals that use the system be
literally part of the team that will
create these Pilots
Define what we want these Pilots to
prove
administer the pilots and do the
analysis of the data that is those
crucial seats must must be held by users
of the system
we are the experts in the field
make no mistake
and I have no question about many
well-meaning people that work up at 30
000 feet looking trying to fix things
but
ignorance is no excuse even if you're
well-meaning
we need to be asked
we need to be shown and when you get a
chance to look at the written testimony
I gave you I'd call your attention to
the second sheet where I give you some
math of the value
based on statistics and I've cited all
my data last year the value of the free
supports families provide often to their
own death
and I'll leave you with this the
direction things are going which are
back to Medical model thinking siloing
people
and
restricting freedom of how each
individual gets to choose what they want
their life to look like
I have no faith in that direction and as
a parent who will be in a couple of
weeks will be 65. my best option right
now of what I'm hoping for is that my
daughter dies before I do
and that's a pretty awful thing for a
parent to have to hope for I hope none
of you ever have to hope for that
but we can fix it if we slow it down and
ask us and that's what this bill seeks
to do thank you
questions
yes representative gophalt
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so and in the uh at
the bottom of the uh first page of the
materials you handed us you refer to a
concern that service definitions are
being changed and you make the statement
that
um
how they are defined matters very
specifically so I'm wondering if you
could speak to that a little bit further
for us thank you I'll give you an
example I I work in the field of patents
and I work with a lot of patent
attorneys and when a patent attorney
writes the claims of why this is a
unique invention they try to make those
claims very broad that's always the goal
and because you want to you want as many
little variations to fit and still have
protection
umbrella definitions of services would
be like
if you want this service you need to
pick something that's blue
well this navy blue aqua teal light blue
sky blue Etc you get a lot of
flexibility to find a blue
but if service definitions are narrowed
to say you can have the navy blue one or
the powder blue one
well that narrows how you're going to
choose to implement your idea of a life
and if you read any of in our law if you
read any of the history of this system
it has always been designed and worked
toward allowing an individual with a
disability to access what I call my word
an ordinary life the similar kind of a
life that you would have be able to make
the similar kind of choices that you
have do the similar kinds of things that
you would want to do but obviously with
needing some supports and get as close
to that as we possibly can as close to
that Equity of a good life
and when you narrow service definitions
to plug them into a rate that by
definition
Narrows flexibility and freedom and we
haven't seen them yet that's the point
maybe they'll be wonderful and terribly
Broad
but
how can you implement something we again
on the ground haven't seen yet so we can
at least advise you if there's an
unintended consequence to that decision
at least at least thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
would you agree or disagree that in
order to have a pilot
program
it's essential that we actually have a
design to Pilot
so what I'm hearing throughout this
testimony is that we really don't even
have a good design yet on the table
so if we don't have a good design on the
table
how can we have a pilot program if we
don't have the design in place in other
words if you're going to have a model
car you design the car and then you
create the model and you test it but I
don't see a design yet as everybody's
agreed to I think what we have is the
set of questions or a good start on the
set of questions that need to be
answered because we've been asking them
um you know in addition to a parent just
to give you background I am a governing
officer of one of the area agencies so
I'm a board member I am on the
developmental Services quality Council
since its Inception and was chair for
the first seven or eight years of it and
I am on multiple committees
related to the redesign process
so I'm a knowledgeable parent I'm a
knowledgeable member of this
constituency we have asked many many
many very detailed specific questions we
do not have answers to and some of these
Pilots would be geared to answering
those questions if you want one example
I can give it to you but I don't want to
monopolize time thank you other
questions
seeing no other questions
okay thank you very much
just so everyone knows what what the
plan is we we are running behind but we
are going to finish up this bill and
what the plan is then to break for lunch
and then take up the remaining two bills
which are HB 238 and hb2 HB 317 and then
of course we'll be proceeding into
executive sessions so if you're waiting
for those other two bills we just want
to let you know what the plan is
representative Weber
just for planning purposes I am aware am
I correct in thinking we only have one
early Bill still left to exec I think
it's two isn't it we have two early
bills to exec and we have another one
that's looming on a May 11th Federal
expiration of benefits so we have three
that must be out today okay
um I'm just concerned because uh we have
those execs that are time critical we
have Bill hearings that are not time
critical but understandably concerning
for the people who have been waiting for
them uh but a number of us also have
time issues at the end of the day so I
just want to be sure that we're planning
for that because it has been our
practice not to go past a certain time
and I think people plan on that we're
definitely going to take up the time
sensitive executive session bills okay
thank you thank you
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman I would just like to remind the
committee and people in the audience
that one of the bills coming up
um House Bill 238 involves
um
some of the similar ideas of what we've
been talking about which is really about
um people who are most affected being
represented in the process so
I know this oh people want to have their
say and people want to ask their
questions but there there's going to be
some overlap when we talk about 2 30
when we have a hearing for 238
thank you
anyone else
okay hearing saying no one no other
comments moving on the next person who
uh who has signed up to testify on hb608
is Virginia Cannon um from Concord
ma'am you've asked for five minutes if
you could cut it down to three it'd be
great
I will endeavor to read quickly sir okay
thank you
um and the only question I have is how
do I submit this to you because I just
brought my copy to read
how do I if you can just give it to the
clerk okay because I've got notes on it
is that okay that's okay okay
thank you
good afternoon
um I'm here to ask you or to oppose as
written uh House Bill 608 my name is
Gina Cannon and I live here in Concord
with my husband and my daughter
prior to my daughter's birth I practiced
law in Concord in Manchester
I worked for New Hampshire DHHS as a
hearings officer
and following her birth in order to have
the flexibility needed for her care I
ran my own business as a private
Professional Guardian for over a decade
I also worked for a brief stint in
low-level administration at our local
area agency and most recently served as
a term on our school board
but that's me and that's not why I'm
here today I'm concerned for my daughter
my daughter has multiple medical issues
which result in her having considerable
developmental delays and which require
complex Medical Care
we are lucky
she's incredibly smart verbal and
opinionated and she will in all
likelihood never be able to live
independently and will be dependent upon
the DD waiver system
although she's very bright with her
combined disabilities according to a
recent study by the National Institute
of Health the longitudinal probability
of her obtaining sufficient life skills
and or employment sufficient to allow
her to live an independent life is
statistically zero
let me repeat that studies show despite
an intellect well above average she will
likely never be able to live
independently due to her developmental
disabilities
she will turn 18 in just over six weeks
and will start her transition into the
world of Adult Services her father and I
are justifiably concerned about the
quality of life she can expect to have
I have seen wonderful Services provided
within our DD waiver system and
appallingly horrific failures to provide
minimally appropriate services
I do not believe there is a single
person in attendance today who would
willingly live The Limited lives that
some of our adult intellectually and
developmentally disabled individuals
live
they are for the most part not the full
meaningful lives rich with relationships
experiences and opportunities to
contribute that we would want for our
loved ones
please make no mistake our system needs
significant correction
but therein lies the difficulty and I do
not envy your responsibilities today for
after hours and hours of reading
listening talking to various people with
various points of view I sit before you
this morning to ask you to look at hb608
with the same lens that you look at the
underlying BDS restructuring with some
healthy skepticism and wariness
we've heard today change is difficult
people are afraid of the change people
don't understand the change the
underlying redesign has insufficient
details at this point for individuals
family members area agencies vendors or
frankly anyone else to know with any
degree of certainty whether this
redesign will be positive or negative in
the lives of some of our most vulnerable
citizens you can begin wrapping up man
yep at the same time this bill has
insufficient details to know whether
enacting it would be of harm or benefit
we have no standardized assessments
across the state we have no standardized
implementation we have no idea of the
destination of this pilot project and
how in the world do you know if you've
arrived if or whether you need to
backtrack if you have no goals
in my opinion neither HP 608 nor the
current redesign has sufficient
infrastructure at this time to advance
and both need to return to the drawing
board to develop infrastructure prior to
a rollout of either the plan or a pilot
um I've just most problematically
however is the distressingly imminent
deadline centered by uh sorry set by CMS
um the state of New Hampshire has known
of this correction of action necessary
since 2016 and we still have
insufficient details of how we are going
to comply this potentially risks 162
million dollars that's 50 funding for
approximately 5500 of our most
vulnerable citizens
okay thank you ladies and gentlemen I
don't envy you but this Mass has
unfortunately dropped squarely in your
lap thank you questions
any questions any questions for this yes
representative McLean yeah uh thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question so it sounds like if I'm
teasing out what you're saying you have
a problem not just with the pilot but
with the redesign as well so as you say
say you're opposed to it as written so I
guess what what approach would you be
advocating
um at this point well I think one of the
things that's been suggested is that
we're putting the cart before even
knowing whether it's a horse cart or a a
goat cart we don't know we need more
details I would like to see BDS roll out
a pilot project itself but at this point
we don't have enough of a plan to know
we have a pilot
unfortunately I don't think we can move
forward requiring a pilot when we don't
have an underlying plan
other questions
okay thank you very much thank you very
much
I'm sorry representative King can I
approach that oh absolutely please come
up
it's not Court yeah it's not Court I
don't look good in Blacks
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Will Walker
from Hollis
thank you for the opportunity to speak
today thank you thanks for being here my
name is Will Walker my wife Kelly and I
live in Hollis with our 23 year old son
who has autism
he requires 24 7 observation okay so
we're directly impacted by the change
Happening Here
um I've also in knee deep in this
systems change I'm on two committees two
working groups uh where the systems
change one is The Advisory Group and one
is on the rates working group okay so
I'm not just an outsider I'm also kind
of have an inside view of what's going
on and I'm concerned and I'm here to ask
for your support for HP 608
um I've spent several decades in the
software industry okay and as part of
that I've released many projects and
what you do in releasing a project is
you develop a a test plan you develop
success criteria you develop metrics for
what it means to go live with your
project we call this a beta we'll go to
Beta and we'll release it to a small set
of customers see how it works out flesh
out the problems find the unknowns and
improve improve the software before we
go live for the general public okay I
don't see that being done here and I
think hb608 allows us to do that okay
and the the other thing I've been I've
been on a date driven deadline and the
results are usually a disaster okay my
phone rings at 3 am in the morning I'm
on the phone the next day with the
president of the company asking me why I
cost a customer you know millions of
dollars and lost because of a bug in our
software okay we we don't want that to
happen here right we we want our most
vulnerable citizens to be in a stable
system okay so I support the idea of
testing and vetting this system and
making sure it's going to serve our
citizens our most vulnerable citizens
appropriately before it goes live okay
so I support that and I'll just add one
more just you know anecdote my bank did
a systems change okay my it's I won't
say who the bank is but they did a
systems change what happened
are automatic bill payments failed okay
so we weren't paying our electric bills
we weren't paying our other bills that
impacted us very negatively okay let's
take that and now say okay this system
change happens and there's a bug in it
and it's not about my electric bill
anymore it's about whether my son
receives Services it's about whether his
direct support professional shows up to
provide the services from that day okay
that's that's what we're risking here
and as an Insider into this what I'm
seeing is that the devil is in the
details okay these details surface every
meeting a new issue comes up every
meeting we don't understand the whole
thing okay so a new issue comes up and I
think Einstein said you know as the
circle of light grows so does the circle
of Darkness okay so come out of these
meetings and yes I understand that much
better now but oh no I've got this many
more questions than arose okay so when I
see that and as somebody who has led
projects and released them I am
concerned that this is going too fast a
pilot program will help us figure these
things out better and do a much better
job so we don't upset the system
thank you thank you questions yes
representative Shapiro
yes thank you
um Mr chairman and thank you for taking
this question I understand that you're
in favor of the concept of having a
pilot program and in reading the bill
um
it talks about
the pilot program addressing and then it
says topic shall include and it I won't
I won't read it all but it includes
various topics and then it says any
additional changes to the existing
system of care not defined in the
contracts you'll also be included in the
pilot program so the pilot program
for my understand meager understanding
of it is um
is quite a a big pilot program I mean
it's covering a lot of a lot of topics a
lot of changes
um do you think there's
what do you think it'll
take to uh to design a pilot program and
incorporate all these changes into the
pilot and and and and addendum to that
question is can that be done by the um
current
um
expiration time so thank you for that
question I I think there's two two
changes that we're looking at here right
there's one for the July 1st corrective
action plan okay that one still has
unanswered questions still unknown okay
so we could do a pilot program just
focused on that okay to help understand
what it would mean to do a good pilot
program we need to involve more families
and more people with disabilities in
here right that's part of our RSA 171
law state law is to involve people with
disabilities
okay we need to Define what the success
criteria are what are the uh you know
what's the um what I write down uh
uh boy quality metrics success criteria
and so on and then the follow-on is post
July there's these non-mandatory changes
that BDS would like to make and we need
to involve families in that and I think
we do have time to develop a better plan
for what's going to go on post-july and
what the a pilot program would be
follow up so you're really proposing
um
at least two pilots one with the
immediate issues with the immediate
deadline of July 1st and then another
one
that using feedback from families will
address a broader group of issues yeah
yeah thank you I think you know what I'm
proposing is look at the situations in
terms of what is required from a federal
compliance point of view
okay Implement those and then the the
proposed broader changes keep that
separate
okay yes representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking
the question
I think what I'm hearing and I want to
be clear about this instead of a pilot
program is a design program to basically
design something correct
correctly that involves all the
stakeholders including BDS
and once we have the design program in
place then we can do a pilot
but to think step one is getting the
design built to begin with is that kind
of what I'm hearing
I I think so I mean the design is in
progress okay I mean it's it is and
there's the concern is there are a lot
of unknowns in this design but still in
in software one of the things you do is
you develop what your success criteria
is you develop your less set of
requirements what is this thing going to
look like okay and then you implement
your your test plan or your beta program
pilot program to make sure that you've
met your requirements
follow up please hello thank you so
basically at this point in time to
understand the software analogy we're
still designing the software we haven't
got to the beta test yet
I I would probably characterize it that
way yeah thank you
other questions
any other questions
okay seeing none thank you thank you
they also signed up to testify is uh Amy
joard I believe it is uh from Concord
and I'm sure I didn't pronounce that
name correctly was I even close
uh you asked for six minutes ma'am we
really need you to stick to you know
it's pretty as much as you can
nearly close to three I can hear you oh
yeah you need to push the hit the button
there you go
okay that's better
um yes I will do my best to stick to
that time frame thank you for allowing
me to testify here this morning my name
is Amy Gerard I am from Concord and I
live with my family and a daughter with
a disability
I am here to oppose
hbo608
I represent other family members and
individuals served with the sorry I
represent individuals that have come
together
to oppose this bill because we don't
believe that this bill in as the way it
is written really speaks to the issues
of the pilot program and how this should
be implemented
New Hampshire Bureau of Developmental
Services has been under a CMS corrective
action plan since 2016. specific to the
conflict of interest and direct bill as
noted in a
2017 position paper from Sydney the
scope of the CMS cap regarding the
centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services has determined that New
Hampshire's service system does not
comply with these rules and as a result
New Hampshire is operating its
developmental disability and acquired
brain disorders Medicaid waivers under a
correction action plan after seven years
the CMS cap has a current compliance
deadline of July 1st 2023 the
legislation as proposed does not comply
with these Federal deadlines
the Redden legislation states the
purpose of the pilot program will be to
test with Alvarez and Marcel Public
accessor Services Concepts prior to
comprehensive rollout of the redesign
program however these concepts are not
clear and the quality educators are not
available or transparent
Additionally the legislation provides
language that the data points being
gathered to determine positive or
negative consequences are based on
topics
such as but not limited to mandated and
proposed changes to the waiver system
revised weight and reimbursement models
system upgrades
in integration billion reimbursement
changes budget and service level changes
the language continues to allow any
additional change that may be included
in the pilot program without mentioning
scope or review and to me that is very
dangerous
the timeline as someone had mentioned
earlier and I'll be brief the timeline
is of great concern there are numerous
concerns the timeline as proposed and in
this the date and time requirements
contradict each other while
contradicting the CMS cap deadlines
within no later date data of July 1st
this leaves two to three area agencies
with less than four months if this
legislation is accepted as written at
the date of this letter to implement a
net new pilot program closeout current
programming inform consumers families
and vendors and create sustainable
standardized data points together for
analysis the pilot scope intends to have
data for a minimum of 10 months however
the pilot analysis should be publicly
available by March 1st 2024 a mere eight
to nine months when the pilot is
initiated
as we know that data analysis must begin
before a public report can be produced
we would anticipate the data analysis
I hear the timer
the data analysis
would engage 30 to 60 days before the
reporting deadline as proposed this
creates a slimming of the data
collection time frame closer to seven
months of data four are shorter than the
10-month minimum requested
and I know and I appreciate that I am
running out of time and I just wouldn't
like to indulge you for one more thing
I know that the Bureau of Department of
Health and excuse me the Bureau of
Developmental Services has worked really
hard with families and consumers over
the last years to make sure that our
voices are heard
I am very concerned that people are not
coming forward because they are afraid
they are afraid of retaliation from the
area agencies they are afraid that their
services will be cut they are afraid
that the Mantra of going back to Laconia
is true
I do not hear that from the Department
I hear Innovation I hear appropriate
systems change and I hear that they
really want to be able to move forward
and make sure that families and
individuals particularly individuals
with developmental disabilities are
served in the way that they need to be
served and have a full and robust life
full of services that provide a good and
decent quality of life
I am proposed I am opposed to this pilot
because I don't believe that this will
solve anything
hey thank you questions
yes representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um we we took some testimony a little
bit earlier
um about the suggestion that maybe we
would go forward
um with the redesign on the the
corrective action elements of it but
maybe pilot the a m portion
um if the bill were amended to modify
the scope in some way would you is that
something you think you could support
let me see if I understand you correctly
um so you're saying that we wouldn't the
bill that proposed changes would
implement the corrective action plan and
direct bill
is that what you're saying yeah it's my
understanding from the testimony that
there's just two elements of this
there's we got to get the the CMS uh the
corrective action part done and there's
a hard date on that and then there's the
a m recommendations so if you were to
push forward with the one element of it
um
because you have to because the time
constraints and then do the pilot on the
a m recommendation so you're basically
dividing it up
would that be something you could
support I think if the scope was clear
in that way then yes
other questions
uh yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um you said something in your testimony
that was a concern of mine that I think
has gone away but you mentioned the
concern that programs would be suspended
while the pilot program was going on my
understanding from everything I've heard
is that's not going to happen but the
plans that BDS has created will be
suspended indefinitely not the actual
programs am I wrong about that I think
that it is very unclear within this bill
is what I'm going back to and there's a
what I was saying about the fear is that
there is a general Community fear of the
redesign itself
because
people are afraid that what the redesign
means is that they we are all going back
to the days of Laconia state school and
nobody wants that that is not what I'm
hearing from the Department however that
is not what I have been seeing in the
stakeholder meetings that have been vast
I am hearing from many stakeholders who
are afraid to come forward that they do
feel heard by the department
and they are incredibly excited about
this redesign because it will allow for
broader Services
individualized services that will
promote quality of life
you mentioned Department which
department sorry Department of Health
and Human Services CDs
other questions
see no other questions okay thank you
thank you
and the final person signed up to
testify is Teresa Olson Martin from
Webster
is is she still here Ms Martin's still
here
does anyone else wish to testify on a
house bill could you just let us know if
she said whether she supported or
opposed he does not
okay
thank you
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 608
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 608 and we
will be in recess it is what uh what's
the official time 12 38 so we'll be
convened in one hour uh and uh Mr
chairman could I ask
fervently that we convene in less than
an hour because
it seems to me that we have an awful lot
of work in front of us and many of us
including myself have a hard end date
here so I would be glad to give up a
significant portion of lunch hour if we
could get back together in half an hour
okay all right so uh 110. I'll be back
at 1 10. and I'll be glad to offer
anybody half a sandwich if that helps
and with that time we will take up house
bills at 238 and House Bill 317. we have
anything to get them today I usually do
I'm sorry that's all right I'm
trying I'm trying to eat a little more
healthier than I have
in recent days so
I'm a big believer in chocolate chips so
am I
okay
good afternoon everyone I'm gonna
reconvene the meeting welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly affairs
uh we I'm going to open the Committee
hearing at this time on House Bill 238
and recognize representative McMahon the
prime sponsor
thank you Mr chairman
and good afternoon members
um representative Charlie McMahon here
in
support of the hospital 238 um you'll
see that what was initially provided
was House Bill 238 and what I presented
to you today was an amendment to the
bill uh copy was given to all members
earlier
this morning
for your review and support the bill
before you
is addressing improvements enhanced
enhancements
and abilities to the developmental
Services quality Council that currently
exists and has been for many years
in dealing with and meeting the
challenges of programs as they develop
and providing a doorway of communication
from those uh in in the field providing
the services receiving the services
and delivering the services
but we have before you is
the
intent of generating Cooperative
collaboration to achieve consensus
with new programs coming on the table
and being reviewed is to have those who
were then committed to meeting what
those programs require to be part of
their generation
and that is something that uh we hope
that you will agree in supporting uh
with the modality being the council that
exists and and having a a doorway open
between the uh Department of Health and
Human Services and specifically the
Bureau of Developmental Services as well
within that department and to facilitate
a communication
Avenue for as detailed in the amendment
is for those who are making things
happen for our families in the state of
New Hampshire uh who are dealing with
disability issues uh quite broad that
you've heard already on the previous two
uh two bills this is uh one conduit that
uh we hope to add to and to provide as a
solid resource that once programs are
instituted
and supported is that those who are
being served will have the not just the
physical but the intellectual commitment
to meet the requirements because they
were part of the process in their
approval and uh promulgation into law
and rate and regulation
and that's uh that's my comments Mr
chairman thank you very much questions
yes representative Shapiro
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative McMahon
um I did come in a little late so I hope
I'm not embarrassing myself but could
you talk
um through what the amendment
changes
uh the amendment is not change and it's
adding
and uh specific what is what it's adding
um and you'll see primarily on page two
uh it's the
processes of allowing information to be
provided by the the Department of Health
and Human Services within the committee
meetings that take place or the council
meetings that take place when uh if if
and when policies and processes are
being proposed and also how they're
running and the so folks know what's
taking place and most importantly what's
not taking place
uh it's uh also providing for a council
member
to be part of the selection process for
contractors and contracts to give their
input and and the input is to ensure
that the ground level
uh comments uh spoken for when these
long-term long term that's my word
long-term commitments are being made for
services uh to our to our disabled uh
young adults and adults in addition it's
to ensure that a number of members of
this this committee are in effect
physically handicapped and also those
who have a parent or or to bring them to
the meetings have the challenges of how
they can get to the meeting is to win to
ensure that there is just like we have
here a zoom connection for these
meetings and that they would be
considered part of the Quorum that's
needed when policies are voted on is
that it's done by by a majority as per
statute that we have uh in here but
that's that is uh ultimately
as you wait we threw read through this
uh what's in Black letter A highlighted
black letter hope the copies did show
that
uh is those are the additions and to
facilitate
functional participation by the council
members in developing in collaboration
with the department policies and
regulations and services that will be
supported once passed and because
they're meeting exactly what has been
received in in overview and testimony at
the meetings that they have in working
with the Department who's doing the work
and putting these programs together as
stated earlier to meet the funding
through whether it's CMS or state
funding there's qualifications needed
but meeting the the broad uh challenges
and requirements uh if if you don't live
the life then you're not going to know
what it is and those requirements are
brought together by this by this Council
and it's to facilitate what they bring
to the table will be part of the
policies ultimately approved and and
offered what ultimately comes back here
to to Health and Human Services
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
McMahon for being here today would these
change do you think that these changes
would solve or at least significantly
address the concerns we heard this
morning about people in the community
not feeling involved in the process
I well the short short answer is yes I
do when there's a voice I can speak
alone in the woods or I can you know
speak in front of to to get the
collaborative cooperation and that's
working together and and it's having
here where you where you will be given
that that opportunity but you've got to
show up
and and there was there's the continuity
that is offered uh that does exist but
what was not taking place was more
participation and recognition of the
contribution and that contribution is to
put uh the uh like it says in here a
council member on the decision-making
capacity of
um contracts or Services uh as being
spent after we have uh voted for funding
here in the finance
hello and would you be opposed to
changing it to being enacted upon
passage so that the script has a better
voice going forward
and faster right now it says 60 days
after passage so if we do this amendment
I'd like to see it with it upon Passage
well I I uh well I'm I'm one that wants
to make sure that everyone's fully
loaded before that they'll support this
and also I am one that does believe and
I'm not trying to be funny let's do it
while we're young so it's it's yes the
if the if the committee is in support of
that I sure sure am and and I would
offer that those who I've spoken to and
others will testify on uh on the service
Council that uh and I haven't asked him
that it's just that we need this done
now and that's why I was honor honored
to be able to offer this bill for your
consideration and support
other questions
yes representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
representative
you think it's a criteria that the
members of this Council be young so that
they can do things in the early part of
our life and not wait to be older
I mean do they need to be young I think
they should be well no they need to be
aggressively mature
and uh age does not play a role there
it's it's uh communicated with manners
and do the work but whether you're um
up there in age or not uh if you're
living the life that's what gets people
really motivated and this is a Avenue
where you can speak and people and those
who are there will can understand and
talk on the correct language and then
working with our Department of Health
and Human Services is to continue for us
in New Hampshire and this is my bias to
lead the way in home and community-based
care and that's what what we need now
it's whether those are willing to put it
in the time
and as I learned from your guidance many
years ago I said you need to show up
Mr chairman that the uh
was that this member often says we
should vote for this while we're still
young and and get the work done and I
just want to be sure that you were
applying that to this legislation as
well thank you yes I was waiting for you
to finally say you supported yes
it took a while instead of land you had
a question uh no oh I'm sorry oh sorry
oh yes okay I'm representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here and for taking my question
um I I I believe that I like this
amendment
um I do have concerns about one section
it's on page three
um it says that the meeting shall be
open to the public subject to the
provisions of rsa91a on online 23 and
24. but then
um and then you define the Quorum but
91a does not permit remote
um members who are attending to be a
part of the Quorum or to vote and so
this would be a precedent being set that
has never been in our state to my
knowledge
and um no it looks like I have some
feedback from the other committee
members
representative Weber
representative McMahon is it is it not
true that under the first of all there
is 91a yes and that we have any number
of exceptions to 91a that are built into
either 91a itself or everywhere else in
the statutes
for various things that are not that
ought to be on under 91a under its plain
language but we have accepted them
confidential records for example is that
true yeah and yes yes ma'am and then I'm
if I may I have a series I'm in attorney
mode if I may Mr chairman
um is it
um also not true that 91a right now
permits remote participation
when a quorum is present in the room
other members May participate remotely
is that true if you know that's my end
that's my understanding which is why
it's in in the billas of recommendation
and then finally Mr chairman uh and
isn't it true that for purposes of a
quorum if we are to involve members of
this community and their caregivers
meaningfully
with all the issues that they may have
with respect to their medical care and
their transport and their ability to get
to meetings that we need this exception
like all the other exceptions to 91a in
order for there to be the kind of
meaningful participation
from uh
the community and their caregivers so
that's the purpose for this exemption
well I want to check if you're a sponsor
of the bill with me that sure sounded
like it
uh
yes Joanna uh at the the uh the issue is
that you know you're exactly correct I
appreciate your very knowledgeable
expression on that there's there's the
law then there's the application of the
law and it's it's and it's for our
citizens and the protection of our
citizens so that's why it's here and
we're dealing with a subset of our
population
that still can participate but
physically can't uh may not get there
and this allows them to participate
thank you
thank you Mr chair and I'll thank you
for taking the question it's good to see
you back
in regards to the Quorum and what we
just heard from representative Weber
many of the individuals may be on this
Council
could have transportation issues
would it be better to have an exemption
to 91a so there's not a requirement for
a physical Quorum and a central location
this isn't compliance with 91a 91a
requires a physical Quorum
representative did you have an answer
for that or
um thank you
um I hosted another bill House Bill 308
which deals uh exactly with this
initially it started out to be a bill
allowing the rare disease Council to
meet but we also added in the
disabilities and then there was an
amendment that made it a much broader
um Bill and it has passed through
Judiciary so it's got you know two more
three more steps to do but would it was
with your Council exactly in mind that
that was initiated and it would allow
um you needed a third of the membership
to be in a physical location but that
the rest of the people online could
count as the Quorum right so it that's a
fix if that goes through
other questions
yes
did you have your hand up again okay
other questions
saying no other questions
that sun is not I do not have a question
seeing you look into the glare of if
this is bothering people I'll close it
we open the blind we open the curtains
so that air could come in that's fine
because the glare isn't helping my
eyesight right now okay I'll close
foot support
and Mr chairman yes if I may um uh
Charlie McMahon okay yeah just to add
one comment there the intent here was
not to facilitate uh non
-physical presence for folks not to come
to these to this meeting it's
specifically was is targeting
the individuals who can't get their due
to their physical challenges so so it's
not to abuse the uh any intent of
transparency
when you're having a meeting or or to
play with a quorum requirement when very
important decisions are being made
thank you
other questions
okay I'm not seeing any okay thank you
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members
also signed up to speak is
representative Mark Pearson
oh okay I saw you had written
for Mark Pearson on yours but then I
also saw he had seen seen he had filled
one out so
I wasn't sure how that was going to work
thank you I'm uh Fran Nutter Upham
Hillsboro eight and I'm reading the
testimony of Mark Pearson Who had a
doctor's appointment and although he'd
been here all morning he couldn't stay
any longer
okay
um thank you Mr chairman and members of
the health human services and Elder
Affairs committee for the record my name
is Mark Pearson I'm reading his letter
all right anyway I'm chairman of and
wouldn't I like to say that I am a
chairman of the children and family law
committee and the joint legislative
legislative
DHHS oversight committee and I am past
chairman of Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee when I first
got to Concord I decided to adopt the
needs of the DD Community as one of my
places of interest and have been active
in this work for going on to seven years
in my work as a part-time executive
director of a family
Medical Practice Center
I know
this part I know we have served many DD
patients when the department started to
consider a redesign of the Bureau of
Developmental Services I did some
shuttle dis
diplomacy among department leaders the
area agencies and those with DD people
at home while we didn't come to any
conclusions it was apparent that more
work has to be done in order to create a
system that both serves the department
and the recipients in my opinion we
still aren't there yet I believe the
people working at DHHS
in the area of Developmental disability
planning a change in the system are
capable and caring not a few of them
themselves have DD loved ones
I enjoy my time with the department
leaders however numbers of stakeholders
have indicated their input needs to be
welcomed and considered more than has
happened to date in my opinion there's
still a disconnect the bill before us
House Bill 238 asks for more important
more input before any contract is
finalized in my opinion this is most
justifi justified
I could
live with any of the three bills you are
considering today
608 317 or this one as long as the
transition to a two-tier waiver is
delayed so further conversation and
collaboration can take place thank you
thank you
I'm assuming you're taking no questions
no I know
that was kind of a rhetorical that was
kind of perhaps not that was meant to be
a rhetorical question but
uh the cleric wants a copy of that
testimony
thank you representative
also signed up to speak today from the
Health Department of Health and Human
Services is Robert Moore and Melissa
Nemeth
good afternoon members of the committee
my name is Melissa Nemeth I am the
legislative liaison for the Bureau of
Developmental Services no one's ever
told me I was quiet before
um and and Robert Moore from the
Department is here with me as well um
he's going to speak to the piece
relative to Contracting while I'm going
to address the remaining elements of the
bill the department is not taking a
position on the bill today but did want
to provide information and point out
some concerns that we do have in the way
that the bill is currently written I
think as you've heard you know associate
commissioner santanello in her testimony
this morning the the department very
much values the input of all
stakeholders be it those on the quality
Council family members area agencies
what have you we realize and recognize
that they are key components and key
contributors to all the work that is
done but the this bill appears to move
the quality Council more from The
Advisory role that they have today into
an oversight position and as you're all
well aware the department already
reports to Health and Human Services
oversight on a regular basis and could
provide much of this information
and I think you are going to hear some
testimony today that others you know
that are part of the community family
members feel perhaps that their
feedback is not heard and not listened
to
BDS feels we have a very robust
stakeholder engagement process and an
elaborate system for the members of the
quality Council specifically to have
their voices heard some of the members
are very involved in the redesign
efforts that are going on and sit on
committees that have been established as
part of the redesign work there is a
member of the Department of Health and
Human Services Bureau of Developmental
Services who is a member who sits on the
quality Council and provides a great
deal of information through all of their
meetings we respond to requests that we
get a vast number of requests for
certain data points from the quality
Council that we are more than willing to
provide and have provided and will
continue to do
in this bill you know while it may be
well intentioned to the extent folks
feel they aren't being heard we have
some concern learns that there might
actually be some unintended negative
consequences of this that will be to the
detriment of the individuals that are
supported it would some of what is in
here would significantly impact the
ability of the department to conduct its
functions and impede the efficient
delivery of services to this vulnerable
population for instance
on page three of the bill it requests
that or it would require that we seek
input solicit input before and
recommendations from the council at the
initial stages of consideration
for any policies it goes on it's a long
list and it would seem to and again this
could be not the intention of the bill
but reading it it seems to be that there
would be very little work that the
Bureau of Developmental Services could
do without soliciting input and again
while it's valued
if it is required at every level of
every move that the department makes
it's going to be unduly burdensome and
prevent the department from doing the
important work every day that needs to
be done to ensure that these services
are delivered to folks
um sure
so it begins on page three line line 37
and then it goes on to lines one and two
x one through six really of page four of
the bill and it goes beyond even the
areas that the quality council is
already charged with receiving
information and providing
recommendations for another concern that
the department has is that although this
committee has been and I I hear the
timer I'll wrap up
um the the quality council is charged in
the current statute with providing
recommendations to the department and
providing an annual report I I will say
that the it's my understanding that
annual reports have not always been
provided on a regular basis in those
that I have seen for the last five or
four or five years
the areas for which they provided
recommendations have been with respect
to administrative rules and the waiver
amendments or the waiver renewals
primarily and although these are
important from this group those are
areas that are open to all public
stakeholder engagement so the department
has not received to date a lot of
information and recommendations from
this committee
and with that if I could I we had asked
for three minutes each if I I don't know
if you want to ask questions now and I
know Robert has to get to a meeting so
maybe if he could provide a testimony
before we take any questions
foreign thank you Mr chairman thank you
to the committee
um Robert Moore DHHS contracts and
procurement director so I'm here as
Melissa said to speak specifically about
the impacts on the procurement process
of HB 238 I'll be brief just just three
key points some current concerns that I
have about that we have about this bill
and its impacts on our ability to
conduct Fair confidential and efficient
procurements one we must be in
compliance with all relevant statutes
related to the current process RSA 21g37
actually requires the process to remain
confidential so the issuing agency
including DHHS is not able to provide
any information related to the
procurements or contracts from the date
a request for proposal closes up until
GNC approval so it's click not clear to
me that this bill would not put us in
conflict with RSA 21g37
secondly in relatedly many of the
members on this Council would be
representatives of organizations that
are current vendors and contractors with
DHHS or potential bidders on some of
these requests for proposals so I think
there's a real potential here for
perceived if not actual conflicts of
interest if we're giving a subset of our
potential betters the opportunity to
give input on the solicitations prior to
them being issued
um and then just the third point I want
to make and sort of echoing a comment
that Melissa made I think this is adding
another level of bureaucratic review and
approval to what is already can be a
prolonged process and speaking
specifically about the procurement
process this could potentially delay our
ability to issue these requests for
proposals and get contracts to governor
and executive Council for approval which
ultimately could delay the timely
delivery of these services so thank you
thank you questions yes representative
Weber
the confidential nature of the
Contracting process
how onerous would it be for you to
involve the council in uh
solicit the feedback of the council
prior to the RFP stage so when you're
developing an RFP
surely you would want
or what maybe you wouldn't want wouldn't
you want feedback from the council
as to what the effect of whatever your
proposal is is going to be on their
community
so I I think that would raise more the
issue of the conflict of interests with
potential representatives of
organizations that could be potential
Bettors on this request for a proposal
on these requests for a proposal giving
input on you know the selection criteria
the eligibility requirements I think
there is a way to solicit input from
this Council and I'll look to Melissa to
speak to this more on the goals or
overall objectives of a request for a
proposal but the actual input on the
document itself could raise those
potential perceived conflicts of
interest
may I have a follow-up follow-up so what
I'm really trying to get at and I think
we're maybe saying the same thing but
I'm having a hard time feeling like
you're actually responding to my
question is
um
isn't there a way and perhaps we have
not yet drafted it properly
to solicit the input and maybe it exists
already but what is the way that you
will solicit the input of the community
that is and I'm not talking about all
you know the community that is the
recipient
of the care for one thing and also I
understand your concern about conflicts
of interest but uh how do you propose to
solicit the input from the people who
are providing the care because if
there's anything we heard in the last
four hours of Our Lives it is that
neither the community receiving the care
nor the providers of the Care feel like
they're adequately being heard
let's do you want to take them
uh thank you for the question
representative Weber and I think that
it's a little bit tough to
um to answer this question in a way
because it the department feels that it
is providing ample opportunities and
receiving the feedback
um and I know that the people that are
providing the feedback don't don't feel
that that's the case
um and so it is a little bit difficult
to sit here too I think I would need to
take this back and provide a follow-up
and speak with our our program folks
themselves to see um you know what we
might potentially be able to offer uh to
answer the question that you've raised
other questions
I am seeing no other questions
okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Deborah
okay you guessed
um from quality control
quality Council
good afternoon microphone please
I have a seat on the quality Council as
a family member
since its Inception by legislation in
2009 the quality Council seats have been
filled with people with disabilities
family members Advocates providers area
agencies and the Bureau of Developmental
services
at least 51 percent of the members of
the councils are individuals with
disabilities and served by the system or
parents of individuals served by the
system
the ideas and opinions of these men
members are vital to strong systems
services and supports we live the life
the bureau does not
all of these groups are seated on the
quality Council
the council is an independent voice
which includes a diverse group of
stakeholders with various thoughts and
opinions the council's advocacy is a
result of regular discussions
compromises from all the stakeholders
this voice is critical
the legislation as amended seeks to
expand the quality council's ability to
influence decisions made by the Bureau
of Developmental services and clarifies
the responsibility of the Bureau of
Developmental services to respond to
Quality Council concerns
the quality Council was not
invited to participate in the
developmental service redesign and the
bureau has not directly addressed
concerns about the redesign
developmental Services redesign and the
bureau has not directly
enter the concerns of the regional and
signed shared with the council remember
we are members family members
stakeholders who were involved in the
Grassroots work that needs to be done to
deliver services
over the last two decades the quality
Council has advocated for Quality
surface for people with developmental
disabilities in areas such as Managed
Care employment rights equitable
distribution of American Rescue plan act
funding for direct support works
DD waiver reauthorization and the dozens
of rules impacting the quality of
service
it is a critical that the quality
Council have a voice and major Decisions
by the department and the department
responds to Quality Council have a
The Voice
by the department and responds to
Quality Council recommendations in
writing and in detail particularly when
the recommendations are not adopted
this legislation seeks to ensure this to
happen
also the legislation addresses issues
that the ability of the quality
council's members to participate in
meetings Viva Zoom which is critical as
many members are people with
disabilities are caring for family
members with disabilities thank you
thank you would you also like to testify
and then we'll I'm Stephanie Patrick I'm
the chair of the quality Council and I
just came to this case you have any
other questions
okay questions for these ladies
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking this question
um
this may have been better as to the
people who um
testified before you but I'll put it up
for you for the two of you
um there was concern from the Department
that this would um
give people on the council
um
these weren't their words but too much
power or veto power over many things and
tie their hands in a certain way
I may have characterized that poorly but
um but in any case in the original bill
it does say that um
the council shall solicit input and make
recommendations but it also says it will
give due deference to the council's
input I'm not really sure what give do
deference means
if that gives them veto power but in any
case that part seems to be excluded from
the amendment which replaces the whole
bill which is my understanding
so
is your understanding that
you will be able to give
um feedback about a very broad number of
issues including redesign including
contracts putting out rfps for contracts
but
ultimately you will be sharing
responsibility for making decisions with
the Department
or that one will have more
responsibility will ultimately have more
power to do that than the other
I think our intent with this is that we
would be giving input to the department
and then they would be held accountable
for responding to that input either to
say yes we agree with that or know that
we don't in a really thoughtful and
thorough process but I think we need the
ultimate decision for these things is
going to rely with the Department who's
responsible for providing the services
follow up follow up but the intent is
not that you would have veto power over
their decisions
for families and people with
disabilities and that they would be
responsible for saying well we think it
does because of this or we we agree with
you this wasn't how we meant it you know
to be able to have those kinds of
discussions that we haven't we haven't
felt like we have had in the past back
in
so so that this would create more of an
honest
um vibrant back and forth in terms of
getting to a final solution right
right thank you representative Leon um
thank you Mr chairman and thank you both
for being here
um I appreciate the intent of this but
it looks like I don't know if there's a
certain minimum level of change at which
something below a certain level is
necessary to come to the committee that
come to the council and which decisions
are just those day-to-day operations and
I think trying to get a handle on that
would be helpful for us so that we can
make sure that we're not
crossing the line in the wrong place so
that then it needs to come back and get
Revisited so could you help with that
yeah
the quality Council was created
so that we can assure the quality that
is
happening to the families
and many of the members are family
members whether they hold an agency seat
or not so
not the day-to-day that we're concerned
with with the redesign it's a different
story right but what we're asking the
bureau to do be is transparent with it
the entity that was created to assure
quality for families
and it's a communication
thing and you know you what you might
describe as we're talking to the
families and the families are telling us
no they're not
so we have to come to some agreement and
some understanding and that takes a
conversation a transparent conversation
follow up um thank you and us follow-up
would that be for to determine what what
qualifies as a major decision versus one
that's minor that's something where I'd
like to get an idea of what level of um
what level of detail you're interested
in and that might just be a follow-up
issue to get back with the committee but
I think that would be helpful to know
and we can I mean the quality Council
meets on Tuesday so we can definitely
talk about that as a council so that we
can give you a position in more details
on that but I can tell you that the
intent was not that we would be involved
if someone's moving offices or they need
a new copy machine or things like that
it was the big decisions that are
significantly impacting the
developmental Disability Services System
thank you
other questions
you want to see any other questions
thank you thank you thank you
foreign
also signed up to testify is Maureen
Tierney
nope there's Maureen's Tierney still
here
do not
t-r-a-c-e Tracy is it Tracy
I mispronounce it
hey all right
right
um also signed up to speak is Kathy
spinney from Pelham
and welcome back
as I mentioned earlier I am also a
member of the DD quality Council I was
its chair for the first seven or eight
years
um you've already heard about the
membership and why those members are so
crucial to be heard on quality issues
this is a legislatively seated Council
it has a very specific mandate to
monitor all accessory system in order to
do that we need meaningful data on a
regular basis as we request it
department has a seat on the council as
well and is an active participant
sometimes our requests for data are
responded to promptly sometimes not
um we've got some pieces of data we've
requested over and over again in the
context of a meeting it's meant to be
collegial it's meant to be collaborative
um but it's gotten to the point where
sometimes it seems like for the council
to get what it needs it needs to put its
requests in writing so they're very
specific so there's no misunderstanding
of what is being asked and then we
usually ask for written responses and
and
it's just come to that and and to be
fair you know over the years the
bureau's been short staffed and you know
sometimes you know amassing data is is a
challenging thing so this isn't meant to
be punitive but it's meant to be clear
when you sit in a room and you have a
conversation among a lot of people
but you don't document it sometimes you
leave that meeting if you don't meet
again for two months you forget what did
I promise I was going to do I mean you
know so having
specifically data requests from the
Department be very clear and very
specific in what is being asked and then
having the department come back and say
we'll get you this by this date we can't
give you that because we don't collect
it or whatever
um keeps continuity it keeps the Council
on track and it's clear you know there's
nothing better than a written contract
even among the best of friends
everybody's roles are clearly defined
and it is really difficult for the
council to do the work it has to do
further what we've learned from
testimony on the last bill
had the department come to this Council
before it hired a m
so this council could have made
recommendations on what the system
really needed to work on for the
meaningful improvements that everybody
wants it would have looked very
different very different
instead the department embarked on this
exercise with an out-of-state consultant
for an exorbitant amount of money
and it's gone in such a direction on
many of the recommendations that are not
what families have repeatedly said they
want and so this would avoid that
because had had the department come to
the council and said what do you think
of the idea of two-tiered waivers with
caps we could have given them some very
meaningful feedback on why perhaps
that's not the best idea and would be
documented and written and there would
be robust back and forth not only among
the people who administer such things
but the people for whom it will impact
most the people on the ground the
families and the individuals served and
maybe we could have avoided a whole
bunch of stuff and and there's been
enough said on the remote access issue I
think you get why that's important
um keeping also in mind that many
families right now can't hire staff so
they've had to leave their own jobs to
be staff
but you know they're members and they
have meaningful voices and we don't want
them to be silenced
um but you really
um need to understand that
not Consulting the final users of the
system first
can result in many unintended negative
consequences that now I think we're
starting to try to see if we can put the
brakes on and dig out of and so this is
being more proactive to avoid such
things in the future
perfect timing
any questions get it down now
any questions
do I see any questions okay no thank you
also signed up to speak is Will Walker
from Hollis
hello thanks again for the opportunity
to speak live in Hollis with my son
who's 23 year olds with autism
I'm requesting your support for HP 238
uh I don't want to repeat too much of
what's already been said uh in the
testimony this morning and what's
happened now but you know my wife and I
are Advocates we Advocate strongly for
our son
um we rely upon being involved we we we
rely upon the nothing about us without
us portion right if you if you look at
RSA 171 it means that people uh and and
families of people with disabilities
need to be involved in changes affecting
them
okay so we cannot always be aware of
everything we can rely upon the quality
Council to be aware okay we want them to
have the awareness we want them to have
the information we want them to have to
have the ability to have input they help
us right they help families provide
input help families provide you know the
influence over what policies are going
to affect them so
be very brief
thank you again and please support HP
thank you questions
yes can we get the copy of your
testimony please I emailed it to the the
committee is it email uh sufficient or
do you want a hard copy oh this is for
the
record okay we'll do yeah if we could
have you an odd copy that'd be great
it's just for the clerk you can you can
come up here if you want
okay all right okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Jennifer
Bertrand from Mount Vernon
good afternoon members of the committee
thank you for your attention and
thoughtful questions and consideration
of everything that we've been talking to
talking about today uh I'm from Mount
Vernon New Hampshire I am a parent of a
now adult daughter who experiences a
significant developmental disability
um she still lives at home with my
husband and I and her younger brother
and I'm just going to pass this around
picture of Chloe here so you can see who
she is
my husband and I provide
um just about all of the supports that
she needs she needs support 24 7 to be
safe and to live a meaningful life we've
also helped to support her to open up
her own small business she loves
shredding paper so she um has Chloe's
Shred Shed in her own workspace and my
husband and I work full-time remotely
and we while he's working I'm with Chloe
while I'm working he's with Chloe so
between our full-time jobs and caring
for Chloe because she can never be left
alone
that's our life and we haven't been able
to hire dsps to fully utilize her budget
and support her needs because of the
workforce crisis
getting to this bill right here today
this bill HB 238 I urge you to support
it because it's a reasonable and
appropriate and it really seeks to make
sure that the quality Council the
experts within the system the users of
the system and the vendor agencies and
area agencies and other stakeholder and
groups
that know where the barriers are where
the challenges are you know they're at
that street level and they can provide
the knowledge
and wisdom to help make appropriate
changes
to either the waivers or the
developmental service system so it can
work more efficiently
unfortunately
the council was sidestepped during this
most recent process when the bureau went
to evaluate the system and this bill
will help to ensure that it brings it
back I know that the department
mentioned a few things about you know
was this going from advisory to
oversight
um
and they mentioned how robust their
stakeholder input was I wanted to let
you know while I I'm not on one of the
work groups they were holding the
department was holding these Zoom like
webinar meetings
not every month but several they've had
them for you know multiple months and
you can't see anybody who's on other
than the bureau people and the a m
people you can't see any of the families
or individuals in order to ask a
question you have to type it into the
chat my daughter Chloe can't type it in
so it was very hard for people with
disabilities to even access that and to
be perfectly honest based on the
proposals that they've put forward that
input isn't there and they're not
listening some parents feel like they
stakeholder input themselves to death
because you keep putting in some input
but it's not really being hurt and this
bill make makes sense because it will
help to ensure that and I'm sure about
the contract ma'am yes the Contracting
confidentiality I'm sure there's a way
around that as well this bill will help
put the spirit of the law that's already
in place for this entity it'll help see
that through and ensure that they're
making those functional contributions
questions thank you any questions
oh yes go ahead representative profile
yes so you hit on a concern that I had
when I read the bill which is you can
have a mechanism for input the question
is
will that input be heard and responded
to so the bill the bill does provide
that there should be a response you know
if exactly both in an affirmative in a
um so if the if the department agrees
with or doesn't agree with
um
is there anything else that you can uh
foresee that might help to ensure that
that input is really
um clearly heard and acted upon when
appropriate I guess right you know so so
that's my general concern about this is
we can create a commission we can create
it we can create a mechanism for people
to provide input which is great
um how do we ensure that that input is
is really taken to Heart well there's no
guarantees in life but this really does
help you know when the quality Council
who's responsible for over for the
oversight of quality within the system
can't get the information they need to
be able to evaluate things make
recommendations I think it's really
important this bill includes the fact
that when they do make recommendations
the quality Council that if the
department chooses to forego those
recommendations that they respond in
writing they explain why that's the case
um
unfortunately I think prior to this bill
you know it was more like checking the
box right we say oh we have these
advisory councils oh we checked that box
we scheduled those meetings but I'll
tell you as a family member spending
several hours month after month
typing into the chat and there were some
sessions where they're like oh we don't
feel like you know we can't scroll all
the way back down the chat to find your
questions just retype them
it was just very frustrating and you
know I'm not the fastest typer having
one ham and having a hand and having a
limb difference I'm like this this is
about the developmental service system
why aren't we making this accessible and
I realize there are challenges around
covid and maybe people didn't want to
congregate in person but there were
better ways to do that this is a
reasonable step to help ensure that our
our input is being more thoughtfully
considered
gives the council more teeth
other questions
saying no other questions
okay thank you
the last person who has signed up to
testify today is is Adora Rodriguez
Legend
for the New Hampshire Council on
development
developmental disabilities
good afternoon everyone I'm it'sadora
Rodriguez Le chandray I serve as the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Council on developmental disabilities
thank you to the chair and members of
the committee for hearing my testimony I
won't take up too much time because I
simply want to reiterate the importance
of the quality Council we are an entity
that seats no less than three members of
the quality Council
we see a person with a disability a
direct support professional and an
enhanced home care provider these are
seats that are integral to determining
and evaluating the service system and
providing meaningful feedback and
recommendations
on what the service system needs and
what may or may not be
unintended consequences of decisions
that are made and so in my testimony
that I provided I also cited the RFA
171a which talks about the quality
council's role in providing meaningful
feedback to the department on decisions
regarding quality services and as other
people have said
that cannot happen if we are not
receiving timely information before
changes and decisions are made by the
department
that's it great thank you questions
any questions from anyone
I'm seeing none
thank you thank you very much
I have no other no other no one else
signed up to testify on HB 238 does
anyone else wish to testify on HB 238
saying no no I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 238 and open the
public hearing on HP 317 and recognize
the prime sponsor representative
Stringham
foreign
thank you very much Mr chairman and uh
boy you got you're a hard-working group
so we tried I'm I'm representative Jerry
Stringham from Lincoln Woodstock and I'm
here to introduce HB 317 which is an act
establishing a commission to study
transitioning to a two-tiered waiver
system for individuals eligible for
disability services
uh as is a very clear uh by now uh the
individuals and area agencies and other
individuals that serve disabled Granite
Staters
uh have concerns about the transition to
the Alvarez and Marshall reports
recommendation of a two-tiered
disability system
since you have heard a lot about it
already I will just say that important
state stakeholders feel strongly that
they're input had not been heard yet and
I saw that they had severe concerns that
the move to a tier two two-tiered system
May create more problems that it solves
my intent here was to assure thoughtful
input before implementing to a change to
the two-tiered system with legislative
input as well
uh HB 317's legislative solution is to
create a commission to more thoroughly
examine the two-tier program
regarding HB 317 itself I have received
some feedback about the makeup of the
committee uh and that some that may want
to provide input
are not part of the membership
OLS had restricted the committee size
due to RSA 1449 but over the weekend I
got some also some additional
information from the former chair that
has some suggestions that would
strengthen the committee
and still still be within the context of
1449 just mainly on naming those as
non-voting members which in his
experience is quite quite
effective so uh the other the other
opportunity would be to as I've seen
other bills do say notwithstanding 1449
and then having the broader committee is
in the draft Amendment that
that I had worked on before ALS OLS had
turned it down so basically this this
bill was just a committee to to allow
thoughtful progress on the structure of
the disability program particularly
emphasizing the two-tier disability
system and there's a lot of people here
with a lot more experience than me on
this but uh I thank you for for uh
taking this up and looking out for these
uh important and valued citizens and of
course I'm happy to answer any questions
that you may have thank you question
just a representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question I think I'm going to
wait to ask for a definition of a
two-tiered waiver system unless you want
to answer that but the question I have
for you is we just heard a bill about
the
developmental disabilities Council and
the ways that that should be a more
um
that there should be more responsiveness
between the department and the
developmental disabilities Council
why is this not duplicative
uh it's it's possible there's some over
overlap uh the disability the
communications I had with the disability
uh Community was specifically on the
implementation of the two-tiered system
where
um uh you know where the level of
benefits would be different for uh one
group of disabled
um
citizens versus versus another changing
basically the packages of services they
would be eligible to receive so this
committee which has a you know short
comparatively short Horizon would really
be addressing specifically that program
uh rather than perhaps a broader issue
with the previous bill but I'm not an
expert on the earlier bill either thank
you
representative Weber you had your hand
up a moment ago
I think that my my piece of turf has
been plowed already so thank you
other questions yes representative Nagle
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question so we've heard three bills
today that there's a lot of overlap on
and the first bill was 608
um it would seem to me that if that Bill
gets passed that this bill becomes
Superfluous
um
um do you have an opinion on 608 I'm
just curious well I I did speak with the
prime sponsor of 608 before uh you know
during the bill submission process and
um you know I thought that uh you know
committee or commission might be a
better way to get at the issue than
actually trying to implement something
and uh under under uh some kind of a
temporary program
um so I I just thought it was a better
way to start so I ended up submitting
this bill rather than signing on to that
one
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
on page on line 11 and
again on 15
you use the word leader of the minority
party
a party seems strange to be in that
context that's a very political
concept from my point of view
and so I wonder if that's whether
uh whether you wanted this to be a
political appointment by the sound of it
uh that's not really what I what I had
in mind I just I just thought it's a
bipartisan issue so so
um
should probably be a bipartisan
commission so that was my thought at the
time maybe you could just take out party
or have a party or something
yeah
okay other questions
I am seeing none
all right thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Melissa
Nemeth from the Department of Health and
Human Services
good afternoon again Mr chairman and
members of the committee again for the
record my name is Melissa Nemeth and I
am the legislative liaison for the
Bureau of Developmental services and
again we wanted to provide some
information to the committee with
respect to this bill
um and in part to answer representative
Shapiro's question that he posed to the
prime sponsor the tiered waivers are the
idea is that potentially there could be
two different waivers for people with
developmental disabilities and the
services provided on those waivers would
be a little different with one being
more comprehensive than the other in the
idea being that the end goal is to
ensure that only those individuals with
the highest level of need access to
access access the services that are the
most costly so really ensuring that
people are getting the most appropriate
services in in the most you know there's
cost Effectiveness but it has to to
match the needs of the individual so the
idea is you you match that up
appropriately
and that was a recommendation from a m
um we have already the department has
been working on that there is um as as
part of the redesign work that you've
heard a great deal about today there are
several committees that have been
established one is titled the waiver
structure work group and it was decided
and they've met excuse me for uh since
2021 and still ongoing today but as of
the spring of 2022 because as you've
heard there is a great deal of change
happening the department decided that in
the context of all the other work going
on perhaps it was time to slow down
where we could and so it was decided
that the tiered waiver discussions would
be tabled for a time and those
discussions are not expected to pick
back up until the fall or or winter of
this year the waiver structure work
group is still meeting and and they are
discussing you know services and service
definitions but the idea of a tiered
waiver has been put on hold by the
department at this time and it's it
almost feels like this commission could
be a duplication of efforts with that
group that is going on
um and I know that you know a lot of the
concerns are making sure that this would
really change potentially services that
are are being provided in the structure
of the waiver so it's critically
important to hear from all stakeholders
most importantly those of the families
so we have those ongoing groups where
there are family members that are
present on those groups but if the
department if and when the department
proposes any changes to a waiver per the
federal guidelines there is a lengthy
period of time with stakeholder
engagement where to the extent that it's
that people feel their input has not
been provided prior to even a draft of
the waiver they would have an additional
time to voice those concerns the
department would be responsible for
responding to those concerns
additionally we would have to get
approval from HHS oversight before
implementing any waivers and we would
also have to go bring that to the
medical care advisory committee so there
are a lot of groups that would provide
oversight and a lot of opportunities for
feedback in that regard
thank you questions
yes representative Weber thank you and
thank you for taking my question could
you give us uh not necessarily now but
perhaps by email the exact composition
of that working group I'd be happy to do
that yes so we know who is there and and
to what extent the people covered by the
various other bills are already involved
in that group I would be happy to I can
get to the um the clerk there is a
website devoted to the stakeholder
engagement through this redesign process
that it will take you there's a lot of
links and it can take you to a lot of
places but it has the makeup of all of
these different groups that has the
meeting minutes
for most of the meetings I don't know if
all the meeting minutes are posted but
there is a great deal of information
that I think could be helpful for all
these bills and I'd be happy to provide
that okay thank you thank you all the
questions
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much this
seems like one of the opportunities for
the council to work with that work group
I was wondering if there's a way for
that to happen with input so that
instead of having this this um
commission there's more dialogue between
the existing Council and that work group
so that those voices can happen
organically
um you know I don't have a great answer
for that because I'm not sure I have the
list but I know that's the the work
group itself I think a lot of those
meetings are public so I'm not sure I
can certainly get back to you once I get
more information from the program about
what those opportunities are it's likely
they exist but I'd be happy to provide
that thank you
other questions
are you seeing no other questions
okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Alex katrubis
from csni
uh good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is Alice katrubis
I'm here to support this legislation on
behalf of the 10 area agencies that
provide services and coordinate services
to people with developmental
disabilities and acquired brain
disorders the 10 area agencies
unanimously voted to endorse the concept
of further study of the a m recommend
recommended changes to our long-standing
Medicaid waiver and we thank
representative Stringham who brought
this issue forward on behalf of his
constituents to allow them this forum to
speak with you their elected
representatives
as you heard from the legislation this
morning uh I think from our perspective
the unfortunate decision to bring the a
m recommendations forward during the
pandemic during the healthcare Workforce
crisis and most importantly before we
got into compliance with the CMS
corrective action plan has caused a lot
of concern and confusion for not only
the area agencies but the families and
the individuals who rely on the
developmental Services System
just to give you a little background on
the waiver it was created in the early
1980s and it really has been a life
support for thousands of lives over the
decades the waiver has allowed us to not
only access funding but to create the
blueprint that we have
the array of the services and supports
that families rely on so in a nutshell
the waiver permits New Hampshire to
offer home and community-based care that
assists people on Medicaid to live in
their in their community
and the a m recommendations to make
changes they may be a good thing they
may not be a good thing uh
I'm not going to go into the definition
of a waiver I'm happy to or the supports
waiver and the two tiers because you've
already heard that from the Department I
know we've been here a long time but the
reason that this bill is here is I mean
the well was really poisoned from the
from the gate from The Starting Gate the
department hired a consultant a national
consultant to make recommended changes
to the DD system the report came out and
during that process they didn't consult
with anyone who was a receiver of the
service and they didn't consult with
anyone who provided services to the
system so I think you could understand
why there's a skepticism here of what
what went down so that's in the past I
think we've had some good discussions
today about how to move forward I think
the department there's some new
leadership who are working on these
issues now and I I have a lot more
confidence in them I think they they
understand that it was a misstep how
this all rolled out but there's concerns
and I think Kathy spinney said
it correctly uh we may want to go down
this road with the two-tier waiver but
we need to ask the families first we
need to at least ask them first and the
problem is yes there's all this robust
stakeholder input I don't dispute that
if some someone from the Department said
it was the most robust stakeholder input
in the history of the department I don't
necessarily dispute that but the problem
is is that the recommendation was
already made so they said we're going to
change the waiver now you tell us how
we're going to implement it and that's
not how it should have happened we
should have went to the families first
and said do you think this is a good
idea then maybe we could go down that
road so that this is clearly a reaction
to that I understand that we have to
move forward this bill was really I
think an opportunity for people to have
their voices heard we want to try to be
as collaborative as we can with the
Department we understand the system
needs to change but you know from the
air agency perspective you know we
really feel I don't know that starting
this up in the fall makes sense you you
just heard this morning that we have to
do direct Bill and conflict free July
1st we really want to start talking
three months later to change the waiver
I mean I let's get into CMS compliance
let's let's that be the focus for 2023
then maybe in 2024 we can look at
changes to the DD waiver that's been in
place for 40 years so I know it's been a
long day Mr chairman so I appreciate it
I'm happy to give a copy of my full
remarks to the uh to the clerk for the
record so thank you very much thank you
any questions
I'm saying no questions okay thank you
you're welcome
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Karen Blake
Miss Blake here
also signed up to speak is Will Walker
from Hollis
I thank you again uh when I look at this
bill which I do support uh please please
support it uh there was a question from
representative Shapiro okay about you
know overlap with this morning and when
I look at it this morning was if I look
at just the requirements for July 1st
the decisions been made and we want to
do a pilot program to make sure that
thing's okay
this other stuff is not mandatory and is
optional and what I see this bill being
is something to evaluate is it the right
thing to do okay so it's not to do a
pilot program on the execution of it but
first of all what is it and is it the
right thing to do so that's how I see
the difference between the bill we
talked about this morning and this bill
today
um and you know I've read the Alvarez
and Marcel report over and over and over
again okay and you come across this this
re this multi-tier waiver structure it's
only a couple pages in there it's just
they were just spitballing right here's
here's an idea that we might throw out
there and in their own words it was to
incentive incentivize access to lower to
your waivers and my understanding is
when I look at this the the uh impetus
for that came from other states where
they had a wait list that was
unmanageable and they were trying to
manage their wait list okay so by
introducing multiple tiers to the
structure they were able to pull some
people off the wait list and so it was
an expedience measure and we don't have
that context here we don't have that
problem it's a completely different
context okay so that just wanted to say
you know the multi tier waiver was an
idea it's not well thought out Alvarez
Marcel even says in the report don't
take it lightly figure out the right
thing to do here
and then you know what does that mean
when you look at doing a multi-tier
waiver it is huge it causes you to now
re-evaluate how people are evaluated in
the system what bucket do you fit in and
to come back to software as soon as you
define a bucket Define multiple buckets
you soon realize you've defined the
wrong buckets you don't have it done
well all right so you're going to put
somebody in the wrong bucket and when I
look at this the way things are being
defined it comes it comes down to the
service plan for the individual it
doesn't come come down to what bucket
they fit in it comes down to what they
require what needs do they have buckets
won't Define that the service plan will
Define that okay so I don't see it me
personally I don't see a need for a
two-tier waiver system but let's have
this let's have this uh go to a
commission let's have the commission be
involved or involve people with families
you people with disabilities people with
disabilities themselves and decide what
the right thing to do here is okay so I
support HP 317 okay thank you questions
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
I'm just curious on this two-tiered
system how close assuming we do nothing
here today are we to implementation of
this two-tiered system
think it's a good question it's
currently tabled tabled and then yeah I
have a second follow-up question
um
would that system grandfather people
that are already in the current system
or does the entire everybody on the
disability Spectrum have to be
reevaluated my understanding is it's a
complete reveal and you figure out what
bucket to put people in so that could
result in significant change in services
significant change thank you other
questions
any other questions
thank you thank you for your time
here it comes
foreign
also signed up to testify is Jennifer
Bertrand from Mount Vernon
hello again Jennifer Bertrand from Mount
Vernon a parent of Chloe Bertrand who is
23 year old adults young woman who has a
significant developmental intellectual
disability she's living at home we help
her run her business
um you know she has a good life a
meaningful life and she has a purpose in
the community by performing a service
and enjoying recreational activities I
support HB 317 like will just mentioned
um the bill this morning is different
from this bill because this bill is
really the opportunity to think about
should we even move in this direction
break the DD waiver apart into two tiers
and create these different buckets I
have some personal concerns as did Kathy
spinney who was here earlier
as you might remember she also has an
adult daughter who requires significant
supports
just like my daughter Chloe Chloe would
by would definitely qualify for a the
more
um
not the Family Support waiver but the
um waiver that would provide more robust
services to individuals however
upon reviewing the most recent service
definitions that the department had put
out
it doesn't include that Chloe could live
at home and that her family members and
or dsps in the community could provide
her with that support it would require
us to pick out a place like I don't know
a medical home or a mini Institution
and put her in there instead of living
her life in the community running her
business riding her bike in Amherst
Center and doing all the things that she
loves like kayaking and boating and you
know enjoying Civic engagement like any
of us so that's my real concern and why
I support this bill because we really
need to think about is that splitting
the DD waiver into two separate waivers
capping that lower waiver
would it mean that like all right we
cannot do that to our daughter I can't
pick out a place for her and say yeah
we're just gonna drop you off and leave
you there
and no parent should have to have to
make that choice by the way or maybe
we'll just accept whatever that lower
capped waiver amount even it if it means
that she doesn't have the support that
she needs maybe would mean that I quit
my job and we just figure out a way to
live on my husband's salary while
helping our other children you know go
to college or move on with their lives
um
that many families won't have that
choice and then you might be looking at
families that might need more govern
government assistance because they just
can't bear to place their daughter or
their son in a placement
people people don't want to live in
placements necessarily we even heard
testimony from Michelle earlier and we
talked out in the hall we used to serve
on the council on developmental
disabilities and the reason why she's
moving into that that medical home is
because she couldn't find the support
that she needed because of the workforce
crisis having a waiver two-tiered waiver
like this I see creating more challenges
than you know it solving problems
okay
thank you representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking the question
um this should not
um be taken as any kind of comment on
the two-tier waiver system versus what
we have now I I don't really know
anything about it and I understand
people being very concerned who's um
who are in the system or whose family
members are in the system but I'm kind
of hung up on why and and so it's very
important that there be a very
um vibrant dialogue about this issue
before it comes to fruition but I'm
I'm wondering why that can't happen in
the context of the council
which already meets which also already
has a structure which wouldn't have to
recruit new people or duplicate people
in another group why is that the council
not an Avenue to do the same thing
you're describing that is so important
to do
you know makes me think back to when we
New Hampshire made the decision to
fundamentally change the Medicaid system
we went from our fee for service to you
know managed care approach if you might
you might remember that we created a
commission to study that transition and
I think the reason to study this is in
many ways the same as why we made the
decision to study that trans transition
I think this would provide more public
more
um
structured
thoughtful process
which would be needed because
if it were to move forward like it
what's being proposed now
I mean imagine what that would mean to
to Chloe and her life or Kelly who lives
at home with Kathy
follow up follow up once again I'm not
commenting at all about whether it's a
good idea or not just kind of where that
dialogue should take place and
um
and there is an issue that comes before
us all the time about the abundance of
commissions and the difficulty getting
people to serve on them and that some
languish without really
getting a quorum or not so
my question is only really and and I
think you've answered it um
only about whether we already have a
vehicle for this dialogue
um
or not yeah certainly the quality
Council has its responsibilities and the
things that it's supposed to do but I
think this is even bigger than that like
it deserves this much attention and this
kind of structure to more thoughtfully
consider it and be a little bit more
public and
um
and thoughtful about rolling something
like that out
I could be wrong there might be other
people with other points of view thank
you representative Weber
thank you and I was just perking back to
the old the other um
hearing when you passed a picture of
Chloe around and it hasn't passed me so
I'm wondering if it stopped anywhere or
whether you have got it back yeah I do
hope okay great good
okay any other questions yes
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
I'm
really struck with this tiered thing and
I really want to understand it better so
I work with people with chronic
disabilities I see people on a quote
patient-centered individual basis I see
them and I make a decision
what service that they get I don't have
a limit
um I'm trying to understand is that how
if we go from a one-tier system do we go
from that from a patient-centered thing
to something that you can only be here
or here and there's no overlap is that
your understanding so you know I the the
department hasn't released everything
and they've they've tabled it but be
sure it is not off the table and like
will had said I think we given the other
requirements were and we're expected to
meet through CMS it would be too too
much to work on that now but um
I just I lost your question just could
you repeat it yeah I'm trying to
understand
oh what what what it is now in a
one-tiered system versus what a two-tier
system so right now you know we sit down
uh with our local area agency Chloe
served through gateways
and we put together a service budget you
know we look at all the different
aspects of her life like you know she
has these employment support needs and
she needs assistance with all of her
activities of daily living Chloe also
experiences uh a serious seizure
disorder so you know the workers that
support her they need to be
knowledgeable about how to keep her safe
when she has a full-blown tonic clonic
seizure she also is non-verbal and uses
a variety of communication strategies so
we sit down and we look at like all the
different aspects of her life what is it
what does a good life mean to Chloe she
loves to go bike riding and you know she
does some adaptive skiing and she loves
the Black Diamond Trails because she's
like her mom she like gets that Thrill
of the rush you know
um so we sit down we put together
um uh her service plan and when she was
transitioning from you know into
adulthood uh we built a budget based on
Chloe as an individual and what it means
to her to have a good life
the bureau's also been working on
rate revisions and some of the
conversations are using this thing
called the supports intensity scale and
tying like the the number that someone
receives for their support's intensity
scale to like a budget amount and maybe
that would be correlated when they do do
a two-tiered waiver you know which
waiver the individual would receive
right now it's just the DD waiver it's
based on who is this individual what
does it look like for them to live you
know a meaningful life and everyone
served on that waiver now I know there
are challenges there are individuals
with more
um robust needs that sometimes could
even be uh the behavioral challenges you
know they could sometimes be a danger
maybe to others and they require maybe
even a two to one that type of thing
some people end up either like in an
emergency room or so on and so forth
certainly
um you know we need to address those
things you also talked this morning
about bringing some folks back from
Florida that you know have been placed
there because of the extensive support
needs that they require yeah I mean we
definitely need to work on how that
happens in the state but the way that
it's currently proposed if we were to go
a two-tiered waiver and based on the
definition service definitions that I
reviewed and that Kathy reviewed where
would Chloe go where would
um Kelly go
um
it won't allow family families are not
written in for that comprehensive waiver
I hate creating more buckets because
there's always going to be those
individuals that aren't going to fall
they're going to like be in between or
outside of a bucket somewhere and then
what do you do
you know it's my personal opinion as a
family member with a 23 year old
daughter who has been active in the
community support system to have a
comprehensive waiver and that we could
still continue to put the individual who
needs support first and to build a
budget based on
their individual needs and their hopes
and their dreams and what it means to
live a meaningful life
thank you just have a follow-up on the
quick follow-up so what in effect I hate
the word one you're talking about a
multi-tiered spectrum as opposed to uh
it's a comprehensive waiver so that you
don't have like you know it's not
separated into buckets like well if your
sis score is this to this number you
fall in this bucket and you know that's
a real medical model approach with a
medical lens my daughter is a person you
know she has a developmental disability
she has certain support needs the sis
can help inform like maybe some of the
supports that she might need to be
receiving but to tie that number to a
budget and then associate that to you
know a capped waiver or you know a
choice of one or two
RSA 171a as it stands right now
it's probably one of the most
Progressive statutes here in the United
States you know they talk about you know
individuals with developmental
disabilities being able to access
service to ameliorate their condition to
support their habilitation and their
ease even a passage in there that talks
about within the bounds of human
knowledge I think we understand ma'am so
to have you know a small finite list and
oh you have to check something off which
box do you want to check that could
really limit people's ability to live
their life representative Weber point of
procedure Mr chairman uh I think it
might be helpful and maybe this has
already happened but I am way behind on
some of my communications would it be
possible perhaps to ask our researcher
to do a a memo for us about the
two-tiered system so that we could have
a baseline of knowledge that that that
comes from
her experience Christina
okay thank you does that and that will
take care of a lot of those questions
and it might also tell us who to go to
to ask
in in the department about what's being
contemplated
or not contemplated
other questions for this lady
and if I may I not meaning to diminish
at all your concerns and your concerns
about how it's implemented I I do
understand those I just I just want to
be sure we have really clear information
from
our researcher and others about where we
are now
I appreciate the thoughtful approach and
you know there are a lot of questions
that we've asked and Bureau doesn't have
answers to those yet so that's why I
support the bill because we need a more
specific thoughtful way to
seriously consider making this change
right thank you
any other questions I see none thank you
last person to who has signed up to
testify is is Adora Rodriguez legendre
New Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities
hello thank you again to members of the
committee for hearing my testimony on
HB 317 so if I could just for a moment
tell you a little bit more about the DD
counselor the developmental disabilities
Council we're a federally funded state
agency whose membership is at least 60
percent people with lived experience and
connection to intellectual and
developmental disabilities and this
really ensures that the work that we do
and the advocacy we do is led by the
people most impacted by the decisions
made in our service system and so that's
also why we are a member on the equality
Council and why we think it's so
important to make sure that family
members and community members are really
engaged in a thoughtful and meaningful
way when making decisions
so
um although this I wasn't going to
comment on a two-tier waiver system
um but since it's come up over and over
I think it's important to know that
although this work has been tabled you
heard from the Department today that
they plan to pick it up again this year
right and so understanding that
um it's a pause and that's exactly the
word they use it's a pause on the
implementation of this and the
development of this system we have
significant concerns about whether a
two-tiered waiver system is even
necessary
they talked about the development of
currently happening of service arrays
available to individuals with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities
so if we are doing true person-centered
evaluations on people's needs and
providing those supports to People based
on their needs why would you need to
tier that why not just develop a full
array of services and allow an
individual to receive the services that
they need based on that whatever
assessment and tools you're going to use
to determine what their needs are to
have a meaningful community-based life
because that's what we're talking about
one that we would also want for
ourselves right and so
we're all for studying things that have
such a huge impact on our system and I
just want to address a couple of
comments that I heard earlier about some
of the other work that's happening and
could perhaps the quality Council be a
body that helps provide feedback and
evaluation of a two-tiered waiver system
and I want to point out that one of the
reasons that that other bill was
presented here today is because although
opportunities for feedback
are provided it does not necessarily
mean that there's going to be an impact
on the decisions made and that I think
is that piece that we're really talking
about here we want to make sure that
there are stakeholders on a commission
that really one have a really good sense
of what the needs of the developmental
disabilities Community has but also that
half the power and the ability to make
decisions like you all do to be able to
say
um this is not a meaningful way to
provide services for people in the
community and that we may need to go
back to the drawing board on this and so
you can be getting wrapping up
absolutely so actually my testimony is
mostly about there are some people
missing on this commission if you're
going to establish a commission you need
to make sure that there are individuals
who are receiving services on the
commission family members
a person from the developmental
disabilities
Council would be a recommendation I
would make again because our membership
is comprised of people with disabilities
that are directly impacted by the
decisions made and then
um also a member of the developmental
Services quality Council because again
we have seen that their input in some
cases has been circumvented in decisions
that have been made thus far
that's it for me thank you questions
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here uh
if we were to charge the council with uh
working on this project would that meet
your needs of having the people in the
community appropriately heard
so it would but I believe that it would
be missing that other piece of the
legislative input and the legislative
resource to to be able to say
you can't do this right because again
we've provided input in a number of
different ways to the bureau on changes
that are being developed in the system
and I think that some of those changes
need to happen and some of those changes
are optional and it's it's about
families not only being heard but that
their input is the most valuable for
implementing changes and I think that's
the piece that we haven't seen really
been taken into consideration follow-up
thank you and as follow-up then if we
had the council write a report on this
and provide it to the this committee The
Joint Committee of oversight and the
Senate Health and Human Services
committee with that and make it so that
you feel that your voices are being
heard by us of the legislature so that
we can take action I mean I definitely
think as long as there's a commitment
from the legislature to take that
information really provide thoughtful
evaluation and create future legislation
around those that input yes
thank you other questions
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman just quickly what
were the three groups of added
representation so um it is in my
testimony I have a list a member of the
developmental Services quality Council
a member of the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities
a state Family Support council member
which represents families in our service
system and an individual with lived
experience of intellectual and
developmental disability thank you other
questions
so you know other questions
okay thank you thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on this bill has anyone else wish to
testify on House Bill 317.
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on House Bill B17 that
concludes all of the bills that we had
noticed for today in terms of public
hearings and we will now be going into
hold on we go into it at three o'clock
so we can have a bio break if necessary
okay uh I'll buy that why don't we
recess until 3 pm
I wasn't sure if anybody wanted to do
that given the hour but either way it's
fine what's that yes I saw people
fidgeting in their seats okay
I might as well take
foreign
thank you
my heart goes outside
are you ready to go
oh she's just giving him
okay I'd like to call the um meeting
back to order we are now in executive
session
and at this time I'd recognize Vice
chairman Leon from motion
Mr chairman um we on House Bill 614 I
would like to move Amendment uh
2023-0533h that's moving down the line
um each Direction
emotions been made and seconded
on Amendment 2023 hyphen 0533h is that
the one yes okay would you like to speak
to your motion representative yes thank
you Mr chairman
um I want to thank representative Nancy
Murphy for bringing us the amendment um
initially in order to take the findings
of the pfas and the environmental talk
environmental disease uh work groups to
be able to move this forward and I'd
also like to thank her for working with
me in the department to draft a language
where we can appropriate the the money
that's required but also yes it was
seconded by Weber
um sorry so that we can we can make it
so that the department is seeking out
grants from the CDC NIH or other grants
first
and they can't access the funds until
it's approved by the oversight committee
so that this is actually a feasible plan
if they're unable to find grant funding
then they'll have access to those funds
if they do find grant funding then that
500 000 would go into a non-lapsing fund
so that it can move toward forwards
towards additional phases this is a way
to make sure that it can move forward
but we're able to maximize on what's
already happening on this exact same
issue nationally and I hope that this
can have everyone's support
uh discussion
seeing no discussion
okay if I see no discussion and by the
way I'd like to recognize we have a
couple of substitutes here
representative Melvin representative
long welcome
and uh Mr Clark are you ready almost
okay just I'm just gonna get the clerk a
moment to
can't do it without him
okay that's the fact callable
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative Wong yes
and representative McDonald yes 20-0
there's no well you're not the main bill
yet
right
and I'd like to move ought to pass as
amended by Amendment 0533h on House Bill
614.
okay would you like to speak to your
motion representative Leon um thank you
Mr chairman I think that everything was
encompassed in this amendment so
um I'll talk just long enough for the
clerk to be able to make his notes and
be ready for the next one okay is there
any other discussion by committee
members
seeing none um
again once when the clock is ready
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri yes
representative
Nagel yeah
representative Melvin
yes
representative Weber yes
representative what uh McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes
and representative McDonald yes
uh 19 to 1.
okay there's no objection we'll put it
on the consent calendar Mr chairman I
don't believe it can because it contains
an appropriation I think it has to go on
the regular calendar okay thank you
representative Weber
okay representative Leon
I'll recognize you or
no okay House Bill 282 is up next
and I'd recognize representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman um I would like to
make a motion I have an amendment
um
to bring forward which I did pass out
but I have more copies if people don't
have it
um so I would like to make a motion to
adopt Amendment zero one six zero
zero one six zero do you have spares
I think I've seen that either you
haven't seen it either yes zero one six
zero
and the clerk needs it
the clerk doesn't have it either
that's correct
okay so you're moving this amendment
representative Shapiro always have a
second by the way
I'll second it
okay thank you representative Weber
would you like to speak to your emotion
representative Shapiro
yes I will
um the amendment does one thing and one
thing only it changes the appropriation
and I don't have a numbered bill in
front of me but
um in part two of the original bill it
calls for an appropriation of a hundred
and eighteen thousand dollars
for the fiscal year ending June 30th
2024 and this was a result this is the
exact same thing that was taken from the
bill I
um submitted last year
and so
um now that we're in a different year we
need to cover 18 months until the end of
the biennium the bill would go into
effect January 1st 2024 and we need to
cover 18 months as opposed to six months
that we would have had a cover had the
bill passed last year
unfortunately because OLS seemed to be
so backed up I couldn't get them to
change it in time so the amount of the
new appropriation is 336 thousand
dollars to cover an 18-month period And
if you look at the
um fiscal note
you'll see that it's totally consistent
with the fiscal note which is 224 000 in
state funds
for 2024 and the same for 2025 that
would be 448 000 and 336 000 which is
the new appropriation would be three
quarters of the 18 months worth
so I would ask you to
um vote to adopt this
um
so we can get on with talking about the
actual bill
okay any other discussion on this
amendment
okay saying none I will ask the clerk to
call a roll a motion is ought to pass
right octopass on Amendment 2023-0160h
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kopal yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative excuse me representative
Melvin
yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes
and representative McDonald yes
19-1
okay the amendment passes 19 to 1.
and um
representative Shapiro do you have a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion
that we
um vote ought to pass as amended by
Amendment 0160 on House Bill 282. okay
is there a second second
representative Merchant seconds
any discussion
representative Chipotle do you want to
speak to emotion or yes I do
so
there are many reasons why I would hope
that we would pass this bill the first
one is the kind of investment in
families and in child and maternal
Health
um there's a bunch of research that I
found on this but
research shows that children and
um
pregnant women who do not are not
covered
receive less care and that that results
in delayed treatment for children and an
increase in
um
low birth weights and infant mortality
for pregnant women
um
there's a there's a lot of specific
research but I my main point really is
that it's a good investment in families
and in Children And getting people off
to the right start I think one aspect an
important aspect of this bill is that
welcoming immigrants to New Hampshire is
is certainly not going to solve our
Workforce Problem by any means but it's
one small part that we can do to
um
to create a more vibrant and greater
Workforce and I just want to talk about
one person I met in the course of
researching this bill someone directed
me to this fellow who was vice president
of pitco friellator anybody know pitco
friellator it's evidently a
Manufacturing Company in Concord I'd
never heard of it and it's
um they make friolators for McDonald's
all over the world and they were really
during the pandemic they were really
really hurting in terms of Workforce and
someone suggested to them that they hire
four of the Afghan evacuees who had been
brought to Concord and they did that as
a kind of a
pilot program
um and
um when I spoke to the vice president
the Afghan evacuees had been here for
about nine months and they had hired 40
Afghan evacuees and they were in the
process of figuring out how they could
create
um a room where people could pray since
Muslims pray five times a day they felt
like that had really been salvaged their
Workforce
so once again I don't think it's the
solution to Workforce but we certainly
don't want to hang out a sign that's
saying we're the only state in the
Northeast that doesn't have this program
that welcomes immigrants
I also just wanted to comment briefly
about some of the comments that came up
during the hearing about
um
the ACA and um why can't these people
just get insurance through the
Affordable Care Act and um
certainly some immigrants can get
um
get health care coverage through the
Affordable Care Act but I want to just
kind of give you an example of people
who can't we talked a lot about or I
talked a lot about how
um
you know this was not a a binary
situation between documented people and
undocumented and while all these people
have to be lawfully residing there are
all kinds of lawfully residing
immigrants so let me just give you the
example of a family that moved to Keene
my hometown
um this was a family who entered the
country and immediately asked for Asylum
they were in Texas they found a family
who would spot a group and a family who
would sponsor them in Keene they were a
family of a married couple and three
children
so they moved to Keene either before
they moved to Keene or right after they
got came to Keene they got legal
assistance and they
um made application for Asylum
in order to make application for Asylum
you have to pass a credible fear
interview which means that there's a
good chance that you will get Asylum
because you're coming from a country
where if you went back you would be in
danger of
um
of being killed because of religious
persecution or because of political
persecution of or because of gang
activity
so these are people that are not coming
just because they
um
want to get Medicaid they're people who
are coming because their situation is
really bleak
so so for this family of three children
and um
a mother and a father
if this bill passes and if the five-year
wait is waived these children would have
been eligible for Medicaid
180 days after they made their initial
application
the mom if she was pregnant would have
been eligible for
Medicaid after her work permit was given
which is something that usually happens
about halfway between when somebody
applies for Asylum and when they have
their final hearing where they will
either get Asylum or not
so in this particular case not relevant
for the woman because she wasn't
pregnant but these three children would
have had Medicaid
they've been here for almost three years
now and um they would have had Medicaid
um two and a two and a half years ago
whereas medical providers in Keene have
been providing unreimbursed services for
them
um because that's their value and
because they step forward to do that so
that's an example
um of people who would not be able to
access the Affordable Care Act because
they really came with nothing and with
no money and with no possessions
people who come through family
unification where family may have some
more resources those people possibly
could access the Affordable Care Act
in in summary this bill will ease the
eligibility for a small number perhaps
300 children and pregnant women all of
who were lawfully residing in this state
at a reasonable cost to our state
no undocumented immigrants will be
eligible under this option
and so I would urge you to
vote
ought to pass on 282.
okay any other discussion
representative Leon representative King
thank you chairman McDonald
I'd like to speak against voting for
this bill I vote for itl
so you should all know me by now that
I'm against the welfare state
I'm against it for a philosophical and
economic reasons which I won't bore you
with again
but secondly as far as immigration is
concerned
I don't like the entitlement mentality
that exists even amongst Americans in
this country
and I think that's in large part due to
the entitlement state that we have
I don't believe people are entitled to
all of these things these are things
that we need to work for and learn to
live within our means and strive for
it's not something that you're entitled
to based on other people's taxes
secondly
um you know a few years ago we had a
presidential candidate I'm not sure
exactly where I went but he was talking
about how we really don't want
immigrants in this country that uh are
going to be dependent on freebies in
fact he was talking about we should get
rid of green cards and
um allowing immigrants that are going to
be here dependent on freebies if you
they couldn't stand on their own they
shouldn't be here and I agree with that
completely matter of fact we have three
immigrants on this board who I'm pretty
sure came here not because of the
freebies but for the freedom the freedom
from overburden some taxes and uh the
welfare state that they ran away from in
their own country
um and um
so yeah I'm against it for all of those
reasons if you want to talk about
immigrants who come here with nothing we
should think about the people that came
here on the Mayflower I mean these
people had nothing
and uh and they were fleeing uh
religious persecution so but they didn't
have an entitlement uh welfare system to
come to and they built the greatest
country that ever lived so I totally
reject the idea that somebody who is
needy has to depend only on the state
this is something that could be done
through voluntary charity it can be done
through the marketplace it does not need
to be done through government large s i
reject that wholeheartedly and I will do
that for all bills similar to this thank
you thank you representative
um thank you Mr chairman
um I think it's very interesting that we
started off this discussion about
welcoming immigrants and I'm opposed to
this bill because the way that I want to
welcome immigrants isn't by making them
rely on the state which happens in too
many other countries in the world but to
make sure that our community is
empowered and enabled to welcome our
newest Neighbors in we should be doing
that through employers who are hiring
them making sure that they're offering
benefits and making sure that we have
systems where people can contribute to
their care or offer that through direct
primary if people supported these
families in direct primary that would
work we heard a bill earlier where if it
was amended so that we could have people
contribute money to provide care for
people that would be an option in places
like birthing centers I want to welcome
immigrants and I want to welcome them
into a community that doesn't just say
here's a government that's going to help
you but says hi I'm your neighbor and
I'm going to help you so that's why I'm
opposed to this bill although I
appreciate we're all trying to get
to the same thing just just in different
ways
I just want to respond to a couple of
things it may not change anyone's mind
but in regards to taxes
my understanding is these people are
employed gainfully and therefore they're
paying taxes but they're getting nothing
in return for it
in regards to the Mayflower
if it wasn't for the benefit of the
Indians who are here
they probably wouldn't have survived
because they had a safety net around
them to help them get through some hard
times
in regards to looking at
the policy itself not the economics of
it
it's only falafly
rise adding people awfully residing in
the United States so I'll just leave you
those things is that I'm not talking
about the illegal aliens not talking
about DACA workers they're talking about
people here lawfully
they pay taxes
and don't forget the Mayflower was
survived by survived because of the
support if you will of the American
Indians
okay thank you
uh yes representative Cushman sorry
thank you Mr chairman representative
Coachman representative McLean sorry
um
I just wanted to make note that the
difference between the Native Americans
helping us and the welfare state that um
was referred to earlier is that one is
voluntary
they helped voluntarily and the others
through taxation which is forced
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair
um I you know representative Shapiro
when when you tell me your story it
really touches my heart
um one of my best friends is an Iranian
immigrant who came over under just those
circumstances her uncle was beheaded
um you know when the when the Shah fell
and so they came over here with nothing
and her contribution to this country in
in the decade sense has I think just
been incredible so I have a lot of
sympathy uh with what you're saying but
I really think that as these people are
coming in they bring enormous value but
we we seem to be just adopting this one
approach and that is we're putting them
all into Medicaid we just heard
testimony today about how the critical
access hospitals Etc they're all on the
verge of breaking and I really think
that we have to be looking at other
approaches as to how we integrate these
very valuable people into our community
thank you
another discussion yes representative
um I I I'm kind of wondering actually
who are writing this bill for because I
as I talked to a variety of people and
there is somebody from the New Hampshire
Hospital Association here who I'm
staring at right now but but um you know
the initial thought is is the immigrants
we we had a um a plan the Lutheran
society that they would bring immigrants
here they've got eight months of
Medicaid I'm not sure how they swung
that and then they're on their own
um most of the people that you had
talked about the pipco folks they
actually get health insurance through
pitco so they've actually gone from this
stage to actually being functional
members whatever that means of society
but that's not what the issue that
started to make me think a little
differently about this
um we're talking about hospitals in
danger and I would probably asked our
two other doctors to maybe comment on
this because you work in hospital
settings and I don't but they're going
to get care one way or the other
you know there it's either going to get
paid care or not paid care and these
people are going to go to the hospital
and the hospital is going to eat that
care so in the end it wasn't clear
whether this bill to me was going to
benefit the immigrants as much as it
would benefit the hospitals and I would
really love to hear your thoughts about
that
um because you deal with that issue a
lot more than I do
um but that was that was the point of
view that made me think about this a
little differently
representative King and then
representative Shapiro are you ready to
end up I think a minute ago
oh yeah although this may confuse some
of you I'm actually going to vote for
this bill and
um I'm on and the reason is Con it will
be confusing is because I'm actually on
the same plane as what uh representative
Seth King mentioned
um maybe not in as strong a terms but
I'm not a big fan of creating more
programs and I'm not a fan of you know
the Medicaid extension but to what
representative menagle said you know
we're going to we're going to be paying
for this whether it's uh whether it's
through the emergency room and they and
the hospital eats it or whether we pay
for it through Medicaid and
um
oh
the other the other thing I see this as
is kind of a pro-life look at things
where we're actually here to help the
mother during her pregnancy and so I see
this I see this in a way of helping the
unborn child
and uh the last thing I'll say and this
is actually where my blood starts to
boil a little bit is that
um
quite honestly I wouldn't I don't want
to see this taken care of through taxes
I'd like to see this taken care of
through the churches and I just don't
see the church being in a position to to
handle the amount of help that these
women need we live in a state where only
four percent of the people go to church
and four percent just isn't enough to
support this but maybe in three years
from now uh maybe through some of our
activity we can actually support the
church in a way that that we don't have
to rely on tax dollars and so that's why
I'm voting for this at this time and I
would hope that in three years we don't
need this through Medicaid
representative Shapiro and then
representative Webber thank you Mr
chairman I I would urge people to um try
to view this in a less than black and
white
um Viewpoint
um
I actually share people's concern about
Medicaid or some other benefits
um creating or maintaining dependency I
worked for years as a psychotherapist
mostly with pretty people who were poor
and and pretty marginalized not all of
them but um some of them had health care
through their employers some of them
didn't have any health care
a fair amount of them had um
Healthcare through Medicaid and
um
I don't really disagree with you that
Medicaid or other benefits can at times
maintain a um a dependency I I think
there are things we could fix in the
Medicaid Program that might help that
but I would ask you to kind of every
Bill week that comes before us has a
positive and a negative or many
positives and many negatives and
um to the degree that anybody who goes
on Medicaid
becomes dependent on Medicaid and never
goes to work and lives
um you know a marginal existence that's
a bad thing but I would say to you that
that's not the case at all for
um all the people who go on Medicaid
even most of the people who go on
Medicaid I don't have the statistics and
I don't think there's anybody here who
has some but I think many many many
people on Medicaid work and work
full-time and still qualify for Medicaid
um the best of all situations is that
it's something that keeps you in good
health something that once they're a
dental benefit will help you get better
teeth so you won't be in pain all the
time so that you are able to be a more
independent person that you are able to
go to work that you are able to take
care of yourself
I also want to address the black and
white situation in terms of
being dependent
on government subsidies versus why don't
the communities take care of these
people or why don't the churches take
care of these people and I would say I
agree with you
um I would say that in a lot of parts of
the state churches are doing just that
for immigrant populations and in Keene
where I live where there's a an
organization called project home that
takes in Asylum Seekers
um
that is not specifically through the
church but it's through the community
and P and these organ this organization
has raised thousands and thousands of
dollars
um through the generosity of people in
our community
um to sponsor people in their homes
people have taken people into their
homes they've used the money that
they've raised to help them with legal
assistance with medical assistance with
clothes for kids so they can go to
school so I wouldn't assume that just
because someone is now going to be
eligible for Medicaid that the community
is doing nothing to support these people
okay thank you representative Weber
I just want to make one small
point to representative Nagel's inquiry
um
if somebody goes to the hospital
[Music]
if if they have Medicaid it's paid for
the by the government but if they have
Medicaid they might have gone to a
primary care provider before they needed
the hospital
so that's one thing
uh secondly if they go to the hospital
and it's completely uncovered then it's
uncompensated care and there's a
complicated system of reimbursement
which also
deals in tax dollars so it's not
again it's not black and white but the
final thing is that if they don't have
some kind of coverage there are people
who will not seek care at all
and that's a tragedy and it's
particularly a tragedy because all we're
talking about here
is pregnant women and small children and
I think we owe they don't have a right
to work the children don't the mothers
may but they may not be able to
but we're talking about kids here and we
know that every dollar that we spend
on giving a kid a good start in life
returns
ten later tenfold going on in terms of
care that we don't have to give them
later on so for that reason I will be
voting for the bill
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
inviting me to comment uh representative
Nagel uh and you're exactly right as you
know and I know and I I think Paula
minnahan's from the hospital Society
mentioned this today is that a patient
that comes to the hospital uh will be
taken care of regardless of ability to
pay that's that's a no-brainer that's
always that's always been my experience
and that's what the hospitals in the
state do the problem with that is that
they go to the hospital usually because
of an emergency or some more acute
injury and as representative Weber said
you know this would also help to support
them in a preventative manner
um so I I yes you're right it regardless
of who's going to cover the bill whether
it's you know a church a local
organization philanthropy or Medicaid
um we're going to take care of them but
it would be much better to take care of
them early on rather than an acute
situation and lastly
it's it's it's important to recognize
though this is the business part of
medicine I always I'll always love the
professional side of medicine but the
business side does exist and without if
they have Medicaid for insurance
I hate to hear the the statement over
and over again the hospitals will eat it
you know that is a problem for not only
the hospitals maintaining their
viability but for the communities in
which they serve there have been a
number of hospitals in this state that
have actually shut down because of
finances if you look at the critical
access hospitals in the state there
which there are a number 16 maybe of the
16 if you were to check in their balance
sheet and their budgets every year at
least a dozen of them are in the red we
used to always say if we didn't have a
bottom bottom line meaning philanthropy
we were in the red it was only the
bottom bottom line that supported us so
this is this this is more far-reaching
than just simply taking care of the
patient and the mother it it helps our
whole community and our state thank you
representative Seth King
thank you again chairman
um I'd like to make just three quick
points one to address representative
Bill King and that is there's nothing
more permanent than a temporary
government program had there been some
sort of clause in here that said this
expired in three years then I think
maybe what you're saying might have more
possibility but there is no way this has
ever gone away
number two I've got citizens citizens
who were born and raised in this country
who make just barely enough not to
qualify for Medicaid and too little to
actually pay for their own insurance and
now we're going to give people who had
don't have any blood sweater tears in
the building of this country we're going
to give them Medicaid that's a slap in
the face that's borderline treason as
far as I'm concerned and number three
the elephant in the room that nobody is
discussing is the fact that this country
is 31 trillion dollars in debt and
there's a lot of people that like to
talk about systemic this or systemic
that well let me tell you what there is
a systemic risk to the financial
solvency of this country and it's not a
matter of if it's only a matter of when
when the dollar implodes
when all hell breaks loose there are
going to be so many dependents on the
system that it is going to be
unmitigated human misery that has not
been seen in our lifetimes so just keep
that in mind thank you
okay I think we've talked it to death um
yes one final comment representative
Nagel
ank microphone sorry
um the the comment is that we've been
focusing on women but the actual bill
says children up to age 19 which I think
kind of gets to what you're getting at
with what you're saying so it's not just
women and and I think that that creates
a little bit of a problem for me the
other question I had just has to do with
Medicaid expansion because this actually
refers to Medicaid expansion and my
understanding was that was a 90-10 thing
and this is a 50 50 thing you know what
I'm saying so um Medicaid expansions 90
federal dollars 10 State dollars and
this is 50 50. I I don't understand that
respond if you wish again
this this potentially could have people
from traditional Medicaid or from
expanded medicaid
um in the case of the pregnant woman it
could be expanded medicaid so I think
the numbers are so small they went with
the con in the fiscal note they went
with the conservative
um amounts which would be the 50 50
match so it could potentially be 90 10.
for some people it could be
so that would make this this state match
um quite a bit less
but I I think they it's a small number
of people a small amount of money they
just
did it that way thank you
all right uh I'd like to move on uh
anybody got anything really pressing to
say at this point not uh Alaska clerk to
call the roll
motion is ought to pass as amended on
House Bill 282. if I'm if I remember
correctly
that's what I have
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King yes
Representative copal no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King nope
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative friedas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative Merchant
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes
representative McDonald no
and
uh 12 to 8 okay the bill passes after
pass passes 12 to 8 is amended
okay moving on Mr chairman
representative Shapiro
oh okay
you like the majority report okay is
there a Minority Report all right The
Minority Report the motions itl
okay
okay moving on House Bill 500 is next
for our consideration uh representative
Bland do you have an um you have an
amendment um I think representative
Merchant has an amendment oh I do have
an amendment yes perfect
I apologize representative Merchant
handed out the amendment it is amendment
505 sorry 507 h
uh I need more coffee I apologize
I'll second that
okay representative Leon you want to
speak to your motion uh thank you Mr
chairman uh this amendment takes all of
that confusing language that we had
trying to make sense of all those
different sections and consolidates it
to say that a physician and then the
other one
um
um an APRN is able to prescribe
non-opioid and opioid control drugs
classified in schedule two through four
by means of telemedicine after
establishing a relationship this
includes all the safeguards that already
were in there and the safeguards that
are in the current federal program that
expires on May 11th
um this is a good path for us to be able
to continue providing the good high
quality services to establish patients
and others under a good safety mechanism
and to keep that continuity of care now
that kovid got us over our fear of
telemedicine so I'm hopeful that we can
pass this and send it to the Senate so
they can do some quick work on it
thank you any other discussion on
Amendment 0507h
seeing none I'll ask the clerk if he's
ready
to call of all
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes
and representative McDonald yes
the vote is 20 to zero okay thank you
and now representative Murphy I believe
you have a motion
thank you Mr chairman yes I would like
to pass
um uh ought to pass with Amendment uh
house bill 500.
thank you is there a second
oh sorry would you like a second
representative yes yeah okay thank you
okay would you like to speak to your
motion okay thank you Murphy yes
um
after a very uh well I'd like to thank
representative Merchant for all his help
with the amendment
um and also the committee because of
last week's very deliberative and
thoughtful process
um trying to discern exactly how this
bill should be uh proposed
um I think what we have come up with is
a much more clear and succinct bill
which really allows Physicians to do
what they have done for the past two
plus years during the emergency order uh
during the pandemic which is to
prescribe
controlled drugs scheduled two to four
uh via Telehealth
um they've been doing this for the past
two years they've been doing this
successfully and would venture to say
that the satisfaction for patients
providers and families as importantly
has been equal to if not better than in
person primarily because the people that
are dealing with this mostly are those
that are involved in palliative care
post-surgical patients with their pain
levels change
young adolescents with ADHD that need
medication that don't have to get out of
school or their parents don't have to
take off a day of work so I'm very
thankful for the committee for actually
coming up with some very thoughtful
comments we got rid of the clunky
exception to the exception we now have a
bill which I think is much more clear
succinct and is truly a very strong
patient advocacy bill this is really
basically what I think of as a normal
evolution of the continual Improvement
in medical care for patients Telehealth
is here to stay this is part of it and
this just adds to the um the ability of
providers to take care of patients in
some very difficult circumstances so
thank you for allowing me to speak to it
any other discussion
see no discussion
all right Miss Clark are you are you
ready I am ready okay motion is ought to
pass
um on
that to pass is amended on House Bill
500.
representative land yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin
yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative long yes and
representative McDonald yes
20 to 0.
thank you
and that can consent and consent okay
yep without objection
and is representative Murphy writing the
report for the committee he already has
oh okay excellent hey I like that never
mind and again I would like to thank uh
representative Merchant with his assist
oh by the way that was our last early
bill so we really
we passed the Milestone today Mr chair
what's that what's that sorry on the
early bills things we voted on so far
Windows have to be submitted to the
clerk
um what's the process I believe we're
supposed to get our reports in for that
tonight which I know will probably be in
the early morning on Lindsay's desk
um so before our coffee please the
deadline is usually noon on Wednesday
and that ship has sailed but it needs to
go in the next calendar so it's got to
be in as soon as possible and I will
remind people of the days
because I've been around long enough and
representative McKay will join you where
you didn't leave the room before your
report was submitted so who do I submit
oh sorry who does representative Murphy
Smith the report to if you send it to me
I'll I'll quickly review it and I will
send it over that's what I've been doing
with all of them okay my guess is
they're holding the calendar for the
early bills which need to be done so I
think the debt drop deadline drop dead
deadline is tomorrow at noon yeah thanks
and we also might as well submit all the
other ones that we can too because we
may be able to get those into this
calendar as well
we're going to be sleeping in the house
next week we might as well make the most
of the most of them
okay I'm moving on to House Bill 188 uh
representative Nagel I believe you have
a motion
is there a second representative Weber
seconds
representative Nagel do you want to
speak to your motion
yes
um
yes I I work with physical therapists
for a very long period of time um
physical therapists are now required to
have a doctorate
um to practice the state of New
Hampshire podiatrists are required to
have a doctorate chiropractors are
required to have a doctorate
acupuncturist naturopaths all those
people can perform their services
without a physician's prescription at
all
um I brought up during the testimony
that if you look at the best physical
therapists in the world they come from
Australia and in Australia what's unique
there is they can practice independently
which allows them a sense of creativity
and I've had the honor of serving with a
couple of Australian PTs in the work
that I do and I really think that the
pts here is a starting this is a
starting point for what I hope will
become more freedom and their ability to
do things um with a doctorate they have
the ability to practice what they know
how to do to one to ask for help when
they know to ask for help and I think
this is a small step forward
thank you of the discussion
seeing no other discussion I'll ask her
to call the roll
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yep
representative Melvin yes representative
Weber yes
representative McKay yes
yes representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes
is that Palmer yes
representative long yes
and representative McDonald yes
money to zero
okay
consent consent
no no
[Laughter]
you're the only person who has to write
something but this one could be a really
very quick one uh in that all you have
to say is that currently
this is what they do and then
because of the advanced degrees and
everything else we think that this is an
artificial distinction that should be
removed I appreciate it when somebody
writes something really detailed but at
the same time
three lines
is good on the calendar I think mine was
the second longest One Last Time most
committee reports are not nearly that
long so as you've probably already
noticed so while I appreciate detail
it's it's not as critical as you might
okay moving on uh next up is uh House
Bill 554 and I believe representative
Merchant you have a motion
554 oh yes
along with my recommendation is to
retain the bill and my rationale to it
is we actually have three bills coming
together sort of at the same time
one was going into Commerce which was
House Bill 303 that was supported by
representative Nagel the other one was
also 554 which is represented longrin
they both have the same objective
they're trying to figure out how to help
patients
obtain if you will non-opiate therapy
not alternates if you will
in House Bill 66 hopefully we'll talk
about later is to create a committee the
study committee to explore both of those
bills and try to find a way to
work with the stakeholder Community
draft language
maybe take both of those bills weave
them together into one bill
to make them both workable and
beneficial to the patients
thank you motion's been made in second
representative Leon seconds any other
discussion
yes please oh yes representative Nagel
um just to give a little history behind
this bill it was actually originally
submitted by
um representative mangaputi about three
years ago
um it has some significant issues that I
don't want to go into any detail on
right now
um
um and what she and I talked about it at
length and we both agreed to sit down
and study it which we kind of did then
the the bill kind of took on a life of
its own
um if you want I can talk about the
flaws but I think that's why okay I
won't
um the other little Minor Detail is 303
which represent a merchant referred to
as in the bill and it really was never
supposed to be part of a bill that's a
Commerce bill so the bill needs work but
it has a lot of value and um that's why
I think it should be retained right any
other discussion
okay the clock is ready I would ask him
to call the wall
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman
yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofol yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative Melvin yes representative
Weber yes
uh representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes
and representative McDonald yes
twenty to zero okay very good
next up is House Bill 66 representative
Nagel I believe you have a motion
you have an amendment
you don't see an amendment is it zero
four three five or is it a different one
Amendment today
I didn't either
um it it was passed out I believe at the
initial hearing because it stapled in
together but this is the same thing
coming around again
foreign
I'm going to remove the original
proposal I will um propose to um to pass
the amendment to house bill 66. and you
have to read the number oh
2023-0435h okay so you were moving out
to pass on that Amendment correct second
is there a second second uh
representative Merchant seconds
representative Nagel do you want to
speak to the amendment
um yes the the primary change that we
made was the original
um Bill asked to create a commission
which we thought was excessive that we
feel that we can do the work that we
need to do in a committee
um that's basically it and and
representative Merchant already pretty
much addressed the virtues of this bill
previously
okay any other discussion
seeing none I will ask Clark to call the
roll
yes representative thank you so is the
only change
making it a committee instead of a
commission
is that the only change or anything a
committee instead of a commission
it does change it from a commission to a
committee but in the commission when we
created the commission there was also
stakeholders that were listed in the
commission those have been
um
have been eliminated so the intent of it
was what
the intent of it is to have the
stakeholder Community pull all of mint
all of them together and not try to be
prescriptive about which stakeholder
Community should be part of it but the
goal here is to be sure we're as
inclusive with stakeholder Community as
possible
thank you representative Weber and I was
just going to emphasize that despite the
removal of the specifics are the intent
is to make it more inclusive rather than
less and less dependent on who was doing
the appointing which was one of the
concerns expressed at the at the first
hearing so that the people who are
interested can come and and be heard
you also representative Cushman yes
thank you yes thank you
um
any other discussion
okay if I see no other discussion let's
I'll have the Clark to call the roll on
this amendment zero two is two zero two
three-0435h to pass
representative land yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative Melvin yes representative
Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative long yes
representative McDonald yes
20-0
representative Nagle do you now have
another motion or
um
should do this at home
um I'd like to make a motion uh to
propose that we have ought to pass for
the amended version of hb66
I'll second that okay representative
Merchant seconds any discussion
seeing none unless the clerk was ready
I'll ask him to call the wall
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes and
representative McDonald yes
twenty to zero
okay without objection we'll put that on
the consent calendar
moving on House Bill 325 all right say
one thing I just developed a dystonia in
my right hand I don't think I can write
that but representative Merchant can do
that okay
moving on speaking of Representative
merchant do you have a motion on House
Bill 325
yes
I think there's an amendment to that
with the past first
okay
indeed you have a copy of the amendment
I passed it out before remember see I
haven't seen that before yes yeah and
it's o431h if you don't have copies I
can
get those to the uh
research assistance maybe she could help
me make some copies
I'm sorry I was trying to keep up with
all of this on House Bill 66 were you
writing that report or would you like me
to do that to help everybody else's
typing fingers okay and did we move
consent on that one yes okay perfect
thank you so can you do folks have a
copy of the amendment 0-4
31h I do
okay sure
um yes
for the kids one the kids
representative Weber in the interest of
time uh we're going to get copies of
that Amendment without parliamentarian
would we have to withdraw the motion and
second on that Amendment if we want to
move on to 611
yes okay all right that was quick
all right uh let's proceed then
okay
we have more amendments and we do bills
well I thought we were going to do six
eleven six eleven yes yes we'll do six
eleven I I are there any amendments on
before we do anything
okay I don't think so so let's uh
proceed to 611. uh representative Leon
um I move ought to pass on House Bill
611.
okay representative Weber seconds
representative Leon do you want to speak
to your motion yes thank you Mr chairman
um what this bill does is it removes
what essentially is a mandate that
people try opioids and irreversible
surgeries before having access to
therapeutic cannabis for severe pain I
don't think that that was ever the
intention When It Was Written but it
ended up being that the impact the the
reality so this is just a way to clear
up this bill and allow cannabis before
therapeutic cannabis before opioids or
spinal fusion or any other
exhausting all other possibilities so I
think that this is something that's
quite common sense and that hopefully we
can all support
another discussion representative Weber
I just wanted to say that from an
historic perspective we're seeing this
with several bills that we will exec
either today or shortly
in that the price of getting a governor
to sign a bill and there were Governors
on both sides of the aisle who were
involved in this was to put fairly
strict restrictions on the program and
that was how we got the program passed
to begin with now that we have a
significant amount of
experience with the program we know or
at least I believe and I think everybody
here believes that expanding the program
rather than keeping the guard rails is
where we need to go so that was the
historic reason for some of these
restrictions that don't seem in 2020
hindsight to make a great deal of sense
okay thank you
of the discussion
um representative Nagel we have three
cannabis bills coming up and I'm going
to probably vote for at least two out of
the three somewhat under protest
um I have a really and I I don't know if
this is the right time to bring up the
concerns that I raised is this the right
time yeah not only on this bill though
it's on it's on this bill
um I've been practicing pain management
for over 30 years I've been advocating
for the rights of people to have access
to a broad range of therapeutic
modalities for third over 30 years I
wrote the opioid prescribing rules 30
years ago and the primary reason why was
I was seeing people in intractable pain
that had failed everything Chiropractic
Care Veterinarian care better yeah
whatever I'll go down the list it
doesn't matter I mean and and and they
were severely disabled by their pain and
and I was told by a society that if I
prescribe long-term opioid therapy for
them that I could end up in jail for
doing that in many states the United
States and that included end of life
care we started in this discussion in
1986 and um I was honored to actually be
offered the Catherine Foley chair at the
center of practical bioethics who wrote
the paper on this subject in 1985 to
point out that it was absolutely absurd
to deny people the end of life access to
reasonable medication to control their
pain and it was really sad that it took
that to happen
um
a lot of myth was was portrayed about
opioids during the course of that
testimony
um I personally believe that I mean in
my practice 30-year practice I have
never ever practiced a prescribed an
opioid to anybody
that had not failed multiple modalities
beforehand and I'm fully aware that in
some instances that doesn't happen but
when we look at the data on outcome of
opioid therapy our belief from day one
and we wrote this in 1987 was that
there's a small percentage of people
that can respond very well to opioid
therapy for a long period of time for
chronic pain
we still to this date don't know who
they are
um it's done by trial and error usually
after other things have failed the
addiction rate is not ubiquitous as
people try to say the the likelihood in
this is in the CDC guidelines
um and we've been saying this since 1987
that your likelihood of becoming
addicted to opioids for chronic
therapies five to ten percent it's not
ubiquitous when we prescribe it for
acute care it's like one tenth of a
percent so
we really need to be careful that we
don't blow that out of proportion with
that said we argued way back when that
this is an okay therapy for some people
not everybody
I won't go into great detail about how
that led to an opioid crisis because I
think it's Way Beyond the discussion
here but what I do remember and I I go
to lots of meetings for lots of
therapies and whenever I go to a meeting
everybody tells me that their therapy is
the best and everybody else stinks what
I've come to understand is that that's
that nobody has got the universal
solution for pain that everything has
value and that we've known since the mid
80s that integrative care works the best
what bothered me in hearing this
testimony was the belief that cannabis
has the Ability Beyond its abilities
that everything else does not have and
we know that that's not true we know
there's some people for Canada Cannabis
works really well we know for some
people it's a really rotten modality and
we need to be very careful I don't
personally believe it should ever be a
first line therapy I think you should
exhaust other things and if you look at
my book which one of our kind members
agreed to buy which I would have handed
to him if he wanted but this whole
chapter on how I think we as a society
should use medicinal cannabis as opposed
to recreational Cannabis with that said
the problem that I have with this bill
would I still will vote for it because I
do believe that doctors and patients
have the rights to make the decisions
without Society telling what to do but I
would argue vehemently to any doctor
that if that's the first thing that you
think about then that's a problem there
is a problem with cannabis Addiction in
this society that is totally
underreported
cannabis creates a whole bunch of other
problems that we know it creates motor
impairment it creates
um a tendency towards schizophrenia and
young people the nice thing in my NFL
Pain Group we I'm blessed to have two
experts on cannabis not just one one's
an international expert the other one's
actually a childhood psychiatrist and
we've argued vehemently and we've argued
this with the players that if you're
under 25 and you're not neurologically
developed this is not a good option for
you there are some exceptions
that's my point of view and I'm standing
up for the rights of the people I
represent on the New Hampshire pain
collaborative because right now we're
seeing thousands of people yearly all
over the country being killed by
indiscriminate public policies that are
not looking at their needs and looking
at broad-based policies they're based
more on myth and fantasy that's all I
got to say thank you of the discussion
hearing saying none I'll ask Clark to
call the wall
motion is ought to pass on HP 611
who made the motion seconded motion was
made by uh second was made by
representative Weber
and I made the motion thank you
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative cofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative Nagel yes oh you said yes
okay I'm sorry didn't hear you
representative Melvin yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro
pardon me but I'm not sure which which
um Bill we're voting on it's 11 11. yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes
and represent McDonald yes
20-0
okay without objection we'll put that on
consent
okay now we can return to HB 325
and consider uh an amendment if Mr if
representative Merchant would like to
make a motion thank you Mr chair I make
a motion to pass
House Bill sorry house amendment to
House Bill 325 the amendment reads zero
four three one h
okay is there a second
I representative lay on second so
representative merchant do you want to
speak to your motion
yes
we heard
at least I was informed and it was a
wise informed information if you will
that the way the bill was originally
written
there is no expiration to how long you
stay on the board after their term
expired they could actually take it to
the grade with them quite frankly that
was never the intent of my bill so by
working with some stakeholders I was
able to come up with a reasonable
compromise to make it six months after
the term expires that therefore that's
the reason for the bill for the
amendment to the bill
thank you
of the discussion
representative McLean yeah thank you Mr
chair
um you know having looked at the bill
again
um I really think that the five years
I think gives you enough of a window to
see that the term is going to be coming
to an end and I don't think that there's
any other board that makes this kind of
provision so in this case I will be
voting against this bill
and against the amendment I was talking
about the amendment right now the
amendment yes thank you Mr chair thank
you
um
representative uh Merchant speak there
please I initially thought that too and
I was on the Board of Pharmacy we
actually had members on the board that
term would expire and they would stay on
the board which I don't understand how
they did it because according to what I
read there was no RSA to allow for it
but they did
and what I caught my attention is no one
pays attention to reappointing somebody
to a board until it's time to to do it
and the windows up happening is a lot of
times people get caught by off guard so
all of a sudden the term comes up and
someone goes oh
who's going to be the next person in
line and it's like everything else in
life we're very busy
we lose track of time and it's not until
all sudden the term is going to expire
sometimes literally on the day in which
it's going to be expired someone
responds to it so I understand when
you're coming from representative but
the reality is human behavior being what
it is people don't always look down a
road five years out and saying we have
to take care of the term at that point
in time it doesn't happen until all of a
sudden has to be taken care of
it was to respond yes uh thank you for
the clarification representative
Merchant I I think though that would
probably be the same situation for many
boards so I think maybe a better
approach Michael to be back and look at
a more systemic approach than than just
a piecemeal but I appreciate where
you're coming from I totally agree with
that unfortunately
um
I couldn't tackle the whole lotion I
only could take care of the pond
representative Weber
I was just going to say that if you um
really want it to to be a shorter term
duration thing
my suggestion would be to vote in favor
of the amendment because it makes it
considerably shorter than the original
Bill did and then by all means vote
against the bill when it's ought to pass
is amended but that's just a tactical
consideration and it's entirely for you
point taken thank you representative
Weber
of the discussion
seeing none I don't see any okay that's
the book to call the wall on the
amendment to House Bill 325 which is
again zero four three one h
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter up them yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative long yes
and represent McDonald yes 20-0
that brings us to house bill 325. that
was only the amendment right right oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm okay I'm
forgetting which Bill I'm on my apology
representative Mr chair will make a
motion ought to pass as amended
okay representative Merchant moves out
to pass is amended on House Bill 325 is
there a second
representative Palmer seconds
any discussion representative merchant
do you want to speak to your
to your um
motion
is calling me today thank you Mr chair
I totally agree with comments made
earlier about the um
advisory Council being only one of the
councils one of the boards if you will
that this bill deals with the reality is
that it would be nice if we could do
this for all the boards uh but right now
that's not an option on the table
because it's just too much of a lift
but also knowing human be human behavior
being what it is
people don't respond to things until
deadlines approach and unfortunately
deadlines come and go and then all of a
sudden you have a council that doesn't
have particularly in this particular
case
it's a multi-disciplinary council with
um people from Dentistry medicine nurse
practitioners law enforcement Attorney
General's office and so forth when you
lose that voice this of one particular
member of the council that voice has
gone for a long period of time and it
becomes very valuable to maintain that
we have all the stakeholders around the
table with the council and this allows
for that to happen it doesn't go on
indefinitely it does allow for at least
a period of time for people to respond
to the last minute nature we all face
okay any other discussion
let me see no other discussion
okay the clerk was ready I would ask him
to call of all ought to pass is amended
on House Bill 325. representative Leon
yes representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Melvin yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
represent representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
long yes
and representative McDonald yes
19-1
okay consent any objection to putting
that on the consent
no objections thank you
okay and um Now we move down to HP 610
for which we have an amendment uh
representative Merchant
um you wish to speak you used to make
motion I'll make a motion to pass
amendment
0471 to house bill 610.
is there a second
okay representative Murphy seconds
representative merchant do you wish to
speak to your motion
yes we heard during
testimony about the importance of having
a provider who has
experience and knowledge in Pediatric
Care
we recognize at that point in time
limiting that to a pediatrician which is
obviously a physician who specializes in
Pediatric Care
is quite honor some patience
particularly those in the North country
and people in rural parts of America so
recognizing the importance of having
someone with knowledge in pediatric care
we changed the wording in the amendment
to read basically a provider who
provides pediatric care so it could be a
nurse practitioner it could be a family
practice physician it could be somebody
who's providing pediatric care who
therefore has knowledge in that space to
be the second
certifying physician or provider if you
will who has knowledge for the for the
miners so we're still recognizing the
importance of having somebody with
knowledge with minors but not limiting
it to a pediatrician only
thank you of the discussion
so you know other discussion
clerk is ready I will ask him to call
the wall motion is ought to pass
an amendment
zero four seven one H to a house bill
610 FN
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofault yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
representative Melvin yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative long yes and
representative McDonald yes
20 to zero
how about representative Cannon
I'd like to make a motion to pass House
Bill 610
um
with amendment0471h
ought to pass thank you representative
Cannon is there a second
second representative Weber seconds
representative Canon do you wish to
speak to your motion
I think I think I think we've had enough
okay
all right is there any other discussion
or any discussion
if none I will entertain
um I will proceed and ask for the Clark
to call the ball the motion is ought to
pass is amended on House Bill 610.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Copo yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yep
representative Melvin
yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes representative long yes
and representative McDonald yes
20-0
okay without objection if there is no
objection we will put that on the
consent calendar
okay are we um Vice chairman and I had
collaborated or consulted with the
ranking member and the given time
constraints or experiencing today we
know people have
places they need to be so we decided
that's where we would conclude the
executive session today
431 I it's my understanding we're going
to continue that
so Bill uh the following bills 582
454 and 323
I would continue until March 8th next
week we have two session days that would
conflict with us meeting
we do have we are scheduled to meet
tomorrow and we have a full day of
hearings
we do we are not scheduled to meet next
week as a committee because again the
speaker has told us likely and I assume
it it sounds like it's a virtual
certainty at this point that it's going
to be a session day on Wednesday and
also uh and it's already scheduled for
Thursday and in both days are long days
oh that's being continued to March 8th
we have a little breathing room because
the we are now through the early bills
and the next deadline is March 16th
any other questions
seeing none I will see you tomorrow
morning at nine o'clock thank you all
very much